the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club inconceivable moves led to
miraculous results at the US Women's and
US Open championships in St Louis
players were ready to storm the castle
and get back to hunting Kings following
the rest day the man in Black Fabiano
Carana took no prisoners outd dueling
his opponent with the black pieces to
remain in clear first the women's
leaders seemed out for vengeance with
both winning to remain tied at the top
of the standings looking for the perfect
marriage of giant clashes daring escapes
and phenomenal chess As You Wish day six
of by the book chess coming up
[Music]
next
welcome back chess fans to day six of
the US Chess Championship and US Women's
chess Championships held here at the St
Lou chess club we start today in the St
Louis chess club as we are waiting for
the players to arrive at the world just
Hall of Fame where the games are being
played it's been an incredible event so
far a lot of fighting Spirit a lot of
toughy Turvy games let's see what today
is going to bring let's go to the studio
and start the
action welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the US and US
Women's chess championships past
champions are surging towards the top as
round six is about to
begin
hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us I'm kinaa and I'm here with
yaser Sahan Kate a pleasure always a
pleasure to be with you here in studio
calling the action fantastic round
yesterday so many decisive games
tactical end games wonderful absolutely
hello everyone and Welcome to our show
the
2023 US championships are in full swing
my goodness 10 of the 12 games played
yesterday were decisive what will today
bring well let's pay attention to our
broadcast Kate do the honors what tell
us about the standings let's begin with
the ladies please so let's take a look
the standings after round five we have
two leaders Karissa and beim toir janova
who are having a fantastic tournament so
far with four points out of five then we
have a sole third Placer Arena crash
with three and a half points and a bunch
of players with two and 1 half points
behind real separation the top there you
see those three players they looking
pole position and tell us about the open
in the open section we have a soulle
leader Fabiano Carana just cruising
through the tournament so far four out
of five then we have second Placer Hans
Neiman who is also having a fantastic
tournament amazing win yesterday three
and a half points and then a two-way tie
for the third place wesa and Lenard guas
with three points and for these national
championships tell us about the format
the format is 22 player round Robins
which means each player plays everybody
else in their respective section the
time control is 90 minutes for first 40
moves followed by 30 minutes for rest of
the game and there is a 30 second
increment from move one players are not
allowed to offer draw to agree on draw
so there are real battles on the board
and we have a traditional schol scoring
system one point for win half a point
for a draw and zero points for loss as
we approach the halfway points of the
tournaments tell us about the schedule
the schedule is very simple today we
have round six the coverage always
starts at 1:20 p.m. Center time then two
more rounds and another rest day then
three rounds and if necessary we will
have playoffs on Wednesday October 18th
absolutely wonderful thank you Kate and
Christian I tell you what what around
yesterday day was drill down tell us
more about the leaders good to see good
to see you guys absolutely incredible
round yesterday but I have to say it's
all these styles of play that the
players are bringing to the table as
well that amazed me I have to say that
game between Fabiano and darus a couple
of rounds ago that endgame Mastery just
absolutely incredible and yesterday that
Rook takes F7 Rook sacrifice of Ray
Robson to finally get his first victory
that was really cool to see as well but
let's take a look at our leaders and
where they stand and how they got to
where they are entering round six we're
going to start with the ladies section
and of course one of the co-leaders is
international Master Karis a with a
score of four points out of five
possible and as you can see unblemished
record up to this point a couple of
draws in round one and four and after
that just incredible victories a couple
of them in the Kings Indian defense I
have to say she's been spectacular with
the black pieces and let's see uh where
she actually in history won her national
championship and as you can see in 2021
she took that National Title second
place in 2020 she's bringing a bag of
experience at such a young age but of
course this is a very tight race because
the co-leader in the l section is beim
toir jonova also with a score of four
out of five and an identical line score
to Karissa Yip as you can see one draw
in round number one and actually the
second draw in round four it was against
Karissa in rounds two three and
yesterday just incredible dominating
victory for beim and let's see what are
her best finishes she only started
playing the US W championships a couple
of years ago actually 2021 was her first
participation and she took second place
behind Karissa take a look at that and
there she is she's getting ready for
this very important match up yester
yesterday against Cervantes I have to
say she was quite dominant very good
opening play and very good Mastery of
the middle game situation as well and
what do we have in the open section we
have a single leader as we are entering
round six Fabiano Carana just simply
dominating spectacular chess up to this
point four points out of five he started
off slowly with a couple of draws in
rounds one and two but the hattrick
after that absolutely spectacular and
what a game yesterday against Andrew
Tang he knew he needed that Victory to
stay ahead in the standings because also
Hans Neeman is still closely behind him
but let's take a look at uh his best
finishes at the US Championship first
place 2022 he is the defending champion
he also won a national championship in
2016 immediately after switching
federations and coming back to the
United States and right now he's looking
for his third National Championship as
you can see he's cool calm and collected
he's arriving couple of minutes before
the round he's been very professional
this year and things have been paying
off for him he's been having a
spectacular year qualified for the
candidates W in 2022 the US championship
and he's close to 2800 once again guys
he's over
2790 F rating and that's a very
important step for him I know personally
he really wants to touch that 2800
barrier once again but I have to say
guys everybody has been bringing their
aame into this national championships
we've had a lot of decisive games as we
can see we started off slowly with uh
one decisive result a piece in round
number one in both championships after
that going all the way to round five 10
decisive results out of 12 that was the
day after the rest day you no they came
with Renewed Energy and renewed will to
win their respective games just
incredible chess up to this point I'm I
cannot wait to see what these players
are going to bring to the TBL today to
for me it's Fab's accuracy as well
incredible he has the number of mistakes
he's made Kate very very very SM tell us
about the pairings for today what can
our viewers expect let's start with the
ladies uh for round six so we have
asaran who scored her first draw in the
tournament in the previous round and
she's immediately getting challenged by
yib the co- leader of the women's
section who happens to have a black
magic thing going with the black pieces
Chris has scored a lot then we have
cantes playing abrahamian bashian
challenging another co- leader toir
jonova then we have the former US
Women's Champion Pita challenging the
current US junior girls Champion Lee uh
who we thought coming in the tournament
was a favorite that's a big matchup then
we have another former Women's Champions
zatonski playing you and Yan playing
against Crush arena in third place
looking to uh increase her Point totals
and in the open section pairings there
here we have the boss Carana playing
saan who who has a solid tournament at
50% right now then shankland playing SCH
then we have two very well theoretically
prepared players but who have a very
contrasting style Mishra who is very
young playing very fast and Domingas
playing a little slow yeah but they're
somehow suited for one another then we
have aronian playing so then we have the
two former US Junior Champions Jean
playing nean that's going to be another
big match of today and then tank who
suffered a tough loss yesterday against
Robson who had a brilliant game um
yesterday winning uh his first game yeah
that Rook takes F7 Masterpiece for the
ages as the play is underway we're just
going to go back to the playing Hall as
we have a lovely shot there of beum one
of our tournament co-leaders up against
atusa with the black pieces what do we
have in I think that's one E4 in that
one but you mentioned that Sam Sean is
only on 50% and uh that was a bit
striking to me because he could have
easily been on plus two let's not forget
he started with a victory and he was
completely winning against Hans nean he
should have never lost that game
unfortunately for him he did lose that
game mostly due to uh time trouble uh
problems that he had but I have to say
he's been uh having a good year he won
the chess 9el tournament that was his
first major tournament Victory among the
elites and that definitely him a boost
of confidence so this game between
Fabiano and Sam Sean is going to be a b
burner as well absolutely uh we see E4
E5 in uh beam's game uh remembering that
she defended the black side of a scotch
against Karissa Knight C6 D4 and we'll
see just stay with it for just a moment
I don't think we're going to see D4 but
will we see uh Joko piano or or the R
Lopez Ru Lopez classical Ru Lopez it is
uh let's go to Carissa's game and that's
a bit of a wrinkle right because I
remember there was a game between atusa
during their m match in the American Cup
where Bean
played the I want to say the Petro
Knight to F6 and she won with the black
pieces so playing two Knight C6 uh
allowing the Lopez is definitely a
wrinkle in her repertoire that maybe
Tusa was not ready and that's why she
hesitated to play that move Bishop to B5
we're going to have to wait and see who
is the better prepared player in that
particular matchup yeah especially if
you were preparing for Petro and you see
kn6 it's a completely different mindset
I wanted to turn our attention to our
other co-leader uh in the Women's
Championship Karissa ashria I and
yesterday I got tasered by uh Christian
because I've been playing the perk
defense literally my whole life and this
idea that uh after for example hold on
I'm going to do it wrongly apologies
just Bishop F4 Knight F6 that this
position is so Superior for white
because nobody played Bishop F4 they
play Bishop G5 against me they play
Bishop E3 against me but Bishop F4 in
this particular case of today um Karissa
did not develop her night early she's a
faned bishop F to F4 A7 A6 and this has
been in my repertoire well my whole
career and in the Northwest we would
call this the rat uh as a defense and
you know we were talking about Karissa
really enjoying King's Indian defense
right which he doesn't get now because
the pawn is not on C4 but she has the
same or very similar fiano Bishop D6 so
she may be going for a very similar
plans exactly but without the pawn on C4
well it's definitely an Austrian attack
with F2 F4 so A7 A6 Knight F3 B5 on the
board and this is it promises to be a
double-edged game I don't know who's
going to be the better prepared out of
the opening signaling she is going to
fight she's not going to play anything
calm but she's ready to attack exactly
uh do you have any experience with these
lines yourself on either side K yes I do
play E4 so I get these lines very often
right uh I like it for white I played it
a few times with black and I do feel
like it can be sometimes flexible
because you can attack the center with
E5 sometimes C5 okay um so white also
has to be accurate also the pawn on B5
sometimes can push the Knight away and
kind of weaken the E4 Pawn exactly uh
Bishop D3 uh recognizing that B5 B4 is
always a constant threat where the pawn
on e4 could be under attack so Bishop d
D3 on the board Bishop B7 and I would
expect castles um theoretically speaking
uh
Christian does this line have a good
reputation for black or is white it's
it's the modern it's the modern well I
don't know has it become popular there's
no way this has a good reputation
Karissa is just trying to imbalance the
position she's playing against her
opponent her opponent has been
struggling big in this event ashita so
she wants to get her out of the opening
early on she wants to get complicated
imbalances positions and she thinks that
she's the more in shape player but also
in general just a better player and she
will be able to outplay her even if the
engine right now is saying that white
has a pretty decent Advantage close to
one point Advantage but let's move on to
the open section as well and see what's
happening in this big clash between
Fabby and Sam Sean because we have an
English and already maybe a surprise
with this move last move B3 from Fabiano
so we got an English opening take a look
at this this is very typical Knight to
C3 you don't want to exchange the
knights you want to uh withdraw on B6 it
looks like a reversed Sicilian right
Bishop to E7 and now a B3 this is uh one
of the more rare moves in the positions
D3 by far is the main option along side
A3 as well the ideas are that you want
to take space on the queen side mostly
after A3 and B4 and if black tries to
stop you with A5 then you're giving away
a couple of squares especially this uh
Square on a B5 for my knight potentially
to jump there so A3 is one of the main
options and this B3 I've seen it
recently played at the elite level I
don't remember I'm seeing so many games
I don't remember exactly which one it
was but I've seen it played by one of
the strong players maybe it was Magnus U
but definitely with successful results
in this one after B3 already creating
some difficulties for black because my
idea is pretty clear I want to go Bishop
to B2 and I want to put uh as much
pressure on your Pawn on E5 as possible
as early as possible as well so these
are the type of situations that black
has to deal with how are you going to
stop me from putting a lot of pressure
and transferring the Knight quickly on
C5 as well this is another idea behind
getting the bishop out quickly Rook to
C1 Knight to E4 Knight to C C5 these are
the type of Maneuvers that we will be
looking for in this game but once again
it seems like Fabby has been very well
prepared
or what do we see there we see a few
more moves okay we don't have those
moves but we see them on the board
Castle Bishop to B2 and Bishop to B G4
is what I think we
see which has been played is the second
most played move in the position so I'm
expecting both players to still know
what they're doing in this one uh the
other move the main line in the position
is Rook to E8 once again with the aim of
uh supporting the defense of the Pawn on
E5 after the move Bishop to f8 these are
the type of uh plans that we have at our
disposals with both colors but instead
of that Bishop to G4 King H
okay I'm trying to understand what the
idea of this move Bishop to G4 because I
don't think his Bishop takes F3
just giving me the light score Bishop
like that I don't think that's a healthy
way of approaching at this position
Knight to E4 maybe F6 maybe wants to
provoke the move H3 and then go back to
E6 I usually see the bishop on E6 that's
why I'm a bit puzzled about this
decision of uh getting the bishop out to
G4 so Sean seems to be comfortable with
it probably analyzed it at home uh he's
not at the board or at least he wasn't
at the board at that particular time he
felt oh there we go we have some more
moves okay these players are playing
fast what do we
have let me just refresh the board as
well see Queen on D7
so C1 and the Queen on D7 light Bishops
I don't have the update on my board me
neither so we're not getting the updates
we will have to look at the cameras Bish
G4 to give us a bird ey bird's eye view
like yourself Bishop G4 for me is a bit
of a surprise I am far more familiar
with F5 to stop the Knight E4 Rook C1
business and the idea is to put the
bishop on F6 and keep an eye a watchful
eye over the D4 Square Bishop B2 Bishop
G4 I'm assuming Rook C1 I think it's
Rook C1 Queen D7 on the board because
this is the main line actually yes okay
and uh here we have to stop and think do
we play the move D2 D3 as a pre lude to
Knight E4 because if I do play the move
Knight E4 there is always this uh chance
that black is ready to play E5 E4 in the
uh subsequent positions so should I be
prepping that move with D2 D3 allowing
Bishop H3 right that's the question
right Knight D4 seems to be the main the
main move okay Knight E4 and again I
sort of want to see the players just
because I have a feeling we are not
getting updates and they're probably
making moves yes exactly as I expected
the Knight is on e4 and the bishop is on
H H yes sorry do we have this right
because if I'm in Fabby shoes I'm ready
to sacrifice The Exchange you know the
the old uh Sicilian wait a minute we do
we do have it right yes yes that's the
position Rook to C1 Queen D7 Knight D4
Bishop H3 so we are being tempted
uh Kate what do you think of these
apples uh let's let's have a look right
first of all we get a massively
important Central Pawn the E5 Pawn we've
messed up Black's queenside structure we
get this
imbalance of um an exchange for well
Knight and pawn but great targets for
White's Knights um none of this will
happen because B Knight to C5 was played
already on the board yes
this has been played before though this
exchange sacrifice right because it
actually hasn't no really no not in this
particular move order I guess and am I
looking something F I'm looking at F5 we
can do but then that gives up yeah the
pawn on C6 and the bishop on E7 is
targeted no no black doesn't have to do
anything drastic after Knight takes C5
just Queen E6 just Queen E6 right right
and this position doesn't seem to be
like
super dominant for white why not I can
also start with C5 in
fact uh
c5h perhaps um trying to give you
another Pawn to exchange some pieces
know I can resist everything that
Temptation oh really oh boy okay C five
okay but they're they're moving fast so
they are let me just refresh what
happened after
uh Bishop G4 Rook C1 Bishop H3 o excuse
me pardon me Bishop H3 Knight C5 on the
board I'm assuming Bishop takes
C5 beened usually recapture that Knight
exactly Rook takes
C5 did he take on G2 I I I don't know
we're not getting uh uh the so maybe
black can play Rook a E8 no E5 is being
hit too too many times so we do have the
exch exchange on C5 and then F6 and by
the way there's an exchange on H3 as
well
okay okay Bishop takes H3 so again this
Rook takes C6 is always on tap but now
that the E5 Pawn is so well defended uh
doesn't seem to be the way to go uh e a
change of directions because interesting
move still following a game right now
actually you want to go Queen B3 check
don't think for a moment that Fab has
blundered his B Pawn he has not follow
inantly came Queen E6 where is gaining
time at this moment they're following a
game between abbasov and Safari from
2014 so quite a long time ago right
almost a decade this is exactly how they
played B4 and queen to E6 which by the
way came instantaneously yes it did by
Sam okay so Sam is basically saying I'm
hitting your A2 Pawn you can go and uh
try to capture my C7 Pawn with the move
B5 and here I pause because I don't
think I want to take on A2 right away I
think I'm going to drop back with the
Knight and then we have a A variation
like this right takes takes B5 is on the
board and uh what do you think of this
position king queen A1 or what would you
do here as
why say maybe Queen A1 cuz if you take
that queen I'm going to recapture with
the rook and The Rook is going to be
active on the a file yeah I was thinking
I was going to drop back with my queen
this way I defend my Pawn on B7 so that
I can play Knight E6 in the very near
future if I can get you know what I mean
my piece was coordinated then the bishop
is actually is for the moment biting on
granite right those two look at that
Bond chain right you don't you don't you
don't have a good view what's the third
iCal evaluation of the position
Christian there's no Theory there's only
one game that game that I just mentioned
and that actually continued like this
Knight to d8 and now not Rook takes C7
but rather Queen to B1 and I'm wondering
if we know that Fabby met abasov along
the way at the World Cup and perhaps has
analyzed his games and maybe he drew
some inspiration from uh that after
watching this particular game both
players seem to know what they're doing
uh Sam is making his moves
instantaneously Fab is kind of trying to
decide maybe he has some other ideas
Queen to B1 once again was the move
played not taking on C7 if you do take
on C7 Queen takes A2 and it seems like
uh black is doing more than fine in the
position in fact slightly better at this
point Queen to A1 or queen to B1 things
of that nature but after Queen to A1 I
don't even have to exchange the queen I
can just simply go back to D5 and now in
the absence of the light score
Bishop beautifully placed Cally placed
on D5 this Knight will be landing on E6
I'm looking at the position I don't see
any problems for black in this
particular iteration so this is what we
have Fabby has the opportunity to defend
this Pawn on A2 and not exchanging and
to be honest it makes a lot of sense
right you don't want to exchange these
pawns because the pawn on A2 is not
necessarily a weakness it can also be an
asset if you start pushing it with A4 A5
later on in the end game The Pawn on C7
a backwards Pawn is kind of a liability
for the moment like the only way that
pawn is going to um be a good Pawn is if
it gets exchanged via C6 right so this
is how I'm looking at the position I'm
seeing Queen B1 Queen C2 is an idea as
well and perhaps the idea of Queen C2 is
that if you take I can start with Rook
to A1 and now you don't have Queen to D5
you have to go either to E6 or to F7
where he's going to get hit by Rook day
C7 a lot of moving Targets in the
position I'm curious to see what fa has
in store for us absolutely like to turn
our attention to the game of Hans Neeman
for just a moment Hans again coming into
move yeah on the board Hans uh coming in
today's round in clear second place he's
had a roller coaster ride getting here
but it's been a successful one and check
this out I mean this has been I've
called this the scotch ending for a long
long time and I would dare tell you that
there have been thousands of games
literally from
this can I describe it as a starting
position because this this seems to have
been played so often well a bit of a
surprise for me Bishop hanss with the
black pieces is making a Gambit of it uh
with the move Bishop G4 of course I
understand that I don't like playing
weakening moves like F2 F3 but it does
come with a Tempo and I do indeed want
your Bishop to go somewhere you can go
back if you like I'll take take and yes
maybe my best move would be to play F3
F2 but in the meanwhile I do have a pawn
in hand and well prove it I believe
during us junior championships one of
the Juniors were saying that Bishop G4
is the most accurate move in this
position right now probably Mishra right
that provides black with more kind of
choices or uh easier ways to equalize
then the recapture on D5 yep modern
engines and look what they're doing
wanted to turn our attention back to the
ladies for a moment in the game of Kiss
Carissa yep because got complicated
there uh well can you say blowed up the
position blow up so when we left it we
had just left it at this position Bishop
B7 it's funny uh when I'm Wide in these
positions I love to play the move A4 I
really do and then after B4 I say well
where are you going so one of the things
I like to do as white is Queen E2 the
idea is just to defend the pawn but
literally uh make a move I'm not saying
this is a good move but the whole idea
behind Queen E2 is in a funny way to
give the Knight a square so that it will
hop out to F2 and then D5 so I like
Queen E2 sha took a completely different
attack very very direct the move E4 E5
now after this move if I'm in a Shri the
shoes I'm going to make a terrible move
for black we understand what she wants
she wants again to play A4 B4 and she's
brought her Knight to a gorgeous Square
in the middle of the board so that's
what E4 E5 is all about it's also
stopping the development of the Knight
on G8 exactly and potentially a nice we
can have some sacrifices even if we push
the pawn more forward E6 E6 so for
example a move like Knight H6 might be
more or less well common a strong but a
move A4 B4 Knight E4 you can see that
this Knight will head to this Square
this Knight is already on a good Square
none of this happened because Karissa
said wait a minute you played E5 I'm
going to break up the team in the middle
of the board I want this bishop to be
active I'll play C5 sh said take take
now in this particular case this move I
just don't like you know when I see this
move I think you I can almost hear this
bishop on G7 so sad he's so sad like oh
and even if we forced an ending with
after Bishop E4 like let's say queen
takes D1 King takes D1 the king will go
here the Knight will go here and and
white can also Target the pawn structure
on the queen side with A4 forcing more
weaknesses exact ision is certainly
advantageous for white exactly black has
no fun Carissa says well I'm going to
sacrifice the pawn takes on E5 no can do
castles and asria is essentially a
banking on some types of kingside
attacks here half openen
file what do you think uh are you fan so
Knight F6 is very logical logical move
to make here sure and now I I feel like
my pieces are almost already developed
if I have something quick here um well
let let me just complete the rest of
your development for you Queen then Rook
D1 Rook D1 no no I don't know I like
Rook D1 okay because I also like Rook D
Rook E1 I couldn't make up my mind uh on
on that score either so let's say Knight
D7 I I definitely don't want to get hit
with a nasty discovery
um feels like White's position is
slightly better here yeah it does I I'm
I'm just having a little trouble because
uh once I play the move Rook E1 then I
can kind of feel like okay I'm going to
go Knight G5 or Knight E5 or queen H4 uh
kind of going all in um I'm not sure if
any of this is theoretical or not uh are
we following any games uh not anymore so
Castle was the novelty just giving up
the pawn like this with the move Castle
is a novelty F C5 was played before uh
the most times and after Knight to D7
you even have ideas of at some point
playing the move E6 and sacrificing it
like that what Kate wanted to do yeah sa
at least destroy Black's Pawn structure
on the king side right if you really
want to do it Bishop to E4 is one of the
moves as well Bishop to F4 and E6 those
are the three moves in the position not
castle castle is a novelty and she
played it after after a three minute
thinking Karissa she's not shying away
from any sort of challenges we've seen
that I mean she played the Kings Indian
three times in a row with the black
pieces that's quite courageous
absolutely I wouldn't say it's a dubious
opening the Kings Indian but at the same
time you might get some uh dangerous
position right it's a very risky opening
and that's what she's doing she's just
employing risky openings because she
wants to get victories and it's been
working out so far for her right now
she's a pawn up but there is a lot of
compensation we understand that right
take a look at uh these two ladies by
the way uh if we look at the standings
they're on opposite sides of this table
as you can see Carissa in first position
Four Points ashita just scored her first
half a point in yesterday's game I have
to say she's been having a miserable
event up to this point what was
extraordinary about that of course is
that shria just as you said uh losing
all of her games made the only
draw of the round uh talk about the
current position e e uh e takes F4 we're
expecting Bishop takes F4 right right
Knight F6 you have to Castle fast right
if you don't Castle you're going to get
under a tremendous pressure in the
center maybe we made a mistake with
Queen E2 how about Queen
D2 I wouldn't go Queen D2 I want to go
Bishop H6 but
me there position I don't well wow
objection Castle do you want to go here
yes I think this is too slow how do you
Checkmate me at some point I can even
just stay and go for the pawn or go for
the pawn with Queen D4 if I want to or
wait for you to take on G7 but let's go
for the pawn um do you want to go back
on E3 you just came from E3 doesn't make
a lot of sense right I want to come back
to what we wanted to play in the first
place let's go Queen E2 instead of Queen
D2 Queen E2 okay okay so you take Knight
F6 and now Queen to E2 right you can
also go Queen E1 I mean this is a very
typical way especially in the Grand Prix
type setups whenever you open up this
diagonal with a move F4 to go to H4 it
makes sense right okay I think it's an
improved version uh compared to queen to
E2 and then you go Rook to D1 at least
you're hitting the queen somehow Queen
on d8 Castle let's say Rook to D1 where
do you put the queen C8 let's say just
oh wait a minute E7 you're giving me the
pawn back
no no no no C5 is not hanging right not
yet also I can just reinforce my C5
first with B4 and then threaten take on
E7 how do you defend against Knight C6
iel Knight to C6 makes a lot of sense
let's defend
this P crickets and by the way yeah I
think we've been saying that white is a
pwn out white is not a pawn no no it's
even P No in fact it was uhria that
didn't Capt on E5 she would have been
Pawn up yeah okay we'll definitely keep
an eye on que to H4 is coming I like
what's how the position is looking for
uh White from a visual perspective but
at the same time it remains very
balanced very very complex position if
your attack on the king side doesn't
succeed my Pawn structure is very
healthy as black my Bishops I mean look
at them they're cutting the board in
half so definitely also a lot of Trumps
from a perspective in this one exactly
uh two uh great Champions I wanted to
turn our attention to the game between
Anna zansi and Jennifer Yu the defending
Champion I mean you would have thought
that this was a huge game for these two
ladies of course it is but Jennifer
having a difficult tournament after five
rounds but yesterday scoring an
important win yes against Nasi yeah that
was great uh for Jennifer Knight C3 and
you know we only just seen just just a
few moves it's because Anna went into a
big
tank think after this not unexpected for
her she she gets to spend a lot of time
in her openings a little twist on this
uh one because well uh after the move
Bishop B4 Anna played the move Queen B3
which is kind of a an interesting moment
uh there's a for for for me there's a
little bit of a logic glitch here if
you're going to play Queen out and
develop the queen right it seems to me
like you would want to force your
opponent to essentially now you can't
counter in the center with Knight with
C7 C5 because your Knight's in the way
right so if I go Queen B3 immediately
the problem I have with the move Queen
B3 is C5 now well you were attacking my
Bishop I defended my Bishop now I can go
Knight C6 and almost in a reversal of
the game between uh Arena crush and
an in the previous round exactly we get
uh something where okay Knight D4 is a
Potential Threat okay can always win my
Pawn back with Bishop takes C5 and D
takes C5 and of course we're in
theoretical territory you don't play
Four moves if with Queen's Gambit uh
declined and not be in a in in in
theoretical grounds is Queen B3 a
popular move uh Christian it's not so
popular obviously I me only 30 games
have been played with Queen to B3 but
it's a move has definitely been played
and at the top level as well um we can
see a couple of grand Masters already in
the first uh few games displayed there
so que to B3 definitely asking some
questions and I think it accomplishes
what Anna um was intending to accomplish
with this move Queen to B3 get Jennifer
out of theory she probably did not
expect this move Bishop to B4
as we see that Jennifer did not respond
with C5 she hasn't responded
oh yes yes no C5 is of course the main
move in position Knight to C6 I don't
like this too much no because now you've
put your knight I was going Queen A4
check in order to force the Knight to C6
now you've voluntarily accepted
absolutely that the Knight and with a
queen on B3 this is definitely a better
placement right so I can always go
Knight to F3 and I just simply think I
have have a better position than
compared to the usual Nimo with Knight
F6 que to A4 ideas right right exactly
uh also I just wanted to check in on uh
my pick to see how Alice Lee is doing in
her game against Nasi and it started out
as a um slav uh not the Moran I actually
uh give uh anat karpov the credit for
really making this setup with white the
queen on C2 the F and cetto so I'll call
this the carp off variation and I think
deservedly so E4 on the board takes
takes takes Knight F6 Queen C2
C5 Rook B1 I like this move Bishop E4
that's forcing the queen to go to the
back rank yeah well oh Queen D2 queen2
the idea is you know it's
funny when you look at this very this
position for just a moment you know
that's a nice diagonal right it's kind
of nice but in truth you don't really
get you know good value out of that
diagonal conversely this takes and queen
C3 sometimes you see Black's King coming
under pressure I like the move Bishop E4
because in some variations it's really
nice you know like to be able to put our
Bishop in front of the king queen D2 and
I'm assuming Queen E7 on the board not
yet
uh by the way Nasi is 1 hour 34 minutes
she's playing very fast snapping out
these moves uh with with um the battery
on the defile I if I'm in alysis shoes
Queen E7 uh prepping Rook D to d8 if you
take the bishop takes uh you're quick
assessment I don't know I'm kind of
surprised still by Queen D2 I thought we
want to keep maybe that file open okay
you expected I thought maybe Queen C1
but I understand that that's kind of the
queen is also Under The Rook there can
be some B5 stuff in the um near future
from black side B4 B5 here I mean again
it it's off the Beaten Track but here at
least you can understand uh my point
that okay you could play H6 it's not
like you're really afraid if Bishop
takes F6 anyway but just the bishop
makes that extra guarding of the black
king But to answer your question I do
like White's position I like that the C4
and D4 those pawns are in the center I
mean all the pieces have good squares
maybe we can even play Rook e one at
some moment right there's nothing wrong
with White's position and conversely
though on the other hand same is true of
black black has per share of the center
good development for pieces like you put
the bishop on
C5 you know what I mean you know you're
kind of eyeballing the F2 Square maybe
even Bishop B4 on a good day the Knight
looks good Queen looks good I think the
bishop does a really good job on e4
because sometimes when the bishop is on
B7 we play this
D5 sacrifice yeah that's very annoying
uh absolutely so we'll keep an eye on uh
on this one and why is this such an
important game for these two ladies
we'll take a look at the they're both
tied for fourth and they need to join
that the pack right theyy to catch up
with Karissa begim and Arena who are
just like so far playing really well in
the tournament yeah a draw doesn't
really help either of their causes but
uh Christian over to you and uh what's
caught your eye I'm looking at this game
of Bobby versus Sam S our leader in the
open section because Queen to C2 just
threw a Gauntlet at Sam because Sam
right now he's been thinking for close
to 20 minutes 20 close to 20 minutes yes
yes he had more than an hour and 30
minutes when we got to this position
because he was just blitzing out his
moves and right now Queen to C2 has
surprised him has took him out of theory
definitely uh after Queen to C2 you
don't want to take the pawn on A2 makes
a lot of sense you look at the position
hey why don't I take the pawn on A2 we
exchange the pawns on C7 things are
going to be fine for black but guess
what after
D4 yes D4 is not Rook A1 not Rook to A1
D4 is a very powerful decision in this
one and I'm sure Fabian knows it because
he's been blitzing out his moves if you
take take Knight to E6 things are
looking good for black right I got my
knight out if we exchange and you take
on C7 maybe I go Rook to C8 exchange
some more pieces we're going to soon
right easy draw right there's no reason
for white to be better but take a look
at this out of nowhere this Rook swings
on the other side couples with the
action of the queen on C2 to attack on
H7 and this creates a lot of problems
for Black's position you have to go G6
there's no other way to defend it G6
Knight takes E6 you take back you
probably don't want to take on H5 and
allow I mean this looks pretty bad right
Knight takes f8 first of all but also a
lot of other things maybe even Knight to
G5 ideas at some point so not
immediately you have to take back right
but then I just simply go back to C5 I
will regain my Pawn on C7 and then then
this bishop now that the pawn is on G6
is going to have such a wonderful life
for the remainder of the game because
I'm going to go E3 I'm going to plant
this bishop on D4 in the middle of the
board and then your king is going to be
unsafe for the remainder of the game so
this one is looking really good for
white despite the minimal advantage that
uh the engine is saying 0.3 I believe
it's much more than that from a
practical perspective so I don't advise
Queen T A2 I think C6 has to be played
in this position and it makes some sense
if you look at it but it's not an easy
move to make because you start seeing
ideas such as Bishop to A3 now you can
take sure but if you take Rook takes B5
then Rook to C1 I'm getting both uh of
these open files the B semi open file
and the C open files for my pieces it
feels like I have the initiative as
white but C6 has to be played so right
now this is exactly what Sam is trying
to figure out can I take the pawn on A2
maybe he's looking at Rook takes C7 he
might get tempted by that don't touch
the pawn on A2 because you know D4 is
coming and the pressure is going to be
on go C6 try to keep the position and um
tense after the move C6 don't take the
pawn on A2 uh quick question for you uh
in the current position and I understand
everything you're saying about Queen A2
and D4 that's really remarkable cuz I
thought already Rook A1 was better
wasn't touching the pawn on A2 I was
thinking about
A7 A6 okay so the idea there is quite
simple again if you take once again yeah
if you take on C7 I was going to take on
B5 and you know my Rook is open and
maybe on a good day the Knight can sink
in on C4 even this is not that good for
for black it seems like also after D4
this D4 is just such a strong move to
try to break in in the center and open
up the bishop and a good a good get a
good Square for the Knight on F3 that's
right the thing is after D4 you usually
have to respond with E4 right well
exactly hold on but no no no no no no no
no you you you you go ahead and play D
should we continue yes no no no uh you
go ahead and play D4 yes uh because I'm
playing for a light Square uh game okay
sorry uh I wanted you to play Rook tap
so let's say I take on C7
C I wanted to play Knight D5 Knight D5 a
Tempo Against The Rook like your Rook
has to go away right go back and now E4
and now e and then I was thinking if I
can get a light Square uh complex you
know going I but I think sometimes you
have to be also careful about Queen B3
do you get it in time exactly and that's
the problem because of Queen to B3 so
I'm going to go Knight to H4 how do you
cement your uh system on the light
squares Knight C6 Rook to d8 that would
be ideal right uh
right I hold on just a second I was not
that easy yeah I was looking more like a
knight F7 uh then Knight C6 but but
that's just going to allow me to be a
pawn up after que3 right I'm going to
take on B5 I'm going to be a pawn up
maybe you have some strategical
compensation but it's not with this this
beautiful Knight on D5 yeah but that's
that's about it d8
B6 I don't think he wants to go for it
wow
uh but these ideas certainly should be
going through his mind again a big
Advantage for white here Rook Rook d i i
i well well if we continue because I
have played these positions in my
practice a lot Rook takes B5 if you
don't mind B7
B6 and this Knight on D5 but I'm kicking
it the way yeah that's if you're kicking
it away knight3 and actually yeah I'm
just not getting KN D6 that's the
problem that's the problem Knight D6 you
cannot do that because you lose the
Knight on D5 huh I just some timing
issue there so A7 A6 uh was appealing so
but that's again that's what you're
feeling like playing right and it makes
a lot of sense if you don't see all of
these variations and they're not easy
variations to see also they're not easy
to assess at the end of no no you have
to judge them at the end of the we were
two moves away from White being
completely winning and you were saying
that black is fine with the Knight on D5
right right from afar it's even more
difficult to assess that so a lot of
practical one more thing can I play Rook
F7 just give up that pawn if you want to
take it again D4 I'm not he not that's
the key move I'm not taking no no no cuz
you'll always play Queen A2 at the
because I developed in Rook C8 with
Tempo can we just take a look at that if
after Rook F7 Rook takes C7 instead sure
yes is it Rook takes C7 but you catch my
queen right yeah yeah you trap it right
that would be nice ah
I see what you were trying to do yes
very good tempting tempting I'm not
going to take it no no no um but the
problem is this take a look at this
still looks decent right no D5 guess
what D5 is coming in the position you go
here now my knight gets into play and
your pieces are very awkward yeah no
this is easy Advantage White Queen D6 or
queen D7 I pick up at some point the
pawn on e4 I'm I'm going to be fine with
white actually I'm just simply much
better uh apologies again Christian
because I I really I want to pursue A6
one more time okay A6 one more time go
ahead and play D4 for just a second I'll
take on B5 I open up my Rook you'll take
on E5 I'll play C7 C6 okay so you want
this type of and now you take on F6 I'll
take on F6 you're getting mated yes I'm
getting some some some Maids coming
along am I get if I getting made it
because again I was trying for Rook
takes A2 that's and Knight to
D5 uh and I thought I'd be be great what
is what's going on Queen G7 Queen G7 now
I go back again your king is extremely
weak really obviously I I I took big
risk on the queen side yeah not not good
not good enough no okay you but uh for
Sam this game is so crucial obviously
he's he's out of the pack he wants to
get back in and if he manages to score
half a point or win maybe it's really
going to increase his chances and he's
going to get already to tie for third or
second place exactly and uh and last
look at the uh the game of our
tournament leader
uh
say is not our tournament leader Hans
Neeman I wanted to ask uh about this uh
Pon sacrifice uh Christian that that uh
Hans is assessing um
Kate had said that the Juniors
considered the move Bishop G4 actually a
very good and very decent Pawn sacrifice
for equality is that the case well it's
not really a pawn sacrifice right you
get you are getting the pawn back first
of all you can get it right now after
Queen takes C6 you can even delay that
with the move a bishop to G6 this is
just something that the new engines are
basically trying uh to uncover in this
position that's so well known right and
it has been played so many times
C takes D5 right that's the scotch
ending that I I mean you have Queen to
F3 right now you have Bishop to G5
Jeffrey has been playing these type of
positions he seems to be enjoying this
very minimal because it is a very
minimal Advantage right it's not much
but Bishop to G4 is a move that tries to
kill this position basically kill this
whole line right I'm saying I'm going to
exchange everything I've memorized the
engine suggestions and I'm going to be
able to defend that position and in fact
your Trump is you have the two Bishops
right right and that's G6 that's it
you're not no longer having the two
Bishops because I don't see a good way
to uh avoid this exchange you cannot
move the bishop away to B5 because you
lose on C2 so Bishop to G6 was played
this is by the way some sort of a theory
in this position Hikaru has played it
with Duda the problem is I'm seeing a
lot of draws a lot of draws
predominantly draws but I'm also
sprinkled somewhere here and there
couple of Victories for white as well I
don't see any wins for black so this
position after Bishop to G6 Rook to B3
seems to be the option Bishop to B2 is
an option as well Queen takes C6 and
maybe this is a way to try to get out of
this Bishops this is not enough take
take Rook C3 you're going to take on C7
but again it's one of those positions in
which at some point I'm going to be able
to exchange one of your Bishops it
doesn't seem like enough feels Min it
feels very minimal right the bishop
comes back to E6 this Knight will jump
to B4 I have enough activity to not have
to worry too much and by the way
unfortunately you cannot stay active
with a move Rook to B7 because of Bishop
to C8 that's that traps you so very
interesting decision I have to say for
Hans uh but also you know maybe Jeffrey
is not that upset with a draw he's been
having a difficult event so far he just
lost a couple of games in a row against
Fabiano and against R maybe he's just
trying to as we say stop the bleeding
and take a draw in this one don't take
any chances and uh try to start a new
tournament by the way Rook B3 uh as you
suggested in this game Kate where would
you like uh to take us uh I want to take
a look around all the games in the open
section and that maybe do the same in
the women's one one game we didn't check
in was the game between Mishra and uh
lener The Young and the experienced
theoretician exactly we do have a Joko
piano and you were mentioning that
Mishra plays very quickly lanir very
slowly and I was saying they make a
perfect match for one another night here
it looks different Mish is actually
spending time while Dominguez it's
playing is playing immediately I was
about to say um almost a 1 hour 30
minutes or 29 minutes for laner means to
my ey to to my mind uh all prep for
lanir is we are just about up to date
and look how quickly everybody is
playing Queen C2 Queen D1 also this move
Queen D1 an indication that Mishra has
been here before uh not offering a Pawn
on B2 which you cannot take right Rook
B1 exactly that's the bishop is actually
not defended usually the bishop is
defended on B6 who put the pawn on C6
right uh from the original position so
sure that would be a skure but in this
position should I take and play Bishop B
three should I play Bishop B3 right away
or should I be at pardon me uh something
like this right so I'm a pawn down as
black that
I've that pawn on A4 can be captured in
the future because white doesn't have a
light Square Bishop so that pawn is
going to be very hardly defended by
white exactly uh feels okay uh there uh
for uh lanir picking up this is Andrew
Tang London yeah well Andrew Kan
prepped uh play the London against uh
just any setup kingside F and Shadow
Queen side F and Shadow put your Bishop
on F4 and let's go but there is a slight
difference right what's the difference
he started with Knight F3 in this one he
started with ah move to Knight F3 yes
not Bishop
F4 he got caught in Bishop F4 yesterday
against Fabby Bish F4 G6 Knight C3 and
that Knight H5 early on yes but now he's
trying to a a little twist wait for
black to show his hands first okay you
play E6 all right now I can go into my
LA and Knight E5 on the board is are we
still in the is no when did we leave
Theory
actually there is still one game never
mind I retract that castle is by far the
main option Knight to E5 is also uh has
been played once long time ago
1981 by that was only yesterday what you
do you know anything about the 1972
world championship match you know right
across the hall there's a World Chess
Hall of Fame they've got an exhibit I
started it you've seen it y yes I know
that I know that hey man I watched the
BBS shows those were great oh man all
right right I was not even an idea back
then oh 95 wasn't even an idea
wow that hurts right we're getting
there oh night C7 been an idea that's
going viral I love that Knight C7 was
played by the way um which shies away
deviates from Knight to D5 which was
played back in your days yes
sir oh Only Yesterday dude Only
Yesterday go on go onor night C7 was
played uh still this is a very very
complex position it doesn't seem like
anything major is happening I understand
white has some presence in the center
and the question is how do you untangle
yeah as black like how D6 you would love
to play it and kick the Knight away
unfortunately you cannot do that for
example D6 is going to be B by Knight C6
that's the type of position that you
don't want to see on the board me
picking up the bishop on E7 and then
playing with a minimal Advantage given
my by my Bishop on F4 with a lot of
targets especially this uh Target on D6
so what you want to do after Castle is
probably first start with Knight D5 kick
the bishop away and then go something
like Rook to C8 get ready for the move
D6 can I suggest B5 B5 that's an option
as well if you talk about untangle I
want to go Queen B6 and D6 that's an
option as well okay it's a minimal
Advantage if anything for white right
this is the London they're just simply
going to play CH but from Andrew's point
of view his play is very easy too and
he's not facing any no more Knight H5
ideas no more complications no more
being lost at move T that's that's all
we
ask right yeah not so much right Kate we
some modest expectations yeah but look
at the time Andrew has 1 hour 20 minutes
and Ray Robson 1 Hour 1 minute well
you're talking about somebody who likes
playing slowly Ray Robson just virtually
any position he's going to consume uh
his clock time we'll keep an eye on that
one we're going to continue very quickly
now we got to pick up the pace a bit
here this time it's leavon aronian
versus Wesley so whoa this is another
one of those Joko pianos that are just
so hard I mean uh to keep track
of what can I say file for the black
Rook you like the Dynamics I like the
static weakness uh for white I like the
like playing against the pawns you like
this Dynamic uh play along the file
we're going to call it
balanced and moving on to Sam shankland
and dynamically equal is uh how that one
goes okay here I kind of like white
again because I just do I I see these
pawns and I see that okay I understand
you you can take and double me up but uh
if it just feels to me that if I can
ever get my knight to C6 we're going to
sign score sheets really really fast and
uh just some weaknesses in on the queen
side and I have to be careful as black
about the pawn on F7 right the Knight on
E5 and the bishop on B3 they're
targeting that pawn so for me it's kind
of difficult as black to maybe develop
Rooks on the you know open file d8 yeah
I mean you would just as you're saying
you'd love to challenge the defile but
uh the moment you do that suddenly this
Rook is overloaded having to defend F7
and d8 um so probably BL has to capture
the bishop because I cannot play F6 that
pawn is pinned takes takes and I'm
looking so I'm I'm hoping I'm I'm using
the B3 Pawn as a lure like you know come
and get me so I'll go Rook fd8 Rook F d8
I will play Knight D4 again my goal was
pretty simple I I want to camp on your
doorstep I want to play my knight on C6
one of these Knights the moment I don't
know okay uh let's just say as Sam's for
choice in this one as we go over to the
ladies and just take a look not too much
has happened unless I I have to refresh
my board or well let's just go through
all the games uh this one is Talia and
I'm tell if I'm in Talia shoes I'm just
feeling like the whole world's against
me just so difficult you have the game
you are playing well but then you're
just not able to converting that in into
full points exactly okay this looks like
a full uh throated uh discussion going
on in a very topical line it's of a
Queen's Gambit accepted well ladies have
been playing it kind of slowly wouldn't
you say they yes Italia has 1 hour 5
minutes whereas tev has 1 hour 13
minutes
okay again uh in these positions Bishop
B7 Bishop A6 has been played and uh The
Rook the half open B file normally
speaking I'm not really seeing uh black
playing for C5 in these positions more
more or less they're just trying to keep
the pawn I'm not very familiar with this
structure but I know tat have been
playing this B5 moves in a lot of very
different versions uh in the D4 opening
Fair uh let's go to R's game uh when we
left it we literally just left it at
these points we were expecting um Queen
E1 Queen D2 I was expecting Queen E2 for
me Queen E2 is the most natural move
here Rook a D1 Knight C6 she didn't Rook
ad I agree with you Rook ad1 sure looks
like a a an obvious uh Tempo uh against
the queen Knight E5 on the board and
this
one seems to invite Queen D4 check and I
I'm a pawn Grabber
Kate warning alert Pawn
grabbing there you go I mean one thing
is POR Pawn grabbing but I'm also
wondering about some Knight H5 stuff oh
excuse me you're much much more
ambitious I was a pawn grabbing and
you're peace
grabbing much more if I force you to
trade the knights on C6 I mean then that
Bishop on C6 is amazing
true it is um I
do well you can go Queen H4 or queen E5
Queen
E5 um strangely enough I'm warming up to
Carissa's position I I like the Bishops
the the black's Bishops on G7 and C6
sure look good uh continuing our quick
look around uh um atusa atusa's Queen on
G4 is ready to attack it's just waiting
for that castle to be played okay uh
beum she played uh not the pet defense
but you know the C4 move atusa played
that I think few rounds back in R Lopez
kind of unexpected Jennifer youu that
was the one where the queen got stuck on
A8 and there was a Pawn on A7 C2 C4 her
go-to weapon against the
uh Ru Lopez Bishop takes C6 check wow
that is a confusing move for me I think
it's a very important one right because
maybe if you recapture with Queen which
I would gladly
do Oh I thought say go ahead go ahead
let me show you what you might have
missed no okay I want to go B5 yes you
did and I was going Pawn captures but
now Knight D4 yes that's right and now
if you capture the pawn on A6 I'm going
to go C6 yes and so because my queen is
hanging I will Retreat the queen and
you'll be a pawn down yes for a very
good Knight on
D4 and that's it that's it but because
my next moves are pretty simple Knight
C3 D3 Bishop E3 so if I go by the way
like Queen A5 and queen takes A6 so
you're trying you're you're you're kind
of uh how do you say reaching hoping to
uh make some compensation yeah I think
it's more hoping I agree hoping uh but
this was a surprise for me that you
would take because it's a pin and why
give up on the pin let's quickly catch
up with the players Queen G4 ata's last
minute she's readying F4 F5 if she can
get in such an action she'll be better
by the way Yer did you notice that
Knight's transfer Knight F6 D7 C5 E6
look at that Knight just getting to the
D4 square is so weak so the Knight
really wants to get there night has been
wondering it's the M Missouri Tiger
variation uh Christian this is what
you're teaching your charges stop it
don't name it a tiger
cation look man you know we can sell
t-shirts Missouri Tiger chess this a
night this is a horsey just jumping
around yeah this is no tiger there's no
tiger going on here man I was trying to
he's trying to help my my ability to
influence just took a a big dive okay
what have you got for us uh Mishra and
uh well first of all um Sam thought for
like 30 minutes he did it was a long
thing and he did play the basetball C6
C6 after which Fabi responded
immediately with the move Bishop to A3
so he still had that in his preparation
he thought for a little bit longer Sam
Dar and played Rook to F7 again the best
move in the position sure
excuse me so this is the position we
have right now after Rook to B1 which I
do believe was the last move and Rook to
D7 we were anticipating something
similar to this right to uh at least
visually it looks good I have everything
active as what The Rook on the B file
The Rook on the C file the bishop on A3
maybe I would like it on the long
diagonal with a long diagonal open up
but for the moment A3 is a good Square
as well what's next though right because
Black's position is also very healthy
you haven't made or created any
weaknesses in your structure C7 no
longer a weakness now C6 ready to be
exchanged I have this beautiful um Pawn
wall on the long diagonal G7 F6 and E5
so what's next as white and I'm only
seeing some ideas related to King G2 try
to improve the position to the Max and
then try to get the H Pawn going down
the board H4 H5 H6 things of of that
nature ultimately my goal is to weaken
your King right if I manage to do uh
that in any way shape or form whether I
uh force you to play the move H6 that's
going to weaken the light squares maybe
I get all the way to H6 that's going to
weaken the long diagonal this is my only
active plan in the meantime black is
going to do his own thing on the queen
side mostly probably take on a B5 if you
do take with a C- Rook then I have a lot
of ideas on the C file even if you don't
take with the c Rook then I can go
Knight C6 and double up on the C file uh
Rook C8 Rook C7 or Rook d8 Rook D7 it
seems like he's focused on the defile
Sam seian that is still I'm looking at
the
position 1 hour and 22 minutes for white
58 minutes for black with a complex
battle brewing in the middle game I have
to say probably Fabby got everything he
wanted out of the opening just a
playable position look you're not
getting an advantage but you're getting
a playable position and then you're
hoping that you will be able to use the
resources at your disposal uh to get a
winning Advantage well it's funny that
you're talking about whites play King G2
ah4 H5 on a good day you but from my
point of view from Sam Sean's point of
view if you make a move go ahead King go
and if I decide okay I would like to uh
graas the initiative I want to play E4
so maybe I should stop you first let's
go de ah just humor me for a second king
G2 E4 Knight has to go probably have to
go through H4 right I'll take on B5 okay
you'll recapture with a rook I don't
know which one let's go with this one
yeah and Knight C6 so I got a fork on
you and I'm thinking in my mind I'm
going to play Rook A8 to d8 I've doubled
up Whit King's a little bit Loosey
Goosey that's not the the the best King
ever Rook d8 Rook A8 right okay by the
way Knight F5 stopped my knight4 that
was a very uh important little point I
wanted to say idea that was my idea and
now the question is it looks coordinated
Black's pieces look pretty good I'm not
sure what the white Rooks on the fifth
rank are doing I mean they look pretty
but I remember some attacking ideas with
Knight H G7 the problem is this I'm
missing this Bish B should be maybe on
A1
A1 would be ideal in this position also
I can defend the pawn on D2 with Bishop
C3 so once again maybe I just have to do
something like this bishop to C1 but
yeah it well it's funny sometimes you
prepare a variation and you get your
preparation at the board and then you
get there and you go well where's my
advantage sometimes it happens yeah I
just don't I I don't think he's looking
for an advantage by the way yeah I I
really don't think he's looking for but
but we'll go back to the starting
position in your move D3 I think that's
actually a superior move just to stop
you know that E4 uh as we prepare for
break I just wanted to again go to the
game of leavon and Wesley because we did
have a a very different approach um
after the move A5 A4 you
know I give you this position Kate right
I give you this position Kate and you
know it's leavon aronian so you know I
got to tell you can't guess the
guy I'm the worst leavon aronian guesser
of all times I will not write his
biography I can tell you that uh I give
you this position as a as a problem and
I say just I'm not asking you for the
best move because I actually have no
idea what the best move is I'm asking
you for your candidate moves and they
would include taking on D4 yeah on D4
because if you recapture I pushed the
pawn maybe before ex uh another
candidate move that you might
say well I'm actually looking at some
somehow B4 could be attractive would
Knight A3 be on your I mean
I I going crazy this is great you do I
think he's trying to stop B5 uhuh so he
says I see that b75 is your agenda I'm G
to stop it and do you think he wants to
close it oh I don't know what else he
wants to do one at a time you already
got uh that uh whole stopping the B5
down very good H we're coming to that
part of our show where you we get ready
for our first
break oh not not yet excuse
me okay let's take a look at Jeffy JS
and Hans nean game oh yes because what
is that was the pawn Sacrifice game yeah
and
now it's an interesting position with
two Rooks on open file kind of D3 is a
weakness left it right here Rook B3 o
excuse me we left it at Rook B3 takes
takes Rook B1 Bishop G6 Rook B3 Queen
takes and this is where uh Bishop B5 is
uh been previously played and then there
was a queen takes C2 that Christian was
showing us instead Bishop B2 that was an
alternative Rook d8 Queen A1 take on D3
aren't you surprised to see this Pawn
structure with Pawn on D3 I am I am I'm
I'm looking from jeffy's point of view H
he wants to play um a capture including
uh Rook C1 Rook
E8 but you know my back rank's a little
bit weak this is very awkward I I was I
wanted to play Rook C1 and Bishop takes
F6 but I'm just forgetting about the
fact that I'm not going to take on
C7 uh right because the King on H1 is
just not next to the open Square on F2
you know if you go back yes for a second
I thought it maybe which moment yeah
maybe here Jeffrey was going to capture
the pawn on G6 I mean sorry trade trade
Bishops on G6 just to keep that kind of
mirrored Pawn structure okay get the
bishop to B2 and Bishop B2 and not to
allow the weakness on the D3 Square
seriously Kate I mean uh I'm I was
thinking that if I've got anything I've
got to keep the two Bishops even if I
have to trade Queens um Bishop B5
because the current position I think uh
Hans uh he's probably a very happy
camper now we're ready for our uh
friends at Q Boutique uh let's check in
and see what their specials are today
today it is the 2023 us chess
championships t-shirts grab the newest
apparel for the 2023 us chess
championships these shirts proudly
feature the logos of the US
championships on the front the official
St Louis chess club logo on the sleeve
and the back displays the names of the
players in each field the red shirts are
in men styles and display the players of
the open field and blue are in women's
Styles and represents the women's field
both are only available whil limited
supplies last at Q Boutique St Louis
stl.com and as we go in our break we had
a really really wonderful Opening
Ceremonies we were at the new stadium
the new soccer stadium here in St Louis
and there's a beautiful soccer field and
around the field the the names of the
players were going on the ticket it's a
very new studium just built in St Louis
it was so cool I hope you enjoy the
features as well as the induct have a
have a
look
well I want to welcome all of the
players to St Louis also referred to as
the chess capital of the nation this is
always my favorite time of the year when
we have the best players in America
playing
chess the St Louis chess club has hosted
the last 15 US championships elev
The Prestige of these Premier Events and
you the players are the best us chess
has to offer and we're proud to see you
here over the next two weeks we
celebrate that us chess and the St Louis
chess club do what we do best we are
committed to creating a welcoming and
safe environment for all be they one of
the top players or the Casual chess fan
since the Championships came to St Louis
in 2009 we've learned more than anything
we want what is best for the game and
for the people who make up our chess
community and I'm proud that us chess is
able to partner with the St Louis chess
club as leaders in the Chess World now
on behalf of the chess club and the
board of directors the St Louis Club
remains committed to our mission of
creating a worldclass venue for players
from across the globe to enjoy and we
will do everything in our power to
continue to make the tangible meaningful
changes that Foster an equitable
environment and help the St Club be the
safe and best place in the world to play
chess thank
[Music]
you yeah um it's amazing with the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless um national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping Ground Schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chest in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr Jun
singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that St luus Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there
it is there it will be there I think it
send a hope that the game of chess will
always stay Al flat by the mere fact of
its existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promotee chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years years
stop by and learn about the impact of
Chess from our three floors showcasing
the art culture and history of the game
the World Chess Hall of Fame has
something for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active been over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
veru niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr Genie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex singfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floor show showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
piece sitting outside our front door the
world chest Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign out for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 th000 students in both
in school and after school programs we
view chess as a valuable educational
tool learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting St Louis chess
club.org
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States it also plays host to
an award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting C to luxury chest sets there is
something for everyone at Q Boutique
enjoy a shopping experience like no
other make sure to check out Q Boutique
stl.com for a wide variety of gifts for
everyone to
[Music]
enjoy hello everyone and Welcome to our
coverage of the 2023 national
championships round round five was
amazing round six is shaping up as
another highly combative intense round
but we have a special guest in studio
Shannon Bailey of the World Chess Hall
of Fame Shannon welcome
again so happy to have you here wow so
many great exhibits in the musical
series especially yes so we have this
wonderful music series at the hall of
fame which we've had for years they sell
out almost every single time we've got
one that get a seed no one that focuses
a lot on Regional bands and then one
that kind of goes into more of like a
classical uh kind of genre we work a lot
with the symphony and other types of
classical musicians so it's a little
something for everybody andan I know
that you do a lot of exhibition so take
take us back a little bit why did you
decide to do chess and uh music yeah so
we have an exhibit right now called
sound moves where music meets chess and
that was curated by me and my husband
Bradley Bailey who's a professor at St
Louis University and is an art and chess
scholar as well and he's also a huge fan
of music so we were kind of looking at
all these great music connections that
we have and that we celebrate our music
and so we thought you know let's do a
show about Chess and music well there's
a big correlation when I think about uh
top players Mark Ty off comes
immediately to he featured in the
exhibition lios porish I think got
kamsky is really a classical pianist so
music and chess definitely huge
connection there are so many pieces in
this show and it we just scratched the
surface so you know we could have looked
at it it just as like people that used
uh musicians who used chess on their
album covers that could have been an
entire show uh chess players that play
music music musicians that play chess
but we just kind of threw it all in
there and it's a nice little survey of
stuff so there's a little something for
everybody upcoming yeah so this uh
weekend we have uh Marina toy is coming
in and she is is amazing she uh designed
costumes that Katie Perry's team wore in
the Super Bowl halftime show in 2015
it's amazing I visited Hall of Fame and
with some of my students uh at the chess
games and they just love the costumes so
great so she also did many costumes for
the mass singer uh costumes for uh I
said Katy Perry uh Ariana Grande uh
Taylor Swift and she grew up playing
chess in Russia so she has this great
chess connection and and I don't think
she even realized how much she was
putting chess to her work until we
contacted her and started pointing it
all out so we're really excited that's a
free event Saturday it's at wasu yes on
the 14th 3 p.m. visit our website for
more information about that um we'd love
to see people there you're going to get
to play chess with her and you get to
hear about her work especially what she
did with the Super Bowl halftime show
wow that's amazing you know and chess is
becoming so mainstream a lot of famous
people are now playing chess or posing
with chess uh so can you tell us about
more musicians that are currently
um kind of incorporating chess into
their work so we worked at Julian Castle
blanc' team who is in The Strokes and he
has chess all over his albums and uh he
wore a jacket in a music video with a
chess board on the back and uh we hope
to have him here in St Louis we have
tons of photos of people playing chess
some of them are stage because you you
know how you can tell set up the king of
[Music]
the which I know you guys love to point
out
but there are some people you know who
really are you know playing chess in
them a lot of jazz musicians like Dizzy
Gillespie and count basy um so it's fun
to see them sitting down and playing
chest these beautiful photographs and
then we've got you know the signed copy
of the Queen's Gambit score um we worked
with the mun for Chess the musical this
summer which was such a beautiful
collaboration that was really fresh
fresh in my mind and we went backstage I
actually went to see it twice I saw
three times I saw three times my
daughter and I saw three times and if
there would have been another show we
would have seen it we got to meet the
cast and they were just fantastic
musicians amazing people and they were
telling us how stressed they were they
were about actually getting the the
chess part of that musical correct
exactly they did such a good job though
yeah so it's been fun World Chess Hall
of Fame just had a huge collection we
had Sal Mata who came on he was a
president of the Marshall chess trust
boxes of stuff went to the World Chess
Hall of game so essentially your Fisher
collection's getting bigger stuff and S
I um had brunch with s the other day and
he was telling me about playing Bobby as
a kid right and I said you have to write
all this down you have to turn this into
an article or a book or something
because this firsthand accounts of their
relationship and both being taught by
Jack Collins and um yeah as you can tell
I love my job because I get to meet the
coolest people isn't it and you Boris
basy Jr yes that was a magical too right
and that's all on the World Chess Hall
of Fame website too that see a video of
him um talking about his father and uh
his relationship with Bobby and we did
that huge show last year celebrating the
50th anniversary of the 1972 world
championship and it was much of a
celebration of Boris as it was Bobby two
incredible men uh Boris Basi was a
stand-up human being and his you know
meeting his son was great honor you know
I'm always so impressed to go Chess Hall
of Fame and see all that material and
how much you guys know about chess
players I feel like I know nothing when
I'm there because they know so much
about the personal life I remember
reading some of the letters that Bobby
Fisher wrote to Boris basy I mean you
could see that friendship there for me
it was fantastic well we're really proud
to do a wide array of exhibitions to try
to you know get you guys really excited
about it that are in it but then
bringing in new audiences of people who
might just like music or just like
science or fashion we just we want to
bring everybody in and teach them how
great chess is speaking of new audiences
too one of my favorite exhibitions I'll
surprise you with this one was chess and
Comics oh I love you had all of these
comic book now when I was a kid you know
the Hulk Thor and the greatest Silver
Surfer Silver Surfer I mean he was like
the greatest uh you know he had the
cosmic uh energy uh going but that was a
marvelous exhibit all the kids so I have
to say
what you're going to learn is these
exhibitions are a Bailey Family Affair
so my daughter Mina was little at the
time she was obsessed with superheroes
and I thought I've got some comic books
we've got some chess sets that deal with
superheroes so I put that together
basically as like a gift to her and that
you know ended up being you know such a
fun fun show I mean we had over a
hundred Comics hanging up and that was
just scratching the surface so another
thing you can tell is we've got a great
permanent collection and you know one
thing that I one show that I regret of
missing and I know a lot of people keep
reminding how amazing it was it was I
think called the fire on the board you
play you play with cand your husband was
my opponent the pictures look amazing
and I know the players just loved it how
how you play with bring it back we will
bring it back we almost brought it back
last summer um but we're trying to find
a good time to do that and that is Glen
Kyo is the artist and you literally play
with burning candles I'm definitely
coming for that you will be invited for
sure so yeah I mean we've got GTO Vander
coming back the chess piano that's in
the show that'll be something going on
in January so little something for
everybody shanon thank you so much for
coming thank you for joining us it's
always a great pleasure thank you for
what you do for chess because you know
it's not just the games it's really the
players and learning about them to learn
about the chess culture so thank you
abolutely thank you for having me thank
you Shannon and once again our standings
we're going to start with the ladies
Kate so we have two leers in the women's
section after round five Karis and be to
janova scoring a lot of points here with
four points out of five then we have a
sole third place uh person Ina crash
with three and a half points and then
she's closely followed by bunch of
players Alice Lee Ana zatonski nazzi pit
tatf Abraham and ruang with two and half
points all of 50% and then in the open
section we have two clear uh Front
Runners yes we have Fabiano Carana
leading with four out of five and
closely followed by Hans nean with three
and a half points and then a two-way tie
for the third place wesle so and Lenard
Dominguez with three points Sam
shankland Sam Sean Mishra all at 2 and a
half and uh taking it over to you
Christian tell us where the action is
well I'm hearing there's some uh
repetition going on in the Jeffrey Jang
versus Hans Neiman game take a look at
this we were discussing it we're saying
that white has a slight Advantage not
much right slight Advantage because of
this uh nice battery on the long the
you have some pressure on the C file
there's some games here and one of them
has been won by white Nakamura Nakamura
versus Duda I think that was probably
some sort of a rapid encounter between
the maybe a blitz a title Tuesday game
who knows Rook to C1 Queen to A6 Rook to
A3 Queen to B6 this is the first
repetition that we were discussing might
arise on the board Rook to B3 Queen to
A6 now what I'm seeing is and it could
transpose
in case black takes with the queen this
would in fact be quite a big mistake in
this position if you do take with the
queen this is how you give me some
options of potentially getting an
advantage in the position after the move
H3 this is not a pleasant end game
because you're probably going to defend
like this I'm going to start putting a
lot of pressure on A7 on C7 maybe I can
start pushing my pawns as well this is
how you give white a slight Advantage
what you have to do after Bishop takes
F6 is in fact to take with the G Pawn
take advantage of the fact that it's not
very easy first of all the material is
very limited right there's only a queen
pair of queens and the Rooks on the
board there's no Knights jumping around
my king there's no Bishop on the long
diagonal anymore so the king is in fact
safe despite the fact that sure you have
some ideas maybe of Rook to C4 at the
same time you do have to be careful as
well because you play Rook to C4 yeah
you might have some problems after Queen
takes A2 you have to be careful as well
in the back rank so this is the position
right now that we have white can take
the repetition with Rook to B3 he can
also play something like Bishop to E5
and keep the game going at the same time
again I'm looking at the dynamic of this
encounter between these two players Hans
has been doing quite well in the event
Jeffrey not so much so I think Jeffrey
will be thinking here a little bit will
understand that objectively he doesn't
really have a big advantage Ag and
perhaps he will take the repetition with
Rook to B3 okay I kind of do like Bishop
E5 there just as a move uh kind but
Bishop to5 what if I continue Knight D5
oh you go there oh Sor yeah I'm I'm I'm
going to get in I'm trying to create my
own ideas in the position as well you
want to play Rook e to if I take a pawn
bishop takes C7 you go Rook
E2 yes yes yes no I was going to take
the pawn first of all you cannot ah you
mean the PA C7 okay cuz if play Rook E2
I play Rook G1 my next move I hope is
Bishop G3 to evict you oh yes oh no
Queen takes G3 go
Bishop this is a nice what I might have
missed let me show you yes what what I
might have missed you might have missed
yes yes ni draw The Rook to G1 lock the
king in the corner and then Bishop to G3
is no longer possible on the board very
interesting position but again I have to
say the material is very very limited
Jeffrey has the opportunity to take the
draw and I don't think he's going to uh
refuse it I always uh pay my respects to
our tournament leaders I think it's uh
our duty and uh let's jump into the game
of Bobby versus Sam Sean we have no
duties we have no Allegiance yes sir
have no friends no friends we have
friends Bishop A3 Rook uh d F7 Rook B1
Rook D7 this is where we have left it
and we were looking at this position H2
H4 King G2 uh but for me as white I
didn't want to see E5 E4 Fabby felt the
same way played the move D2 D3 and we
have quickly gotten to the current
position uh we it looks like Blake got
out of trouble right of finishing his
development very very much pushing for
E4 or Knight D4 I really like Knight D4
yeah I really like this idea of Knight
F5 Knight D4 and I agree with you uh I
don't see any really particular problems
in the position for black safe Center
good pieces doubled Rooks I have to say
I like this position for
black Bishop yeah it it's yeah I I would
say it's balance uh I mean I I have far
more experience on the white side of uh
these endings uh playing uh the dragon
as well as the um uh
uh well rat modern and uh so on so this
is uh for for for for me it's it's
balanced we just saw the game of Jeffrey
let's go to the ladies championship and
see how Karissa is doing as well as beum
first we're going to pick up on the beum
again when we left the how funny is that
there was a queen on G4 the next time we
come back there's a queen on G5 like
what uh somebody traded uh places
H5 wow wow very aggressive move forcing
the queen to get away from that G5 yeah
for me that's a very consequent move
because I always ask myself where am I
putting my king just you know where am I
going am I leaving it in the center am I
going Queen side I'm going going King's
side when I see the move H5 I say well I
mean you're not really going keep but
this is the followup I really like
because begging wanted to trade dark
Square Bishops because we see that the
you know D4 square and F4 Square they
are both dark and they're weak so if we
remove the possible Defender the that
dark Square Bishop then it's very easy
for black to jump on those squares good
point and that's why I wanted to ask you
if I'm going to trade Bishops I'd like
to do it on my terms and if you're if
you're fascinated by the E3 pardon me
the uh D4 and F4 four squares I would
like to invite you but you're going to
capture
with help me to defend them and this is
where I come back and I say the move H5
may come back to haunt you a little bit
because you would like to play castles
but you don't want to leave your Pawn on
H5 and this is the moment where double
Pawn is actually very strong in the
center because it controls a lot of
important squares but that was not what
uh atusa played after Bishop G5 she just
took took Queen E3 that's a kind of a
funny invite she's going with the same
idea but she wants the Queens off the
board I think this position is very
balanced the game that was crazy Rockham
sakam was the game between ashria and
Karissa when we left it we left it here
and I think everybody on set was
fascinated by your suggestion of Queen
D4 check and knight uh H5 Karissa more
modestly castled and I think we're also
very interesting position for Karissa
because exactly you need to defend that
pawn on C5 otherwise I capture it I have
extra Pawn I have developed pieces life
has no troubles whatsoever exactly
um you just said it very well yourself
black has no troubles whatsoever I'm
thinking uh
Karissa uh has advantage in fact because
this move B5 B4 as so long as the Knight
you know was jumping forwards that was
fine but if after B4 you have to play
Move shudder Knight B1 yeah terrible
Knight D1 I think uh black is for CH you
that's the difference when we trade the
Knight right when the Knight was on C6
the Black Knight The White Knight on F3
then it wasn't that easy to attack the C
C5 Pawn so we thought Rook ad D1 quickly
finish development right but and the way
you go Rook situation always very
different when that Queen is active no
question about it and I think that uh
Carissa is doing very well in this game
I wanted to go funny enough uh Karissa
is actually winning Carissa is just
winning yes objectively at least it's
winning did you mention the move B4
right now to defend the pawn on C5 or
were are you thinking about B4 for black
later on think you were thinking about
for black but it is a funny instance if
white decides to try to defend the pawn
with the move B4 because after E5 this
is game over oops if you take it I'm
just simply going to pin you down and
then you're going to lose the piece
don't forget about G2 mate right guess
what yeah exactly G2 as well so there's
so many problems Rook A1 was played
which is the best move in the position
but I don't have to take on C5 I can if
I want to I don't have to right Queen
takes C5 is a good move as well Rook A8
is a good move as well you cannot at
least for the moment touch the pawn on
E7 you get checkmated on G2 so don't do
that I can improve my position as much
as possible it's a really good situation
for Karissa and you were saying that
be's position is uh very balanced right
yeah and this surprised me as well the
engine is saying that black is doing
much better actually I I was the move
Bishop takes G5 by white a good move not
a great move no that was the problem and
that she acquiesced to this ending this
whole idea of Queen to G4 and in fact
begim did respond very very well to that
with this move H5 this expansion helps
black on the king side because we are
headed towards some sort of an game and
in the end game I'm going to have a lot
of space I was looking at the lines and
how the engine is trying to play this
position first I'm going to create some
more weaknesses right right once you
play the move B3 later on Maybe not
immediately but at some point the way to
break through is going to be A5 A4
create some weaknesses on that side and
that's how I'm going to try to play it
coupled with the fact that once the
Knight lands on C5 you also have the B3
and the D3 weaknesses as well but the
engine was playing this quite nicely
with H4 as well first to improve the
position on the king side get more space
on this side get the king to E7 solidify
the structure in the center with the
move F6 and another right moment
breakthrough on the queen side and it
seems like white doesn't really have
what to do in the position it's very
very interesting a very interesting
position I don't know if she will go for
this end game Queen takes C3 I know be
him is a fighter she loves to keep the
pieces on the board but look this is the
nature of uh this particular opening
once you exchange the Queens you will
just simply have a risk-free advantage
in the end game it does seem at least we
were're being told that Jeffrey might be
looking at that repetition repetition
with Rook to B3 and in
fact are we going to see Hans get out of
the
repetition was played somebody's going
to call Frank uh over if he goes Queen
A6
that's whoa whoa whoa that was a
shadoo that was a shadoo shadoo yeah
don't touch that
I I adjust I adjust uh looking at the
game of Nasi and Alice Lee again both of
these players coming into this round
needing to score because that pack at
the very top um making some distance and
uh both Alice and Nasi are at two and a
half out of five on a 50%
score Bishop A3 Queen takes and I'm
expecting Rook Rook fd8 actually funnily
enough no uh I was expecting Rook on F
to E8 the idea is the uh different
majorities if you will okay white has a
queenside majority I black has the Cent
SL kingside majority what do I want to
do I want to use my majority I want to
be able to play E5 uh Kick The Rook move
my Bishop go E4 go E3 utilize my
majority if I play the move rook d8 and
again I just want to emphasize I'm
playing the position in the tournament I
need to win right if I start trading off
all the Rooks you know like chop CH chop
um it's going to be very very hard uh so
for Alice to do anything I'm thinking
it's balanced but okay is time a factor
by the way so Nai has 55 minutes and has
46 so they have a lot of time to think
um about their moves Arena Crush coming
into uh today's round in third place uh
she needs well don't we all a victory
here it's interesting she came from this
um what do we call this timeing off
timeing off uh uh Sicilian but it's a
moroi and then quickly the players have
gone into a that was uh a
hedgehog uh but this one is very very
very surprising for me I'm used to
seeing the queen on A8 The Black Queen
on A8 not on
E8 uh help me out do you know about the
Hedgehog with the queen on E8 very
surprisingly positioned there peculiar
is this the latest wrinkle I don't
believe it Hedgehog with a queen on E8
Christian yeah that looks suspicious
very suspicious right is that arena is
very experienced Grandmaster right she
knows her her stuff but what is the
queen doing on E8 I don't know I mean if
you are you going to go f no you're not
going to go F6 and queen H5 that no
that's not possible Right you lose the
pawn on E6 no so what is that Queen on I
can only imagine
G5 Queen f8 and queen H6 that's the only
reason I could put the queen but that is
a stretch I have to I have to say uh
from Arena's pers perspective she's
playing Ru y Yen uh junior player maybe
not that experienced in these Hedgehog
endings uh I think that's what she wants
she exactly she wants a long game she
wants more pieces on the board and she
accepts the fact that maybe objectively
she's going to have a worse position at
the same time she's also looking at
Carissa she's looking at begim and she
sees them winning and she knows she
needs to keep up keep the pace up you
want to win even with the black pieces
you want to score the full point so
that's exactly her strategy that's why
we see all these crazy nuances in the
Hedgehog by the way Hans said no no
repetition no I want to win with the
black pieces you just said in this
completely dry position he's like okay
I'm going to go Queen to F2 and I'm
going to keep the position um complex
like this you're not going to be able to
simplify it because Bishop takes F6 I
take you cannot take on F6 you're
getting checkmated if you do go Rook to
F1 then I go Queen to E2 and once again
how do you simplify the position you
cannot start hunting my queen because
you're dropping some pawns uh along the
way so what do you do you go Rook to G1
this or not actually easy moves to make
right you go D3 you lose a pawn right
maybe I can even go C5 get more space
and in fact this Pawn on F6 perhaps is
going to be an asset later on it's going
to support a transition via the fifth
rank of The Rook from E8 to H5 or G5 to
put more pressure on G2 and your
weaknesses I'm looking at the position
and I'm starting to feel a bit worried
for uh Jeffrey for the simple fact that
psychologically right right now with
Hans declining the repetition you know
the owners is on Jeffrey to prove that
he can hold on to equality in this one
Jeffrey already signal I'm ready to make
a draw Hans was like no I'm not
interested in a draw I need to catch up
with a lader Fabiano Carana I'm half a
point behind him and fabbi is winning
game after game so I might as well try
to win this one with the black pieces as
well Jeffrey Jang as you see he comes
into this tournament with a great deal
of us championship experience he has
played in these US championships in the
past done performed incredibly well I
think one one tournament he he lost a
single game and he was really at the top
half of the event and uh I'm sure he
came in very very ambitious he needs a
win desperately as well so uh for him uh
this game with Hans I'm a little bit
surprised by Hans decision because I'm
looking at this position and uh Bishop
takes F6 Rook F1 I always feel when my
my my King's sides exposed like that but
we see Hans risking right because he
really wants to be risking he wants to
try to get that win or just complicate
stuff make you know Jeffrey make
decisions uh that could be wrong if you
don't have your own tournament well
there you have it and uh Kate where
would you like to take us so let's take
a look at the women's section all right
maybe Talia cantes and TF abrahamian oh
I had that uh actually up on my board
funnily enough uh let's uh take a look
when we left it not actually the players
have played very very slowly I think it
was actually just here when we left it
Bishop B7 I also mentioned that Rook B8
as well as Bishop A6 I've seen these
types of um games uh often Bishop
B7 can I ask a question ask the question
take the
pawn why isn't she taking well why did I
play Knight
D2 take the pawn what is there an
immediate
answer crickets so if I capture yeah
okay I capture the Knight Knight takes
C4 Knight C Bishop takes C4 and Knight
B6 Knight B6 so I'm opening up the
diagonal so I may think about capturing
that pawn on G2 okay
well I know you want to give up that
one in the immortal words of Nikey just
do
it okay let's take it let's yeah exactly
and this was the question can I use
utilize uh the G file or not the bishop
let's just put the bishop back e or
that's a you know borrowing a page from
um the Alice League game where she
played bishop4 against Nazi she can drop
it back to G6 okay fine now we
understand why she didn't take on D on
C4 she did play Queen C2 Rook C8 is
getting ready for that C5 break yes um
yes indeed she is and
A3 and who's been tanking the most um I
guess both players have been using their
clock a great deal here I mean we have
just mooved 13 exactly and uh in some of
the other games we where we're in
endings right and pieces traded there
many pieces traded here here we've got a
board full of pieces going on just want
to check in on Carissa's game very
quickly okay nothing too much has
happened this is the BAM game and an
ending I think is favorable for beum
Rook d8 said Alice she didn't go for my
suggestion of Rook E8 and E5 Rook d8 on
the board again I seeing a very balanced
game well we haven't seen this one since
Queen B3 when we left it we saw Queen B3
Knight C6 and um Anna was playing slowly
but
we are caught up I like this bishop A6
move trying to trade that light Square
Bishop because that Bishop is very
strong the other Bishop on C3 not so
much yeah it's kind of blocked at the
moment but okay we go
castles uh one of the reasons I didn't
want to put the Knight on C6 from the
very early opening is because after Rook
C1 we can see that that Knight on C6 is
going to potentially be a tactical
Target for these Rooks uh I like Anna's
position uh again this was the arena
Crush position we have a hedgehog with
if you Castle Black's Queen castles from
E8 to B8 and The Rook on B8 castles to
E8 I think we have a normal Hedgehog
with the queen on E8 I'm discombobulated
I I'm not sure exactly what the queen is
doing there Christian where's the action
well I'm looking at the open section
this game between Mishra and Dominguez
we didn't talk about this game almost
almost at all we left it off somewhere
around I believe B was coming a queen on
C2 the yes the sacrifice queen2 Queen to
D1 just got back proposed this uh trade
of the Queens lenier said no and no
maybe that's a good idea right because
lener needs some victories right yes he
understood that yesterday as well
against Sam Shanklin and he mentioned it
during the interview also he said yes I
know it's very difficult when the guy is
scoring every single round in this field
fa I need he was talking about Fabby of
course I need to keep up with him and
he's trying to do so against a player
that started off blazing hot NRA that is
but slow down in the last couple of
rounds against Wesley lost yesterday he
had a good opening good opening
understanding but unfortunately for him
he wasn't able uh to uh understand the
differences in the position he didn't
see that Bishop to A3 idea he played it
a bit or at least he thought about
playing it a bit too late after Bishop
to D6 allowed Wesley to uh recover so
that was his uh second loss his first
Ross against Hans that was the difficult
one to digust as well for Mishra so
right now he's struggling and linear is
saying okay let's keep the Queens on the
board I'm trying to put more pressure on
you and guess what he's managing to do
so Bishop to B3 Rook takes d8 Rook takes
d8 Bishop to F4 we have this
position but what do you do after Queen
to F5 my question for you is where are
you trying to get this bishop to I guess
you want to go to E3 and give me the
pawn on E5 but after Queen takes E5 I
have the two Bishops I have this nice
Bishop PA B3 that's plaing your whole
game via the dile there's no more Rook
D1 right no you're no I want Rook Bishop
G3 what is but you just came from there
right the last you just played Bishop F4
right so Queen F5 Bishop G3 that doesn't
really make a lot of sense I will
continue Rook to D3 uh active my Pieces
Just improve my position slowly but
surely and in the meantime what do you
do right if you go Rook to A3 look at
how um um how harmonious my pieces are
after Bishop to C4 right I have Rook
takes C3 in the pipeline I mean this one
is looking really good by the way B3
doesn't work because of Rook takes C3
you cannot take on C4 with any of the
pieces right if you take with a B Pawn
and Rook on A3 is hanging so Queen to F5
by the way ler is probably hey where are
you going with that Bishop right you're
not going to E3 because that drops a
pawn are you going back to G3 well thank
you very much I'm getting a couple of
tempies improving my position I have a
great situation right now and maybe I
will win backto back uh games can I go
Queen
G4 maybe that's what he wants if you
capture I capture Rook D1 Rook D1 is one
way to at least no no no no do that I I
like Black's position in that ending I
want more though oh you want more oh I
want much more yes see I'm so easily
satisfied give me a pwn my favorite
living condition life is good you want
to be a pie you want you you you you
want is a right so you get a pawn but
you get a pawn back sure you have a
better end game but the material is
limited maybe you're going to escape
with a draw none of that for you no no
no no no I'm trying to Checkmate you
here Knight E3 Queen takes B2 Rook F1
and Bishop takes H6 doesn't bother you
B6 I mean I will defend you have one
threat I understand Knight coming to F5
kn5 I was one move away from Knight F5
and maybe this is what he calculated and
maybe he missed Bishop to E6 perhaps
this is what Mishra is lacking right now
in a Tempo I mean if I my knight if you
don't right so just my knight was yeah
if you don't have Bishop B6
B H6 Knight
F5 or on black if he tried to get out
Knight F5 is actually looking really
good for white that's what I mean G5 you
can you can take on G5 and this is very
very good so what's another idea what if
after Queen G4 Queen C2 yes what if I
capture on H6 what am I missing whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa this one this one
right here is it this one right here
this one right here check where's the
mate where's the mate all right there we
go
[Music]
oh sorry I have this one as well that's
it yeah this is
over oh that's painful King H5
[Laughter]
G6 oh oh oh yeah oh no this is looking
that's rough that's Missouri Tigers man
they're
tough yeah wow no um I so Queen F5
Advantage lanir I'm puzzled by this idea
of Bishop for look at Mishra he's not
happy he didn't like it nope he didn't
he missed something in his calculation I
think it was this queen to G4 and
Bishop what you showed which stops
Bishop H6 and stops Knight F5 I think
this is what he missed because otherwise
Bishop to F4 does not make sense at all
in this
position by the way I mean seriously
it's not a joke every time I look at
these pieces I see these beautiful
beautiful uh chess sets those triple
weighted dgt enabled I like the KN it's
so well crafted you can see even the
teeth there exactly exactly I mean when
you're playing on these really luxury
professional sets you feel like you know
you're professional you know like you
don't want to go back to the plastic no
you
don't come on over we'll play some Blitz
I've got this beautiful uh Blitz uh
chess set for us and there you see what
I mean uh about the Mains and as you
were saying the teeth on the night just
gorgeous stuff um what game is that Ah
that's a t of game yes the Fab game he
went for that Bishop E3 which I thought
was a very interesting intriguing
decision by fabbi saying I'm willing go
ahead and take my uh bishop and double
my pawns I sort of like it yeah Bishop
E3 move Fabby knows that the position is
balanced balanced sure not equal but
balanced he doesn't
have the advantage out of the open he
knows that because he's analyzed these
type of positions for white but also for
black he's playing this as well they're
very very healthy for black and look
there's no reasons why black would be
worse he doesn't have any weaknesses
in Knight to D4 is coming and that's
kind of a problem so I have to defend
against that Knight D4 once put the
Knight on D4 I will exchange on D4 at
the end of it I want to take with the
pawn so I have something to work with
right and that's why he played this move
Bishop to E3 right now Knight takes C3
sure but that changes the nature of the
position if you take on E3 and I kind of
like it for white just for the simple
fact that right now I'm controlling D4
sure that's a big one also I have ideas
maybe at some point of Rook to F1 and
trying to look um around the pin on the
f file maybe even G4 G5 if you're not
paying attention so I'm liking White's
chances I don't see an Ive plan for
black and that's what worries me because
as practical players we don't have the
engine to tell us exactly where to place
our pieces we're looking for uh patterns
that we recognize we look for plans
where is our next plan how uh how do I
get out of this and I don't see an
active plan for black in this one that's
why I'm worried if he takes on E3 I
don't think he's going to take on E3 no
so the question is what are you going to
do next right B6 obviously not possible
A6 not possible what what's the plan for
black the engine say that's why we have
Kate in studio to answer all these
difficult question I actually wondering
what if I go Queen E6 okay beautiful yes
and maybe and now I'm asking what's
mying G let's go King G2 I mean it's
useful to cover H3 what's the plan right
yeah how do you continue I know it's
probably very awkward now but I thought
like King F7 oo okay King F7 all right I
mean I want to make sure the queen is
defended on E6 the king is not going
anywhere else H3 or H4 uh but's go H4
just the idea that you wanted to go G5 G
are you wanting to go thinking about it
if you don't play H4 I may be thinking
but you know you have a lot of
sacrifices there I also don't see what
white wants to do in this position
exactly we were discussing about this
idea of H4 just to take more space on
just keeping the position by the way I
do believe we have a move right now
Knight to D6 was played so we we're we
tickle The Rook but the Rook steps up
rook C5 what was the idea of Knight D6
Rook Knight F5 the Knight just came from
F5 oh that's right I thought we are
transferring the night to a very good
Square good morning St
Louis uh Knight F5 boy okay uh but maybe
it's just one of those things that black
has maximized so I can't maximiz maybe
as well we've improved our positions
your king F7 is an indication that all
the pieces are on their best squares has
been played okay so now I'm starting to
understand what white might be trying to
achieve at one point what is white in
this game maybe something along the
lines of a tripling Down on the B5 on
the B file excuse me Rook to B3 followed
by Queen to B2 and try to at some point
say that if you do move the knight from
D6 you will also have to couple that
with B6 and once you play B6 then I can
go back to the cfile and pressure your
knight on C6 that's my plan right now
Rook to C3 I believe Rook to B3 or queen
to B2 first then just try to Triple down
on that's that's so funny I'm I'm used
to seeing the you know alak's gun or
tripling on an open file tripling on a
file that's half closed who knows we're
going to take a a break and as we go on
break we're going to leave you with a
special a message from the St Louis
chess club and Scholastic Center's board
of directors here it
[Music]
is
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping around
schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the United
I think if I look at my own career and I
look at American chest in general we're
in a much better place than we were 15
years ago and so the contributions have
been immense and of course it's all
thanks to Dr J singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that s lucious
Club is like a rock in the ocean of
Chess and we know that it's it's there
it is there it will be there I think it
send a hope that the the game of chess
will always stay flat by the near faor
of its existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess hf.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
Veria niobian other programs include
chess Coxs a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of readand write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Ken sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
awardwinning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at cubu ique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no and become everyone's
favorite Gift Giver if you can shop in
store make sure to check out Q Boutique
stl.com for a wide variety of gifts for
everyone to
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as well as high-profile tournaments
that attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken's cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership ship
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chest
piece sitting outside our front door the
world Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign out for chess events
family-friendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please please visit
World Chess h.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting St Louis chess
club.org
education St Lewis the chess capital of
the United States it also plays host to
an award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other
make sure to check out Q bouti stl.com
for a wide variety of gifts for everyone
to
[Music]
enjoy hello everyone and welcome back to
our coverage of the 2023 national
championships we are in round six and we
have some very eventful games uh taking
place when we left it uh in particular
we were looking at this game of Mishra
and lanir Dominguez and we saw this
position and the last move really is a
very tempting one now for lanir you you
see this move Queen C2 you're setting up
for a checkmating attack because we Chas
predicting this queen G4 exactly uh
chasing the king out if we block the
threat to Queen takes F2 with the move
Knight E3 Queen takes B2 and a very very
very important point just before you can
play Bishop takes H6 and Knight F5 with
the real little threats the move Bishop
E6 just puts a cold chill and a laner
could be in Pole Position this would be
huge for him it would mean back-to-back
victories we're keeping an eye on that
one you wanted to go by the way after
Queen G4 you wanted to capture the queen
right you said you enjoy that in which
moment sorry uh after Queen G4 oh yes
and that was the other thing for me I'm
a very happy uh uh Pond Grabber I did
want to go into this ending because I
saw an opportunity here there's no way
you're you're not going to play Rook A3
you're not going to stay in this have to
trade the Rooks and give up the pawn
back precisely I I give me the pawn back
I get Knight D2 Knight
C4 okay yeah and that that's my uh what
do you say my majority on the queen side
right I will put my Bishop here wait
wait wait a second can I do oh no E6 no
cannot but it's not that I saw this in
advance it just I mean just it just
happen stance at my Bishop just luckily
just black good and the pieces are in
good spot uh but yeah so again lanir is
for choice and okay I'm looking at this
position this is not that easy so qu C2
is not easy at all because we missed a
line at some point at this uh point we
said Rook to F1 kind of an automatic
move in the position to defend the pawn
on F2 and get a queen out uh get the
Rook out of Dodge but the big question
is what if I take on
H6 give you the Rook right to H2 I do
have a checkmating threat and you do
have to be very very uh careful because
if you play the very natural move G6
Queen to H4 finishes the game
attacking The Rook on d8 but most
importantly attacking Queen to F6
there's no way to stop him from doing
that you in fact getting checkm okay so
what you have to calculate and I'm sure
lener right now is looking at this this
King to f8 you have to start running but
again not an easy move to this looks
dangerous guys I mean getting uh with
the King putting on the running shoes
like this is not easy Queen takes G7 not
King to E7 because I'm thinking Knight
to F5 not only that but Bishop to G5
coming with Tempo is problematic but
King to E8 okay how do we assess this
one right I see a knight coming into
play but I'm not really sure what I'm
doing after that so I'm probably not
going to do it but what else maybe C
Bish Bishop F2 too as a responsible with
the Knight to F5 that's why I don't like
Knight F5 yes right Bishop to F2 not
only that um you're not checkmating me
but I'm checkmating you myself with
Queen to G1 wait Bishop takes F2 I am
actually checkmating you know Queen F7
Queen
D6 and Knight
G7 sorry what if you capture Queen F
Queen f8 ah Queen f8 okay okay queen f8
queen D6 and Knight D7 Knight D7 okay
that's a Checkmate very nice very nicely
spotted yes so I don't have time to take
it I have to run immediately and now
that the bishop is guarding everything
it's kind of easy to see at the same
time this is still not over but it's
funny because take a heavy six you got
to be careful in this position guys but
it it's funny because I'm reminded uh of
yesterday's game with Ray Robson and
Jeffrey John was very similar Right
Where You Gave white gave a rook Chase
Black's King to D7 and uh Ray nabbed
Jeff king that's right on the open board
so all of this is not clear at all right
Knight to F5 okay we understand that
right now King to D7 is in fact the best
move mhm and I'm just actually putting
on my running shoes I'm going to A8
right I'm hiding once I get to C8 I'm
hiding there's no way to stop me from
from doing that in the meantime I am a
rook out but you do have this other move
C4 very that's a funny one because you
you showed a discovery you're stopping
me right E6 game over beautiful nice the
queen on A1 what about Bishop C7 it's a
rook bishop7 have a
feeling F yeah F4 is winning already w
why is winning one that's all it takes
one 10 one move quick yeah that's why
he's not playing Queen C2 quickly this
is the line that he's calculating right
now King to D7 sorry that was the bad
move Queen to A3 getting out of Dodge
out of this E6 getting the queen back to
E7 and back close to the king and also
setting up this running idea of King to
D7 King to C8 that's more practical too
right Queen a practical but not easy and
if this is the only move I mean
calculating everything from afar it's
not simple and that's why maybe even
okay do we have any other Alternatives
yes Queen G4 and Rook D1 was the uh the
my actually that was my first
inclination just because I was getting
the A4 pawn and I thought it was a two
result game and I think that he might go
for this my prediction is that after a
long thing he's going try to figure
things out and he's going to see this
easy way out with Queen Tak G4 and he's
going to take it has Hans uh been
rewarded for his courage he declined an
early repetition and he went for the
queen F2 what's the current situation
Christian absolutely no it h he has been
rewarded for sure right now there's some
imbalance in the position is not that
easy to exchange the pieces for white
again right the plan is to exchange as
many pieces as fast as possible and make
a draw Jeffrey already signaled that
he's okay with it B3 Rook A3 says no I'm
not interested in that I want to fight
and right now after C5 okay how easy is
this in fact for white I want to play
the stupid move H3 just to get out of
and okay okay and now I go King to D7
and could play Rook on B2 to C2 so I can
go you're giving me uh the pawn no cuz I
wanted to I wanted to play Rook C4 you
might have some Rook C4 Rook C4 by the
way Rook G4 was my idea Rook D1 is a
problem already much worse Rook D1 right
I thought I had the first R defendant I
thought I had the first rank defendant
maybe technically you're still going to
make a draw but no but that's not what I
wanted when I went for this whole line
you know I was even thinking about
trying to take control of that first
rank very early on after Queen B1 yes
instead of C5 if black wanted to capture
on D3 Rook takes thinking that if Queen
captures I have Rook E1 coming now I
have Rook F1 right queen queen F1 and
this is very good for me actually yeah
because the king white king is very safe
but blacking is not and the two Rooks
are just going to be very dangerous
going to pick this uh Pawn on C7 first
then you're probably going to take this
we're going to trade these two pawns but
after that it's going to be a rook three
Queen three and that's I'm going to be
able to create some uh difficulties for
your position as black Vladimir
karnick versus Peter Leo the world
championship the two Rooks out out Fox
the queen in that uh game
um wow okay so that's the Hans uh so
Hans is doing good so far I mean he's
putting the pressure how are we doing on
time because this is important as well
Hans 23 minutes on his clock so he's
taking his time that's quite important
he's trying to create some imbalances in
the position but he is using spending a
lot of time Jeffrey on the other hand 43
minutes so okay the position still
balanced but I have to say the story is
that Hans is piling on the pressure
trying to create something he's the one
trying to win this game all right I feel
a bit of a like an Oracle in this game
between Ru Yang Yan and Arena Crush
because we were you know scratching our
heads and wondering what is Black's
Queen
doing exactly and the only thing I could
come up with is you want to go Queen f8
and G7 G5 and bring the queen on the
diagonal uh out whether it be to G7 with
the move G5 well let's have a a gander
what happened G5 KN Queen and she
improved the position of the Queen White
hasn't done anything and uh truth be
told if white actually does nothing
nothing nothing black slowly but surely
somehow gets an initiative I don't
understand exactly how it happens but
moves like H5 G4 on are on
Arena's agenda and ruen needs to come up
with something active she needs an
active plan and right now I don't see it
Kate yeah I was looking maybe for like
Queen
A4 to attack the pawn on A6 but black
will simply defend with Bishop B7 yep
now it would be one thing if you could
play F4 and exploit the fact that that
the Knight lacks protection but I don't
see the followup unless Queen is just
kind of misplaced there so let's try
something different you know I would
like to push for C5 or play A4 A5 but
the Rooks the black Rooks are just ready
for that exactly uh Queen A2 if you were
playing for A4 A5 that I might get
behind but how
how important is this Queens side play
versus what uh black is trying to
achieve let's say I go here and let's
say let's push that pawn and just to to
get a position on the board right G4 and
this bishop on A8 is lurking don't don't
be fooled uh I do want to play G3
against F4 I do want to play G3 by the
way and I feel like once again it's
black was suddenly attacking the king
having that initiative yeah and I don't
feel uh that's the Fisher attack right
in uh in the Hedgehog this Rook G8 G5 G4
I right right and now this is an
improved version Irena Crush improved
version with Queen in the front uh on G7
do do do you know a really funny story
about that so okay so it goes like this
Bobby I don't even know how he ends up
visiting Sweden is he Sweden they invite
him on a radio station so he has an
interview on the radio station Sweden
has a strong player his name is Ol
Anderson would you like Bobby to play on
the air radio a game against ol Anderson
Bobby says sure plays a game against ol
Anderson Bobby goes on to win an
absolutely extraordinary brilliant game
which was just an exhibition game it
goes in a book by um John Donaldson
Magnus Carlson reading the book he gets
the position and he plays it just like
B I mean it ripples across time the same
idea uh Magnus used the same idea as
Bobby fiser did 50 years early on an
exhibition of a radio station good that
then they ask him to play a game at the
radio station exactly uh crazy stuff
what did lineer do CH nothing yet
nothing yet no no he's still thinking
anden G right now he's he does have some
time though right he's not down to his
last uh few minutes and also there's not
that many moves to be played once you go
into this queen C2 line at least you
have one okay so let's count them out
right Knight e32 this is pretty much for
B H6 Bishop takes H6 three you have to
take it and then you have to start
thinking King f8 you kind of seeking to
f8 because G6 just loses on the spot and
is the only other alternative in the
position so King to
f8 King to E8 you don't want to go into
check so that's like five right right
right something along those lines right
now we're already at move 28 so with
those fives he's going to go down to
only eight moves left to make the time
control with 30 maybe 25 minutes plus so
perhaps he feels confident going into
this queen C2 line if he does because
all of these details they definitely go
into his decision um of potentially
going Queen to G4 which I have to say
it's an easy way out you're still going
to get an advantage but perhaps not as
much of an advantage as after Queen to
C2 he knows that if Queen C2 Works he
win he probably has a decisive Advantage
why do we seem to understand what's
happening this the moment let's see he
he he he looks like he wants to make a
move is he he does never
mind this is lanir and unless there's a
minute on his clock he could think I
wanted to just uh jump to the game of
tal uh and tata for a moment because um
this was a very big decision by uh Talia
and she made the decision quickly and in
this
position don't look ahead Kate I mean
you're black okay um you know your
Bishop on A5 is a little bit off
kilter um just give me your candidate
moves that you would think of Bishop D5
D5 Knight D5 you understand you have to
calculate something thing uh about
Knight C4 but I'm also targeting C3
exactly Knight Knight D5 yeah you know
there but I really like the decision
that Tata played oh W five which I was
not expecting that no
exactly but it does two things in what
time the first of all it does take away
like if if I'm on White Shoes I'm
sitting there going oh let me please
please allow me to play Knight E4 Knight
D6 I'm in business right so you took
away F5 but you also did something quite
nasty your you just want to tra the
bishop right and you're more or less
kind of
provoking uh White to playing the move
Bishop to E5 and here now you can go
back to thinking about what you would
like to play would you like to play
Knight D5 would you like to play Bishop
D5 I'm just saying that the move F5 for
me uh was you know a nice decision I
like this decision and we'll see if she
gets rewarded for it uh going to the
game of beum uh atusa they go into that
ending where the computer the engines
thought that Black's a little bit better
um it feels balanced to me can we take a
look at Leon tonan and Wesley's games
sure uh because I'm not sure I
understand what's happening there well
okay a lot of we left it we left it with
Knight A3 right way back in the day
Knight A3 was played Knight C2 takes
takes and Knight B4 takes
takes C5 yes takes takes Knight G5 B6
Rook F5 D3 is
hanging no Rook E8 Knight E4 interesting
wa was there a possibility for Queen H5
or right Knight I go Queen H5 probably I
have to play H6 H6 you're threatening me
with a mate H6 Knight E4 four D3 is the
issue right mm I do have Knight takes D3
Rook C7 no yeah I thought some brutal
stuff because if I go let's just take a
look Knight takes D3 Rook C7 if you
happen to capture that Rook on E1 yes
then Queen G6 game over yes uh we're I I
we're in Rook sacrifice mode whether it
be Ray Robson or whether it be lanir
Domingas or in this case leavon Oran
Checkmate on a G7 that's a nice line so
something to think about he didn't play
it by the way he played Knight E4 and
we're just going to quickly catch up to
the players we have done that already um
isn't the pawn on D4 kind of
weak yes isn't the pawn on
E5 I see a candidate pass passer and by
the way the problem is if I do get to
play
A3 that's a very dangerous passer let's
say you just take the pawn on D4 off the
board and you put the Rook on E3 and
you're a pawn up but your Pawn on D3 and
your Pawn on E5 they're not scaring
anybody the pawn on A2 might be scary
but on the other hand you know let's say
I play something like King H2 I'm not oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa pa pa King F1 let's
say okay perfect because if you push now
B4 then I'm getting the other Rook to C4
and the other yes right so like it's not
threatening to go immediately with those
Pawns and of course A4 was hanging as
well of course of course um but white
has some
time yeah no that was just to make a
move that is not not threateningly okay
so yes well indeed I have to prepare it
right because so maybe Rook C7 okay
perfect Rooks to C7 and uh let me deal
with that by the way I love that move
Rooks to C7 the desirable Rook F7 you'll
trade and queen
H5 is in trouble there I'll say
so G6 maybe Queen d8
even yeah I love my queen a moment ago
on the on a it was perched so nicely on
D5 uh Queen to d8 um very
very tense
position is it though why G so what if I
try not Rook to C7 what if I try to go s
like Queen E1 or queen D2 not Rook what
what's first of all what's wrong with
threatening me with this B4 A3 idea by
the way I think Rook C7 was
played has he played it we have the
camera yes Rook to C7 is played on the
board yes it's on the
board okay D I say it these guys are
very
good they liked your move uh at least
leavon likes your move
Kate C
get rid of that Rook that Rook is
bothering try to get rid of that yeah I
was looking at Rook F7 but that didn't
work because of a queen H5 line but Rook
C8 looks very good just chase that Rook
if you go to E7 I'll chase you some more
if you go to A7 I'll chase you some more
right the thing is I'm not worried about
your this is this is the ending that I
change and then go B4 right right this
was the ending that I was saying I like
Wesley's chances here here because I
think his pawns are more dangerous than
anything but you probably after Rook G4
H have to just simply make a draw Rook
F7 Rook f8 Rook F do I have to AC why do
I have to acquas so so quickly if you go
Rook H4 you might end up getting your
Rook tra really really you're actually
going to get so I mean you're very
aggressive I don't know what's wrong
with you today it's my
natural there's is Victory only playing
for victory no friends come on I thought
we were friends yes you found a new role
model on set we're friends by thought we
were friends we are friends you're not
nice all right all right all right we'll
keep that what did you very balanced in
that one right sure Hans was uh thinking
for a very long time actually after
Queen to B1 we were discussing 32
minutes at that point he didn't play C5
he played the move Rook to E3 that's
what we have and Rook to before is on
the board so he spent almost 20
minutes still 15 moves to go with only
13 minutes to go uh for Hans definitely
starting to look at some problems on his
clock so Rook to B4 what do we expect
what has he position now suddenly
because Rook G4 is a nice idea so you
have to stop Rook G4 you do you kind of
have to go Rook to D4 I think he's going
to play it nope never mind as we were
discussing it he played Queen to f F2
inviting Rook G4 well may I seeing a
check you're probably not going to go to
f8 because Queen to B4 is coming that
that might just win the game actually
let's see does it win no it still
doesn't win the game go because to D6
but I don't think you want to allow that
no right you give a check King to h8
makes the most sense now without looking
at the evaluation when you see The Rook
on G4 you're very optimistic aren't you
because the King on h8 you're ideas I
understand but on the other hand your
first rank is very weak I know I got to
play H3 to make L but then the D3 Pawn
I'm going to just grab it PA right okay
there are some problems with this and
this is what he wants to do he wants to
take that pawn on
D3 and I guess this is the question I
mean this uh seems to be pretty close to
equality right if you do play like this
I also have Rook to A4 ideas you're not
saving the pawns you're not saving the
pawns and the thing is with uh my Rook
on the four fourth rank right now even
if you manage to somehow let's say you
go C5 I take it and you manage to double
up on the second rank I always have the
defense with so I don't have any
problems on the second rack this is
probably the best way for both players
to continue this game for me seems
simplistic right but it's not that easy
go I'm surprised that white isn't for
choice I I I would have thought the Rook
on G4 the King on h8 you know all I got
to do is play Queen H6 it's Splat all
I've got to do is go Queen E7 at Splat
you know but it's not easy to get there
right and as soon as you leave with the
queen I have
Rook ideas on the first R so H yeah
probably maybe Queen to B4 does Queen to
B4 make sense now H5 seems to be good
for
black you know yeah I always thought
that I could bail out make a draw with
Queen F4 you know and I get a Perpetual
check or take the Rook on on h8 right so
in this final position maybe we can say
it on on my board okay pardon me I'll
have to bring it
up where are you hun
nean so just in in this moments we were
oh he's already
played Rook B4 Queen F2 we you again we
he already played Rook B2 we had been
looking mainly at Rook G4 ideas um
that's a silence draw offer another one
another one Queen goes back to H4 king
h8 queen B4 and there was this idea that
if you did play H5 I was thinking okay I
always have ideas of Queen takes F6 they
didet check back check but they did
repeat so we do have a queen F2 Rook B2
Queen H4 quickly who's in time trouble
um well hans's 30 minutes Jeffrey has
has 40 minutes so it would be hands but
I think he can just now write uh Queen
F2 and is that a third time
repetition is it not yet not not yet
okay is it second time well you have to
say uh tip your hat and yeah Hans is
showing his courage with 13 minutes on
his clock and you know avoiding a a
repetition how is uh Fabby doing uh
Fabby uh comes into today's round for
those of you who haven't been watching
three in a row I mean we know about the
street the street was one of the most
extraordinary things I've ever witnessed
uh oh yes seven in a row three in a row
uh a redot uh Fabiano the other
competitors do not want to see
Unstoppable yeah do not want to see that
happening let's let's see where we left
it we left it around these parts H5 E4
Bishop comes back to
E3 uh just a lot Knight is just jumping
around I mean last what five moves but
only Knight moves a lot of toing and
throwing going on here but I must say
the knight at last did find its best uh
Square it's eyeballing uh D4 as well as
F4 making the move D3 D4 n impossible
and that's a a backward Pawn now on a
good day you'd like to play Rook here
and queen here and triple
up on the pawn let's see what uh Fabby
did also this move kind of reminds black
well that diagonal is vulnerable as well
as a spawn on B7 King h8 and we're up to
date with the play uh the
game what do you think still balanced
still balanced I don't see really what
black is doing what white is doing I'm
not sure if as black I want to jump with
Knight on D4 no right because it helps
to trade the Knight on F3 that is not
doing much exactly and it opens up more
the kind of coincide the possibilities
so I feel like Sam doesn't want to do
much just even maybe moving King h8 King
G8 back right exactly so uh just to
clarify for everybody um yeah we're
going to play King
G8 sorry King G2 back yeah okay and what
we're what Kate and I are discussing is
the one thing that black needs to avoid
is essentially this ending where first
of all
the you you you've blockaded the defile
so now your two Rooks are no longer
active Rooks you're not hitting the pawn
uh well obviously everything H5 Pawn is
everything forgetting about the H5 Pawn
but the idea is you don't want to occupy
D4 or rather you do want to occupy D4
with a piece and not with a pawn so and
at the current position this kind of
standoff I'm not ready to jump but if
your bishop ever moves away if your
knight ever moves away then I do wanted
play Knight to D4 you know and it's
sometimes very easy to say don't move
just move King back and forth but I
remember for me as a player sometimes
it's difficult not to do anything and
you want to simplify stuff and then you
simplify and you're like I'm worse off
now why did I do anything with my
position no I think that's the hardest
thing in chest to do is actually to sit
on your hands to say okay I don't want
to disturb the equilibrium because we
have this concept of equilibrium right
and sometimes your pieces are just at
their maximum and you don't want to be
active and I think that's very very hard
because we're always striving we're you
want to accomplish something you want to
do something ex and uh rather just
holding the position so do you want to
play A5 in that position I don't think I
want to do anything actually the funny
part is I like my I would rather see you
play A5 than me oh no no with white
pieces I mean yes CU it's Fab's move
right now so well I'm a little bit
worried okay so with the King on G1 it's
Bob's move so you're saying A5 well
aren't I running into trouble with this
guy right Rook B6 oh sorry a E6 is
hanging right right right you cannot
take it yet okay good
point and I wanted to take it
so but that's the strategical risk we're
running right once you play 5 A6 that
pawn on A5 becomes sort of a liability
position so I I'll move my to protect
the Knight defend the Knight so that
Knight takes A5 is possible I would love
to get Knight C7 Knight B5 oh no that
would be a dream that's my dream but
unfortunately yeah that would be asking
a lot from the position yeah okay so um
how do I defend the pawn on A5 is the
question okay let's go Queen A3 yeah
something like that or queen A4 what
queen A4 fair I'm not sure why I put it
on A4 but actually now I understand why
you do because with Queen A3 I think you
do allow Knight C7 Rook B7 Knight B5 uh
uhhuh wow
um by the way Rook D5 that's an
unexpected
move uh and by way fbby kind of caught
up with Sam regarding on A4 A4 yes they
have Rook D5 both around 30
minutes whoa Rook to D5
and by the way that really changes
everything doesn't it sometimes I forget
how good these guys are and how deep
they analyze it yeah lenir did play
Queen C2 after a very long thing too
right yes yes he thought for a while and
finally the decision came he played the
move Queen to C2 the best move in the
position right now Mishra is thinking
and Mishra is thinking for more than 10
minutes the problem is if you don't play
Knight E3 you know you're accepting a
borderline losing position like if you
you try to exchange the pieces with
Bishop to E3 well thank you very much
I'll take take take on B losing C3 it's
over you don't have anything in the
position anymore and I can always stop
you from uh these ideas of Knight F5
with Bishop to E6 at some point you will
be a pawn down and also all of your
pieces are kind of passive right right
but the Rook on d8 is beautifully placed
the queen ready to pick up as many pawns
as possible is not looking good for
white so after Queen to C two you have
to defend the F2 Pawn somehow right
we've seen that Bishop takes H6 is not
possible you get checkmated after Queen
takes F2 so Knight to E3 becomes pretty
much forced he's still thinking spending
a lot of time maybe realizing right now
that my bluff which perhaps was a semi
Bluff right he was looking at that he
was seeing some sort of an attack maybe
my bluff is actually not correct and
with precise play uh my opponent Len
will be able to hide his King via f8 E8
D7 C8 those type of ideas so this one is
going to explode in the next few moves
how much of that Rook sacrifice Kate do
you think lanir had calculated with King
of8 and King I think he calculated very
deep he's a very strong player and he
knows how to calculate really deep uh
we're looking uh at leavon aronian and
Wesley so as it looks like they have
made repetition right a result by the
way that's not very good for leavon is
he's struggling with minus one he's
drawn five games he lost one game he's
not having a very good competition yeah
on the other hand I feel like you know
he is a player that he tries to play for
a win if it doesn't work if it's a draw
he's kind of okay with that well he has
to be by the way guys um are we going to
see finally the repetition in the Hans
game maybe maybe we can out to that game
once again because Queen to F2 was the
last move of Hans did not play Rook to
D4 and maybe that's kind of an once
again an invitation this time coming
from Huts but is Rook B2 a three time I
mean Jeffrey can claim you're saying
Rook with Rook B2 Jeffrey can I don't
think yet no actually I think no he
cannot so this is one yeah and this is
two after Rook to B2 which was played if
he does play Queen to H4 then he can
claim so if Hans right now to play for
win it's only Rook E2 correct I mean
Hans can claim now Queen
H4 yes he can um yes Queen to H4 would
be three time repetition okay so Hans
can stop the clock one game that is not
going for three-time repetition is a
game of Karissa Yip uh versus ashria
wait wait let's let's just say with
there we go there we go okay with less
time Hans says no draw no dra he's a
fighter he doesn't want to repeat three
times Rook takes
E2
okay but by the way is Rook to E1 a move
no Rook to E1 you take on D3 Rook E8
King G7 that's not what I want exactly
but something along those lines with H2
H3 H3 the moment Rook takes
D3 and now I start to look at Queen B8
Shack and queen takes seven so perhaps
Queen B7
right try to uh go for my own pawns and
attacks Queen B7 if you take on D3 I
have ideas of Queen C8 and queen G4
maybe I can do a perpet Sor I'm going to
uh I'm going to change boards for a
second whoops
Hans
Neeman Jeffrey there we go uh Queen be
you don't want to make lft why doesn't
anybody want like lft here Queen B7 and
what did you what what did you say uh
Christian to be honest I don't even know
Jeffrey likes jeffre likes your I'm
telling you
Jeff Jeffrey thank you thank you it's
probably a good idea make because the
way I see it if you take the pawn with
the Rook right you're giving me the
option of Queen B8 check I mean for what
it's worth I'm just gonna put it on
there whose Pawn is more dangerous in
this ending Queen takes
A7 right because you're going to have a
c Pawn I'm actually not sure so Rook D1
let's Rook D1 first of all I also have
Rook D2 wait a minute why why don't I go
Rook B2 Queen G1 back but then I take
the pawn then I take yours and you take
mine and that's it yeah it's it's a draw
it's it's a draw right so sorry just for
the audience even though wait wait a
minute now I go C5 I I don't know well
that was that was the question I was
asking who part is more danger thank you
yeah let's have some fun no no but I
think it's mine okay C C4
C3 okay now I'm scared okay let's go C2
let's just try it out and Rook to D1
who's first me you got a queen bravo
bravo thank you now I guess I I take see
one and we make a draw yeah how do you
make a draw it's just a draw you're
fighting for the draw what did you mean
uh no funny um okay uh that that was fun
Queen E2 on the board H2 H3 not time is
ticking down right he has only six
minutes and still about 10 moves to make
okay we're going keep our eye on that
one once again we only have one result
in the open section leavon ronian and
Wesley so have made a repetition I
wanted to say that one game that's not
going into a repetition whatsoever is
the game of Carissa Yip our co- uh
tournament leader in the lady she's up
against a shria shria is shredding her
Queen side we left it more or less here
and I think this is just about to be
over actually it's uh it's it's enjoy
two pawns Advantage right now
recapturing the second one not only not
only that with compensation yes for
black for for for for black Bishop A2
was Ash's last move because well check
this out this bishop combination E5 E4
Knight D I mean it's all uh Karissa at
the moment and oops I think the idea is
now to go Queen H4 yeah Queen H
Checkmate oops
okay
problem good morning St
Louis in chess is there an whoops
whoopsy Daisy uh I think that was a
whoopsy daisy I I'm sure ashria in her
Mind's Eye was thinking that she wanted
to go Queen H yeah I mean you know
you're kind of blind by your own ideas
Queen G3 but now I can just pick up take
a rook on E1 thank you very much can I
go no actually no F4 doesn't make a lot
of sense CU that actually helps you with
Queen H3 that is true that is true so
let's just pick up the exchange that is
being yes I'm exchange up two
pawns very nice Pawn Center yeah she
grabbed the Rook you've got A3 as a way
of undermining the C3 Pawn you've got H6
when you need uh to De to cover a check
yeah
why it's it's all Carissa which means
that beum she's going to have to win to
keep the pace
and wow look at
that things are blowing up in this game
uh I think what in the world is
happening there uh right atusa got in I
think a very desirable break for herself
this move C4 C5 I think she's happy
about getting that in F7 F5 so shall we
have a look what would happen if we just
capture a lot of things takes takes
takes should I capture some more try to
take everything okay G takes right right
and should
I uh should I be playing for this
or I'm not sure what I should be playing
which what should I be playing for this
guy's weak right okay I got an idea okay
let's go C5 I'm spotting a pawn no you
want to actually take
that did you have to ask you're sneaky
sneaky guy you're a sneaky guy well
thank you thank you all right so I I
have to take on F5 with a rook right
that's the problem you will take with
the rook and uh that's actually very
unpleasant this D5 idea it was a moment
ago right if you take with the pawn
right okay if even if you take with the
Rook the idea what I was hoping to
achieve uh uh positionally speaking I
was trying to secure the E4 Square for a
knight so I don't know if maybe I should
play G5 as a means of securing it aren't
you worried about losing that pawn if I
take take Rook G5
yes Knight
F6 just one move from Knight E4 I was so
close capping my ro oh yes I really
thought I was going to do it too uh yes
uh good point uh I just don't have the
the timing yet but that is the idea
anyway of of of trying to um create an
outpost and for beum again she's coming
in Ty for first and Karissa is just
wiping out the with the black pieces
Carissa is doing she just she doesn't
care that she's supposed to have a
disadvantage with black black it doesn't
matter she has adant
right and she's looking very well to win
her game so beim needs to try to catch
up and for arena same story I mean
trying to keep Pace with the two ladies
in front of her that's a challenge uh
but I thought she was actually really
outplaying uran uh and she did she did
go with that whole
G5 and she did it a different way she
didn't go H5 G4 uh Arena just went for
G4 and look at this G3 takes
takes uh and we're talking about the
arena Crush versus Ru and this position
blow blew up as well and the times are
17 minutes for white and um 21 for black
and you know what's very interesting for
me is if you look at move 15 in this
game just uh going all the way back just
go to move 15 yes and look at white
pieces how they are positioned and how
black pieces are positioned okay and
then we just flip to the current
position may
just and you see that why didn't really
change much the pieces are almost at its
same squares but black position is
completely different there is attack
there is you know pressure on G file
yeah so it looks like white was moving
around but not accomplishing much
whereas black just launched an attack on
the king side and it looks like a very
very successful attack at that because
Arena's thinking to herself if it's my
turn don't even ask me twice I want to
take on F2 and this bishop diagonal
keeping in mind The Rook is also doubled
up I want to take on F2 play Knight
takes A4 then Knight goes somewhere and
Bishop crashes in on G2 and it's to
quote Walter Brown Hakim mate so the
question is can I
because if I move with the Knight on F2
whenever E4 Falls game's over so just
just to throw it out there the
suggestion is again this whole Knight
takes E4 that's a Tempo against the
queen I'm not really too sure to where
to go here do you want to take the
Knight or do you even you want to blast
I I don't think you
win okay well let's take the Knight yeah
let's take the Knight well I do have F6
to defend I mean want it's really funny
it just this Knight ideas Knight
F1 and oh my goodness oh my goodness so
Knight have three let's try to save
everything somehow and by the way this
one is a
draw H Tri all he could not to make a
draw but as reluctant as sometimes you
just play a good game and nothing to be
nothing to be done uh by the way who
claimed the draw was it Hans who stopped
the clock and claimed the draw or was
Jeffrey the
first ah guess what Hans was the one to
say okay enough's enough draw all right
Arena's looking very good we like her
position very much um tatv we that was
that whole F5 sequence I'm looking at
this queen on A1
scratching not a big fan not a big fan
of talia's uh Queen on A1 one but what
if I try to play with white Bishop F3
you know trade that Bishop you do have a
weakness on
E6 well if you trade the bishop on D5
and
I uh okay so who who so whose turn after
Queen a rook C6 okay Bishop
F3
Rook uh B6 oh you want to go to B2 and
the whole idea was that you kind of guys
help me yes I don't want to interrupt
this one but I do believe that Fabiano a
big match against Sam saan I believe
also repetition right now well it's
funny yesterday we saw so many decisive
games 10 decisive games out of the 12
played five in each tournament were
decisive and we've already started with
two draws you're saying we might have a
third the last few moves have been Rook
to C5 Knight to E6 Rook to C3 back
Knight to f8 so right now if Rook to C5
comes along once again they might be
ready to shake hands it's just one of
those positions where neither side it's
like there's a standoff we both have
positioned our pieces to their maximum
and we can't do
anything right okay sometimes just
there's not much more in that position
uh game we haven't followed for some
time Andrew Tang versus Ray Robson
they're not doing very well but that
doesn't mean they're not fighting hard
and uh you know Ray robson's game from
yesterday is I promise you going to be
immortalized in tactical attacking books
one of tyal sacrifices on F7 that's
going to be beautiful beautiful
beautiful uh again a very balance game
nothing too much going on Sam Shanklin
dare I say sam
shank he just never gets tired rook and
game after ren game he was so proud he
present
his book and said yes sir please I want
to hear some criticism you know like
look at it and I'm saying Rook endings
is all this guy plays he don't give me a
book we play
favorites I guess we are I guess we are
I have to say I did get a book
so am I the only one that didn't get a
book I mean come on he look he ran out
you know friends and family first that's
what it's all about have to uh Grill him
in in our next interview right um even
though it's an extra Pond for uh White
theoretically
speaking uh Sam really should draw this
that's an easy draw yes why is it so
easy is it just that the the the
threshold the margin of a draw is always
so high well not really but there's no
imbalances right the pawns are on the
same side the only way for you to create
something is to either play the move H
but even after you play the move H4 you
will still have to go F5 at one point in
time and unfortunately once we eliminate
more and more pawns we're just going to
get down just to give you kind of an
example I I stay on the second rack I
always stay on the second rack you can
give me a check that's this is the
maximum I can get that's the maximum
right at some point you have to go F5
because if you do try to go here first
of all I can even go Rook to E2 and stop
you altoe okay right if you go here then
I have to go here and you have to do
this all over again but it doesn't
really help you too much right so by the
way H4 was played let's just get the
maximum once again finally give me a
real maximum give me
my yeah give me my king on e4 let's say
where do you play where where where do
king D5 but now I attack the Pawn King
E5 Rook F5 that's it oh I want
you I wanted to go King F4 so I can play
rook3 that's it yes cuz you have to stay
close to the pawn and then I go back you
go here and if you do try to go here the
problem is okay I'm not going to
exchange that's the one thing obviously
I'm not going to exchange this end game
is the only one that I'm losing in this
iteration so I'm just going to go Rook
to G6 you're going to have to at some
point just check me fair so we're
expecting it's an easy draw and Sam
definitely will not lose this one I have
to say after yesterday's disaster that
was not an easy one oh against that was
amazing way comp Rook H1 that was so
disappointing for Sam because he just
missed that one move but the critical
move that just decided the end game
exactly yeah this one and by the way
look his and we were discussing this
with Fabiano as well yesterday over
dinner Sami is very confident in his
Rook endgame skills and whenever he gets
a technical position or at least
something that he thinks it's a
technical position he plays very fast it
backfired against him yesterday against
because he got to that position he
missed the move Rook to H1 it's not
going to backfire today and uh as we see
this game heading towards a draw in
studio we have Jeffrey Christian over to
you Jeffrey welcome uh back to the
studio tell us your strategy for today's
game against Hans is definitely a player
that is hot right now in this
competition uh stringing up victories
one after the other you were slowing
down in last few rounds what was the
strategy going in B
round yeah Hans was definitely in good
form and me not so much so the idea was
uh just to play something solid um I
think he caught me off guard with with
Bishop G4 in the opening which I wasn't
anticipating and after that I just tried
to liquidate things that was our
impression as well because this bishop
G4 is more of an off bit line but
generally with the help of the engines
nowadays is considered to be okay did
you analyze this at home at any point in
history yeah I have many Blitz Games
here I tried knight2 as well Knight E2
or or F3 and it's all more yeah Knight
E2 let's say Knight E2 uh cd5 H3 Bishop
H5
C4 you can see that I have some games
here yes Jeffrey versus raay Robson and
these are Blitz Games you were
saying that one maybe was rapid but uh
in general it's you know it's a normal
position I could have went for this I
wasn't sure which to try but in the end
I selected the game variation but I
think he played it very well he played
it very well and at this point were you
worried at all after the queen landed on
F2 he was trying to create something he
was trying to keep the game going were
you getting worried at any
point uh maybe slightly I don't know uh
perhaps after bch like in the the game
Bishop F6 gf6 Rook
B2 I wonder if he could try something
else besides Queen H4 cuz he had he had
either Queen E3 or queen
D4 not sure which but let's say queen
yeah Queen E3 I guess it's it's still
okay after R bb1 this is what I also
saw
um yeah it looks kind of unpleasant but
in the end maybe it's fine yeah and it
didn't seem like you or him made any
mistakes and finally you found not this
repetition but this transition into a
technical drawish end game Jeffrey how
would you assess your performance so far
obviously you probably are not happy
especially with the last couple of games
what are you going to do to turn things
around yeah it's not been great so far
but just got to keep going um tomorrow
another tough game with black I think
against Wesley so take it one game at a
time and see see what I can do that
seems like a very uh good strategy
Wesley will see sorry Jeffrey we'll see
you tomorrow we'll see you against
Wesley tomorrow W good luck Jeffrey
indeed and uh we just getting word that
in the game between Sam shank uh pardon
me as
um fa and Sam that Sam can determine
whether or not uh draw agreed right so
if he goes to Frank right now and says
okay with the move Knight to f8 the
position will be repeat it three times
but he's thinking okay all right maybe
he's trying to more 16 minutes for Fabio
21 minutes but I think they already
they're close to uh the second time
control they're at move 38 no
problems um I was a bit surprised by the
game of laner we'll come to that in a
second I'm just looking at Nasi versus
Alice Lee uh this game looks very
balanced as trades are taking
place in the game of laner when we left
it we were thinking that uh after Queen
takes we had this long uh calculation of
Bishop takes H6 sacrificing a rook uh
and uh black King essentially runs away
even though there are some sharp uh
choices after the move C4 there's this
uh KY little move Queen A3
covering f8 so you can get King D7 but
uh we didn't like the fact that after
Queen C2 Knight E3 Queen takes B2 Rook
F1 we thought the move Bishop E6 would
just give an overwhelming advantage for
laner shocking uh to my eyes he took he
just decided to kind of liquidate and
keep that extra Pawn Yeah but this
Bishops of opposite color positions I
mean even though I look hey look I I I
love the extra Pawn don't get me wrong
but Bishops of opposite color positions
with you
know Bishop B6 could you know just tie
down that majority it's not going to be
that easy uh to put the Pawns in motion
is I mean
I'm I'm saying I I I do like linear's
position I I think he has the advantage
but I think this is a hard slog I don't
think that's just you don't feel that a
three against one on the queen side well
again if I get my Bishop on B6 no I
think so let's say I go Rook D7 okay
because the Rook is attacked yeah good
point right it certainly
was and Bishop B6 yeah you're right the
bishop is kind of strong there it's
stopping the pawns from moving forward
exactly and we have another special
guest in studio over to you Christian
Leon welcome uh to the show this
tournament so far hasn't uh been yours
but definitely still plenty of Chess to
be played tell us your assessment of
this event so far and what are you going
to do to uh turn it around as
well well uh you know I'm learning
trying new things so uh it's a part of
the process you know part of the
learning process so sometimes the result
don't come uh but uh you know as long as
there's a plan you know I I kind of uh
see the light in the end of the tunnel
speaking of the process and trying to
learn new things yesterday you uh played
the Sicilian we haven't seen you play
the Sicilian in a very long time in a
classical uh game of chess how did you
come up with that
decision I thought um
I have some you know events coming so um
that are going to be like um open uh you
know shingan system so like an open
tournament so you know you need to play
the cilian in a shingan tournament
therefore uh I think um you have to
practice uh especially in such an
important tournament so when the
pressure is there yeah you you you need
to try and and play the the new openings
you know it's easy to play new openings
in a Blitz game where nothing really
matters but uh you need to practice this
type of openings U that are new to you
in in a combat kind of simulation mode
absolutely tell us the story of uh
today's
game it was um fairly solid game I was
trying to put a little bit of pressure I
think um uh uh I I didn't really
remember what I was intending to do in
this particular line but I thought you
know it's just a position uh I've played
this uh type of structures a lot uh with
black so let's try to be on a white side
of it and uh I think I managed to to put
put up a little bit of pressure but uh
then I think Wesley played well yeah
than a bit imbalanced at some point
right after this exchange of the Pawns
in the center E5 Queen D5 how did you
assess it at this this point what were
the plans for both sides in your
opinion I thought it was kind of
interesting you know with this A3 and
putting this strategical uh threat so I
mean uh he he he also has this Rook F4
instead of Knight D7 which is very
interesting you know just uh kind of
forcing me to play uh Knight B4 takes
takes a b Queen D7 I thought it's very
very complex strategically something
that uh I generally like to do you know
to just uh to
um game and enjoy it yes yes absolutely
and then he played this Knight D7 which
I felt was also interesting and then
after
C5 yeah it was kind of kind of uh
exciting here because Knight F5 I
thought Rook A6 from distance I thought
is the move but there I have this
interesting SE Point EXC me yeah yeah
yeah after C5 yeah that's all correct
mhm takes Knight G5 yeah oh Knight G5
and after yeah and and here so Rook A6
looks also very natural but there I have
this queen
G4 and Knight D3 and Knight
H7 which is which is very interesting
yeah Knight E1 Knight f8 and queen
G2 uh uh Queen G2 Knight G2 Rook
C8 mhm mhm yeah now it's some sort of a
race yeah he's going to try to go deep
yeah yeah yeah so kind of oh yeah I
didn't see D3 but I felt it was
fascinating position to to calculate all
of those satell this and uh quite often
as it happens you know um once uh my
oppent found the correct moves yeah know
there is not much you can do I thought
that the position is yeah rather yeah
rather solid yeah definitely a very
creative game today still plenty of
rounds to go uh we let you go get some
rest and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you very much thank you
uh leavon indeed that felt like almost a
game of losers chest there where
everybody was just capturing everything
going capture first yeah yeah yeah uh
well lanir still uh nursing that extra
Pawn looks like a the engine is saying
that he's completely winning minus three
right now wow minus three uh for the
simple fact that it seems like the ca
Pawn is actually going down Pawn is the
issue very quickly yeah so for example
if you try to go B6 I'll give you the
pawn oh going to go C5 yeah you take
I'll continue pushing and the problem is
C3 C2 is very threatening and it's very
difficult for you to stop it because
your pieces are on the other side of the
board the Queen is not defending against
this expansion anytime soon and if you
have to play moves such as Bishop to E1
yeah that's not it good luck with that
good luck with that right and if you go
Bishop to B4 for example I can continue
my play is very simple that's the
problem for white right now Rook to C1
for example I can continue you still
cannot touch that pawn you're not in
time right you get checkmated because
the queen on E5 protects against King H2
so this one is looking really really
good for linear and he's making the
Right Moves Rook to D3 activate
everything against once Bishop to B6
comes on the board C5 C4 and the play is
simple has been agreed draw as the
players uh confirm the repe ition with
the chief arborer Frank there um wasn't
intuitively obvious to me that lanir was
going to rush the C you know give up the
Aon run the C pond that's all you need
to do that but once you see it you go
yeah there you go that's what's going on
a lot of draws they're hard fought to be
sure a lot of action in the women
section actually let's go there uh no
results interestingly enough and I
wanted go to the game of because I would
beg him because she want a p if You'
like that if we she did back a little
bit okay so we left it with this
position was exploding after the move F5
I
wanted I think I tried uh pardon me to
take take and play D5 and kind of shut
the action down a little tou kept all
the tension see that's me I'm I'm trying
to resolve the tensions you know be calm
uncomplicate things un complicate things
and uh Tusa
is uh making it more tense takes takes
but very nice for be because suddenly
black has targets that big time and she
took advantage of a pin Knight to C5 yes
okay and Knight to
D3 well she's going to win the pawn back
the right Knight takes E5 King
D6 this is great I was just about to
point out that pawn is attacked and
check this one out too K and you
interrupted me and said King D6
protect the impossible you did it you
protected both pawns at the same time I
is Rook D1 Rook D1 still uh this Knight
C5 is kind of unpleasant nasty you
probably have to go back okay even
though okay so let's continue with that
variation yeah Rook D1 can I go Rook to
d8 no Knight F4 it's a problem Rook to
d8 Knight F4 check yeah let's keep going
let's keep going okay King
E7 do you take on G6 first or let's try
it King F6 let's take on d8 now you have
to right Knight takes d8 how is this end
game you have to go to H4 right or to f8
where do he
go with Trembling Hands
exactly my mouse family Mouse well but
wait a minute this should be okay King
F2
G4 you know T should be happy she'll get
a passer out of all of this business
it's not so easy for you to get in 96
yeah I was more wondering instead of
Rook d8 to play Rook B5 is that a
possibility I want to from the start yes
right here Knight C5 and Rook D7 I think
might be is that a problem King E7 you
still have King E8 right King F6 I
thought well King E8 uh you keep contact
with the
Rook uh King
F6 uh I'm trying to make a draw what are
you trying to do I want to take take and
take and I think I'm going to be but now
I do king D6 and our oh you go Rook G7
well I think you're making a draw for
sure right okay so Rook takes before but
I guess and Away you go um it's okay for
white so at this moment beam's a pawn up
but we think that there's enough
compensation in the position for white
to keep the balance okay let's let's try
a different variation right can we go E4
instead of King
D6 yeah I don't like the king D6 move
anymore because Rook D1 looks really
strong it's your move I know I take back
I'm happy I can do that as a
commentator take it
back and now King
D6 and now King D6 right dang okay okay
so you take that I do that's fine I'll
take on B4 okay so we both have fast
pawns you're going to have a PA and I'm
Pawn
up yes I can't argue it's a double pond
it's not the clean it's not the cleanest
I was waiting I was waiting still a
dirty shirt I was waiting for
that a clean pwn okay King F2 let's go
uh get okay ready Knight C5 whoops I was
going to get ready getting on my uh
knight3 running
shoes is is coming I understand I all
right so let's push push C5 C5 okay
let's offer a
trade ah you're bailing out I's see what
you're doing okay C4 no let's go let's
go C4 let's give him the H5 Pawn thank
you that's all I I know you want it I I
know I know I know all right you know I
feel like a little kid who looks at all
he you know at the Scholastics
tournaments you can see the the children
do that they trade their pieces and then
they count what's off the board three
five it's like neatly positioned next to
the exactly exactly a face off I just
took a right so let's see the board
right now
and it's uh now rugby 5 was by the way
if this Pawn was not on C7 if it was on
that's a clean PA then I'm not happy
camper here be problematic right yeah by
the way Rook B5 on the board so it's
possible the players will play into this
variation sorry the the the game I
really wanted to get to was Carissa
yip's game because Karissa has been just
like a bowling ball just going right
through the tournament field when we
left it she was an exch change to the
good I was curious to see if ashria
would get any compensation the bishop on
A2 you know what I mean the Knight is
jumping uh here we go King
H7 I understand decision she's ready to
kind of give back that exchange because
what she has she has two extra pawns
exactly she doesn't have to deal with
that night anymore because there can be
some sneaky stuff Knight G5 you know
Queen H3 I don't know right
right I like sneaky stuff I mean no uh
here we go here's the sneaky stuff Isa
is fishing a little bit she wants to
take the bishop and then uh crash down
on the H6 Pawn nice move F4 just cutting
off the bishop on
C1 oo look open look at that crafty move
uh well Karissa said look if you don't
want to take my Rook I'm going to move
move it check Knight E4 Rook f8 we've
caught up with the players it does look
like cariss has made a lot of progress
here with an extra exchange she looks
like a
favorite I wanted to go to Arena Crush
because when we left it we had this
crazy position that were two knights
were hanging the Knight on D4 was
hanging to the E5 Pawn as well here and
we thought that Arena was really and
good cruise control wow that's a nice
move you like that move Rook d8 that's a
visual takes takes Queen
H6
stop you know what we want to do right
we want to capture that Bishop
absolutely absolutely how could we not
capture the bishop Capt capture on D4
capture on
G3 please don't tell me I mean I go C3
yeah I mean it looks so natural it's
just so annoying that uh it doesn't win
right Rook
C3 Arena didn't do this what she did do
is play Queen H6 we're g to catch up
with the players very quickly and we
have this current position on the board
Queen F4 is Arena's move have they made
time control by the way uh no they're on
move 34 so still six moves to to make to
uh get to that time control okay
okay okay and that last
well Bishop E5 there's Queen D2 still
there's Queen D2 for a second I was
worried for the queen being trapped I I
hear you loud and clear I mean we're
we're on the diagonal of the king so a
move like Bishop E5 as well as Rook F3
by the way of course Queen takes F3 is
the issue there but you you you start
looking in those General directions okay
so what are you threatening right now if
I was black I would be I don't see what
you're threatening I'd be looking at
ideas of but what if I go Rook one to E3
right now and that's going to start
looking at Bishop E5 and where is your
queen going but also Rook to F3 exactly
I don't know I'm starting to like Ru
Yang's position quite a lot with this
move Rook on E1 to E3 right maybe uh
Arena underestimate
under well by the way Irena is down to
her last five minutes so this one
is crucial but guys this one is going to
go on for a while let's take a look at
uh the Anna zatonski versus Jennifer U
game as well let's move to that one
because I feel that one is going to be
over in just a second unless happened
here unless Anna sacrificed a rook I
don't like Black's King oh my goodness
so uh let's try to catch up quick Queen
B1 Knight B3 what a messy position
Bishop
H7 okay so we do give up The Rook on A1
to A7 no we don't what Rook
A7 you want to play C5 and cover the
seventh rank you actually play Le the
spirit of Le poki is alive this is how
you cover F7 he did this in the poly
gayeski variation of the naidorf uh but
what if I go Knight
G6 yes where is that King going after
Rook
D1 you take Queen F4 is a mating one
right unless I'm missing something no n
and one is easy to spot so if I go C5 I
take on D4 I capture with
Knight ah it's not made in one I have a
knight to retreat but but it's not good
but it's just not it made in one Rook
takes the now we understand this Rook
A7 but you're right there is G can go G4
if but I want something more again I'm
getting greedy maybe more than extra
Knight yeah more than that yes somehow
but okay maybe extra night is
enough Bobby but a night's a night uh
Rook A7 that okay I mean Anna must be
completely winning if Rook A7 is the
best move here she's played Knight G6
and black king is in this terrible
uh mating uh pattern how I only need to
find a check on the f file right just
any check on the file right so Rook
E3 uh sets up that mate idea right rook1
is such a nice natural move Rook e D1
yeah Rook E1 yes I agree but how do we
defend Rook E3 Rook E3 maybe Queen C6 or
something like that no Rook ad1 okay and
here we go Anna played rook ad1 and
she's looking to set up this Rook takes
and queen F4 and that could be C and wow
the curtain could close on Jennifer
right there uh you know hopes of re of
retaining her Championship are out the
door very important win for Anna because
she's going to be at three and a half
points trying to catch up with begim
and once again why is it so important as
we came into today's standings uh Kate
right so we have kis I even beg him to
here jov Four Points who are kind of
trying to run away but Anna zatonski if
she manages to win she will get three
and a half points and kind of start to
closely follow them exactly well that
leader group at the top Arena might be
over pressing uh as she
well let's just jump uh to Arena's we
think Anna zansi is going to win here we
also have current standings in the open
section so a lot of draws yesterday
everybody was was winning or losing
today the players got a little bit tired
maybe they want another rest day so they
have they can have a lot of decisive
games but we do think that lenir
Dominguez is winning against Mishra
lanir at three points a win today would
jump him up to Hans Neiman's uh score
and uh clear a tie for second yeah very
important game for him absolutely and
and Christian over to you well I think
we should stick with this Jennifer game
just because uh we might see a
resignation
well the problem is she only has a
couple of minutes at least she had a
couple of minutes when Anna played the
move R1 so right now she's probably down
to her last few seconds let's see what's
happening down to her last minute 1
minute and 10 seconds is Jennifer this
one is Boston yeah uh you you you play
C5 out of momentum and I once asked
Victor cooi uh he had this terrible
terrible position why he didn't resign
it and he said I didn't have the time
right I didn't have
enough so C you know you you you you
play on adrenaline Rook takes Knight
takes Queen check and you were
mentioning this move G4 uh Kate and well
there's nothing to do to be honest I
really want to get more greedy than this
I want to go Rook D3 after C5 I want to
go Rook F3 checkm that's that's the goal
yeah that's the goal I think uh Kate GRE
is not good so I'm Queen C6 or oh no
Queen C6 not that would be a so Queen A8
I like it right just to keep uh keep an
eye on the F3 Square who said g is not
good G is
great
right only on Wall Street by the way one
thing I liked about uh Anna's game was
she made a lot of forcing moves it was
everything check check attack and it's
always difficult to kind of face when
you see your opponent is just forcing
you to go into a line and you don't
really want to go to and by the way C5
on the board by Jennifer as you were
mentioning the clock sticking down for
Anna looks like she's about that Rook
her opponent's in time trouble you know
like uh very new for her exactly uh for
once the uh slipper is on the other uh
foot well she's in time for too but at
least her opponent is more in time
trouble and with a much more difficult
position by the way even though you
weren't satisfied with an extra Knight I
think I'm going to be very satisfied
Rook takes D4 no Rook d3s no none of
that just let's go for uh well I think
it's a pretty one position it can
actually be more even than the Knight
because then I want to recapture the
pawn and give you Checkmate yep yes and
she's going right for the line and for
Jennifer again the curtain closes on her
um 2023 national champ Championship
aspirations she if she loses this one
then as a defending Champion kind of
over right
right she's going to remain on two
points with Karissa going on five most
likely that's a big difference not to
mention any excuses certainly she
doesn't have that excuse she goes to
Harvard and she's won this Championship
still being a student a full-time
student at Harvard but twice yeah so
that's impressive it really is like how
do you manage that that's you have to be
extraordinarily gifted G4 uh
Anna is just is there another
alternative Anna is looking at something
maybe Rook F Rook
E5 no I think she's just double checking
if maybe there is something on that
diagonal let me try this she to G she to
play G yeah she's played it because a mo
for a moment there you know Rook e five
does look very good maybe Queen C8 the
game yeah well then I'm gonna play G4 so
it's like I go G4 you go Queen C8 and I
don't take the night I go Rook E5 yeah
and I force you to play a move maybe you
don't want G4 on the board this this is
the vulture in you talking yeah just
picking the B
trying is there any marrow it's over is
there any
marrow uhuh G4 well the thing is now
Queen C8 I think I can even take on F5
you take on F5 and queen D6 you're still
not getting away from the no that was
what uh Kate was mentioning it's not
that I just win a night it's like that
the attack still is a flame I was even
thinking about after Queen C8 I capture
Knight you capture and maybe Knight h8
you know I want your queen to capture
that Knight to get away from defending
that pawn on f8 that's the real vou real
vouchers
right grab that horse in the corner good
luck and by the way that's one of those
you you know your opponent plays Knight
h8 against you and it's like the entire
tournament Hall collectively stands up
and comes over to your game the moment
that you're facing a move like Knight h8
because if you had to go King f8 then I
have Queen D6 and that's Checkmate Al uh
it's all over it's all over I think
we're about Queen d8 Again Jennifer
doesn't have enough time on the clock to
resign queen d8 I'm just going to I
believe we may see that Knight h8 move
we might well I take on F5 what do you
do yeah that's the first thing if you
take I probably will take back even
though Knight h8 I mean so what can I do
what what what move can I make I
actually not sure I think you take back
on F5 but then I take back on F5 and
then no because that allows Queen F6 but
Queen takes D5 Queen takes D5 right but
I want Knight H that's me that's me stop
it stop it that's made it's over 88
we've got 88 on the brain oh my goodness
the Dutch have a wonderful expression
for that by the way idea fix they get a
fixed idea you know night H but yeah
idea fix a uh this one's over guys uh
let's just see uh we may see a handshake
soon uh but Carissa also she's yeah know
she's doing incredibly well Crush game
so Arena Crush game
um we left it just here Arena just
played this move Queen F4 and her Queen
is dancing and prancing but it might
have been a little trouble after Rook E1
to E3 to F3 she did play the move Bishop
E5 but Rook D2 and she's out of trouble
now suddenly uh she vacated that the
diagonal King H that king must be so
relieved now finally out of
exactly and uh theyve made time control
or not um no they have two more moves to
make two more moves to make uh First
Impressions wh pieces are not they
starting to struggle the bishop on D3 is
not very great just staring at its own
pawns I the bishop on E5 is position
well that's probably the best piece so
far but it can be kicked away very
easily and you know there's these x-rays
uh you start to see cooperation between
the black pieces Harmony yes uh you know
you just kind of are you doing good are
you doing good yes yes you get a lot of
nods of the head yes and you do see
Knight G4 and again I think uh White is
the one uh struggling here I think one
thing that maybe black has to be careful
about is for The Rook on D2 not being
trapped right that's the only kind of
important job like we'll have to focus
on exactly one other thing I mean I can
see the troubles starting to pile up if
I'm in Arena shoes I'm desperately
interested in the move A5 do me a favor
take that pawn let me put my Bishop on
C5 so that I can pin the Knight a moment
ago we saw that the Knight was in this
pin no longer if I can put the bishop on
C5 Arena she looks good I I think that
arena is a favorite at this EXA moment
to win the game by the way by the way
let's look at let's go back to Theon
game Rook F2 no we have KN
on Knight on h8 oh my goodness there's a
tactic for arena Rook F2 and Knight G4
on a tap uh Anna's game or are you Anna
no this is yeah Anna's game against
Jennifer you Knight H just being played
and um I think there Checkmate
Unstoppable maybe she's just trying to
repeat the position for a second repeat
the position okay not King f8 because of
Queen D6 right that is clear that looks
very good so you have to go King and
then Bishop F5 right game over well that
finishes the job that's for
sure y That's nice King E7 King E7 and
Bishop F5 keeping in mind that uh Anna
zansky had one
of her career best results uh the Ken
Cup champion of the Ken Cup coming into
this competition saying look if I can
win the Ken's cup I mean she was the
last seed in Ken's cup and she just she
won I think one round ahead right yes
G with one round to spare uh she did
play after King E7 by the way Bishop F
five on the board
G5 okay okay last trick
rcks look you can take that Knight it's
fine I know just go Queen G4 or
something
EXA and jenifer's body posture tells me
everything I need to know about this
position she can't look Queen E4 or
queen G4 queen4 why not centralize the
queen looks good I think that's it I
think we going to see handshake now I
don't see anything
else you take on h8 you get mated it's
two extra pieces now right
if you don't think yeah if you're going
to put it that
way two extra pieces now and our
congratulations to Anna a big victory uh
for her as uh you've got
Arena's well perhaps we're seeing some
sort of uh
repetition right Rook to B2 followed by
Rook to uh D2 after Bishop to E5 maybe
that's it why would Arena a draw well
actually Arena was worse a moment I know
you were showing me that move Rook E3
but even here if I try to go for Bishop
to C7 and try to go for the pawn uh the
engine is saying white is doing quite
well really I'm so shocked right right
so Bishop to F4 the question is is she
going to go for this draw with Rook to
B2 maybe bishop to E5 maybe I even have
ideas of Bishop to C1 where do you put
that Rook okay you go here right yeah
then I go here how wait wait wait where
is it so here I go here and maybe right
now you're just taking and taking on e4
that might be enough yes yes yes no I
don't want this I don't want to allow
the opening of the light Square Bishop
because then I have huge problems on G2
none of that okay so Rook to B2 is the
move that she played and if she goes
Bishop to E5 I'm wondering oh no now I
take Knight G4 that was the tactic I was
mentioning yeah so maybe from a
practical perspective arena is still in
full position in this one by objectively
kind of equal at Talia cantes game
against Abraham
okay because that was the crazy F5 uh
game you were
saying black had a weak Pawn on E6 I
remember you telling me about the weak
Pawn true and now I see a white Pawn on
E6 and I sort of like how did white get
a white Pawn on E6 in this position well
we're about to find out here we
go rookies I like this Knight kind of
movement F1 E3 to improve it yes you
have this but aren't you walking into
F4 are you oh wow so that's two pieces
for a rook tell I don't like that move
anymore no too late you already did it o
that was a really tatev is taking over
look it's like everything is hanging
here it just blew up oh but come on this
Pawn on C3 is so massively strong you
would love to involve your queen into
play but from A1 unfortunately
everything is covered I would have to go
Queen B1 Queen H7 but Queen B1 The Rook
is there yeah the queen is is trapped
trapped yeah and tat thinks oh she's
she's got time Rook F3 King E8 is on
theard Rook F3 King E8 is on the board
to just put her King in the because this
queen this Queen's not going to h8 or G8
or anywhere then one day C2 is going you
know what you might even play Rook B2
and just to make sure the
queen never never gets
out this is this is all T she turned it
around completely 93 I mean I heard you
when you were saying 93 and gosh it does
look
good and that was just an oversight it
was a so maybe there just had to be play
like F4 or something and then continue
with that Knight E3 move just to make
sure I don't allow that sacrifice
exactly the sacrifice work wonder maybe
yeah it works wonders for tatev and
we've got this position I think E7 came
on the board as Talia is desperate
because T Talia would be really happy if
t recaptured with the Rook Rook takes E7
so she can finally get that Queen out of
the corner queen that would be like just
a a a joy to have uh some checks in the
position I would call it the joy well
you know I mean you're happy for the
little things yes yes thank you you know
exactly exactly I mean the problem is
after Queen B1 I go Knight B2 and that
kills your your queen again and you go
okay go ahead and have a check on J you
can have a check it's a spike check you
report but no no no no don't take that
don't take that uh on E7 no stay there
exactly because in fact you you have all
the time in the world uh Rook f8 check
isn't a threat uh a moment ago you just
gave me the idea of Knight B2 what is
wrong with that move Knight B2 kind of a
takes c three Rook takes C3 but then you
take on D1 but then Rook C8 check yeah
yeah now it gets a little bit unpleasant
okay Queen
B3 Queen B3 right she's also focused oh
but wa do I have Rook takes D2
here wait a second oh my goodness
because if you capture with Pawn I have
rook f8 and finally the queen is getting
out the corner that might actually be
something you don't take the queen no I
play Rook
f8 oh my goodness takes D2 go this could
be a blunder and another big turnaround
a Tat's getting nervous I she found it
oh no my goodness what a turn of events
I mean tat was just playing Queen B3 to
put on the finishing touches of a
position she had complete control over
chess is brutal oh this is panic time
right now the problem is Queen to B1 is
met by Rook to D1 and change up whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Queen
B1 on the
board Rook f8
again oh and queen takes G7 we were
talking about the queen in the corner
doing nothing
nothing okay just a second a Miss by the
way that was the 40th move so right now
TV is wait a second trade and C2 yes you
would think so you would think this is
winning until you see this
move wait but Rook takes C7 and I have
Rook
E3 I would love you to kind of over
still not over I take so wait a minute
Rook E7 I have
Rook yes I have Rook C1 and that's
enough wow wow what a turn of events
guys oh my goodness this was the last
move wow this was move 40 do you
know in my day move 40 was the most
feared move it was the last move of time
control and so many mistakes took place
you know you were crossing the Finish
Line you made the time control bam blund
Talia made 40th moved mistake yesterday
against begging when she captured that
pawn with the rook and then the game was
over on spot Rook takes D2 We we just
witnessed uh wow an amazing amazing
turnaround and I think that move Rook
takes D2 is just absolutely stunned but
this is absolutely devastating for Tat
because she had such a controlling
position just go King to E7 and look at
her I mean she's just sheer absolutely
shattered right now and for Talia Talia
this is like the most extraordinary
thing she's had winning positions and
she's spoiled them spoiled them spoiled
today she gets completely outplayed
blender blender blender she's heading
towards a loss and suddenly she's
granted a victory it's a remarkable
Queen B1 check on the board only move
and what a a game uh yeah very important
game because we see Talia santz with
only one and a half point being on that
11th place but whenever she wins that
really brings her back to the tournament
because we have a lot of players with
two and a half points exactly and forat
she was hoping to join that Elite group
at the very top TR to catch up with the
leaders Kar and jonava and she had that
on the board she was completely winning
did Queen B1 check on the board uh Rook
D1 only move why is tal even
thinking made the 40th move she's made
the
now it's time to relax get a sip of some
tea or something like that think about
the position and then play the most
obvious moment doubtless she is thinking
about Rook D1 C2 and she's got this
whole line uh she's just working out the
details of this and the problem is with
the Rook on D1 the king is not even
going there anymore oh trying to cross
the def it's over yes with a rook on D1
it's even easier that's made in one que
of
I was trying to cross the defile and I
forgot that you know even though the
Rook is pinned to the King still oh no
this Rook takes D2 wow devastating what
a game
changer and uh as we kind of reveling
over the outcome of this game Anna
zansky in studio Christian over to you
Anna welcome back to the studio what an
amazing Victory with the white pieces
and it started off uh slowly with that
idea of Queen B3 early on in the opening
tell us the story of that
idea okay uh I didn't expect this uh
line from Jennifer and uh I played I
think in first Ken cup versus Hara this
line but I completely forgot what I was
doing and in this lines it's great you
can just like invent Theory play like
normal moves and in the middle just
general understanding so Queen B was
already no preparation I think she never
played Bishop before or I missed maybe
right and but you mentioned you played
this move Queen to B3 so she probably
should have known did I play I don't
remember I don't remember
play in the no no she she played Bishop
before she played Bishop before but I I
I don't remember what I was doing got it
got it got it so this is game first
Karen SC it's four years ago right she
got taken back by this move Queen to B3
because she thought for a while and then
she played this move Knight to C6
now the game continued after that it
looked like some sort of a regoin
situation uh but perhaps a better rosin
for you right yeah yes and it was like
many interesting ideas uh which was
behind the scene instead of cine I
considered E4 right away but then I just
scared I cannot explain why I didn't
play E4 instead of cine and for here
maybe it was better I was thinking E4
here yeah here E4 right way it's
interesting oh oh okay it's not good no
because of this feel that I need to
Queen A2 your sense definitely played uh
in your favor in this one and now take
advantage of this Bish Pawn D3 with
Knight G6 I see I see yeah but General I
have feeling that I have to Castle first
and then make active actions in the
middle no that was the right right
feeling for sure oh could you please go
back could you please go back and I
think for her it was
interesting interesting to take on C4
and played Queen D5 and maybe F5 okay
and this was probably
better here yeah take take take and
queen D5 Queen E2 F5 to try to stop you
from playing E4 in the center yes yes or
play this position maybe with Pawn on A5
was was also possible maybe it's even
better to have Pawn on A5 of course like
I mean I mean instead on A4 to have this
position with black Pawn on a five right
after Castle just take take and do the
same thing after Castle take take que D5
the same thing with spawn on A5 yeah I
thought it was better for here probably
a better option but still the game
continues the game is very very balanced
now where did you feel like you're
taking over the initiative at which
point did you feel secure in your initi
I was like secure I was after move only
after she took Pawn on D4 Rook takes D4
okay yeah because here was very
interesting I was not sure could you
please go back instead of okay oh plus
five I was
right
yeah yeah because it was also very
interesting could like one move back and
uh so instead of Bishop takes F4 I was
thinking I spent a lot of time okay
Knight B3 thinking about Bishop H7 first
okay Bishop Bishop H7 King G8 and uh
Bishop takes F4 of course if Rook takes
F4 it's on my favor right to have King
on H app but I didn't like Bishop F3
very good Tak F3 and yes maybe bishop G3
here and Bishop G3 just Knight A1 I
didn't like
yes no that was very well Cal I have I'm
exchange I should definitely have some
compensation okay Bishop F4 it's not the
move I want to play so or maybe here yes
so that's why I was thinking I should
take Bishop F4 that's what I did in the
game but after after this all option she
had this chance to play King f8 which of
course was better than King h8 here Rook
F6 yes rookus F6 and I think I would
just play something normal like Queen D3
oh wow I was on fire Queen D3 and just
play I will have
compensation
yep great compensation by the way have
some compensation great compensation
maybe more uh than just simple
compensation maybe you're just simply
better right
now yeah much better I think it's like
computer say like small Advantage but
for human beings it's very hard to
defend especially we both R time
pressure yeah yeah and after Rook takes
D4 as you nicely pointed out after Rook
D4 I already thought the S might be
winning this is it somewhere yes yeah
yeah and you conducted the attack uh
brilliantly after that never gave her a
chance to get back into the game an
congratulations you had a great event at
the Ken cup you're starting to pile up
some victories in this one are you
starting to have some dreams about
getting that National Championship once
again I'm trying not not to dream
because sometimes when you dream when
you think about it you relax yes this is
my case so I'm like trying to be like
cautious and uh I'm trying to put less
pressure on myself because before I was
always fighting for like top top places
and uh now I just want to enjoy the game
continue playing and uh with less
pressure as is it used to be well keep
it up you're doing great
job thank you Anna I have just one quick
question for you if you don't
mind today you had this uh rather unique
experience you had more time on the
clock than your opponent your opponent
was in time
trouble this is actually only for a
couple moves like entire game I was down
on down on time not at the end only by
the end yes unfortunately how did it
feel to see your opponent sometimes for
me I'm just like less confidence and I
cannot make decision and I'm afraid to
lose something when you like blunder it
like maybe I blundered more pieces than
anyone in this tournament maybe iena
like because I'm playing chess for how
many years right for 30 or even more
more
than uh like more most of the players
here live on
the and uh so I need to like force
myself to make a move to believe in my
calculations and I'm very happy after
such games I think I will uh I will be
more confident all right Anna thank you
very much uh and congratulations by the
way we're going to be taking a short
break as uh we leave you with an
interview with uh uh Sabina who had uh
caught up with Alice Le but just a note
we do do have a result right Sam
Shanklin did uh draw his game yes yeah
that was V we did not expect much from
that one right that was the three pawns
uh the extra Pawn but the Rook ending
was a draw uh enjoy this interview
between Sabina and Alice Lee we'll see
you on the other side of the
break Alice thank you so much for
joining me today I want to ask you a
little bit about your chess upbringing
there's been a lot talked about you in
the media but I want to hear it again
from you I started playing chess when I
was six years old um so my brother was
going to the school chess club and uh I
went to lawn also because my parents
just wanted to drop us up at the same
time um so after I started playing in
the chess club I was actually like one
of the very worst and uh for me it was
just I lost a lot I was kind of upset
but um as I kept uh actually not losing
every single game I became more
motivated and eventually played in uh my
first rated tournament uh that summer
and from there I think it was just I
really loved the game which allowed me
to continue to uh enjoy chess while
playing it very nice and how did you get
into playing a lot online and how do you
combine that with u studying over the
board yeah um so I think especially in
the recent years there's been a lot of
uh new chess resources both online and
also books published um so for me I did
go over some uh books for example the
100 end games you must know um and
Mauricio flor's Pawn structures book um
I also used like uh some online tools
for example chess Tempo and chess AO um
I think they have a lot of great
resources and for me uh I think
especially in this new generation uh
where everything is just so much
stronger it's really great to have all
these new resources and you're spending
a lot of time online could you give me
an approximate U amount of time that you
spend per day working on chess um so
actually this year I'm doing online
school so it makes it flexible for my
schedule um so I guess before high
school started I was spending like a
couple hours a day on chess sometimes
more especially during the summer when I
was playing in a lot of tournaments uh
now the high school is started uh it's
more work um so I have to I guess find a
new balance since for me it's my first
year and I haven't really had to do
something like this in the past um but I
hope that uh at least I'll be able to
find some sort of balance between school
work and chess and I'll be able to at
least play well in this tournament
you've had some amazing results lately
congratulations for winning gold medal
uh at the women's world team
championship how was that how did you
feel that moment yeah so that was
actually like the first tournament that
I played in uh like internationally on
uh that stage so I think it was really
great for me to be able to do so well
there and of course it was like a really
great experience to be playing on the
first Bo against such strong players um
I I definitely wasn't expecting to uh
win the gold medal there I was just
hoping you know I could at least do okay
um but uh for me it was great that uh I
was able to have like really good
results and it was my first like really
really strong it was a really great
experience for me do you feel nervous at
all or did you feel at that time nervous
because you're you know representing the
United States and it was your first
competition of this kind yeah I mean uh
so beforehand I actually thought I was
playing on the second board so I was
like okay not as much pressure and then
when I went there I like oh I'm playing
number one okay um so it is a team event
and there's something nice which is that
um even if you don't have your desired
result uh you can still hope that your
teammates also do well um of course
there's a little bit more pressure as
well because you want to win for your
team um but for me I was just like
trying to focus game at the game and I
was able to like find I guess a good
start and then after that I think I just
got a some good results very very
awesome congratulations again for that I
want to ask ask you one more thing
regarding this tournament um so last
year as you mentioned maybe your result
wasn't as great but you've had a great
uh year where you've improved a lot um I
think you supposed to get your
International Master title very soon and
this year you're one of the favorites do
you feel any pressure at all or have you
been able by now to deal with all your
emotions and are you just going to take
it a day a game with yeah uh so last
year I think a lot more inexperienced
and this year I've played in like a lot
more strong tournaments so I have
slightly more experience I mean for me I
guess I am one of the top se's but I
don't think I'm like the very favorite
so that's something that's kind of nice
because I don't have so much like
pressure that everybody expects me to
win um and I guess for this tournament
well I think winning would be nice I
it's also extremely hard because the
field is so strong um and for me I'll
just take it one game at a time and try
to play my best very nice thank you so
much Alice I wish you good luck and
looking forward to your games
[Music]
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping around
schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the United States I think
if I look at my own career and I look at
American TR and joh we in a much better
place than we were 15 years ago and so
the contributions have been immense and
of course it's all thanks to Dr Jun
singfield and Ro
singfield I would say that St luou CH
Club is like a rock in the ocean of
Chess and we know that it's it's there
it is there it will be there I think it
sense a hope that the game of chess will
always stay Al flat by the mere fact of
its existence I think it it it sense
positive waves across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership today the World
Chess Hall of Fame located in the heart
of St Louis's historic Central West End
want to know why chess has intrigued
people around the world for nearly 1,500
years stop by and learn about the impact
of Chess from our three floors
showcasing the art culture and history
of the game the World Chess Hall of Fame
has something for everyone to enjoy for
more information on current exhibits
please visit World Chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and right chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store or make sure to check
out Q Boutique stl.com for a wide
variety of gifts for everyone to
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
today
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the 2023 US national
championships we're in round six and we
have a lot of results especially in the
open section but let's first start in
the women's as we have two decisive
games taken away
Kip oh she's actually still playing
pardon me so we have Anna zatonski oh I
Won Won I thought Carissa won finished
the G uh so Anna zatonski won against
Jennifer you very poor win because now
she's at three and a half points
absolutely and if we imagine Karissa
having one uh she will be at Five Points
uh ashria still struggling with a half
Point beam could potentially tie Carissa
with a win and in the open section we I
know we got a lot of draws yeah we have
a lot of draws here look at that uh but
Fabiano is keeping his lead four and a
half points closely followed by Hans
nean uh with four points exactly I
thought lanir was going to win and catch
Hans that's not the case Mishra is uh
fighting very very well to keep the Half
Point as we see a shot of the tournament
Hall World Chess Hall of
Fame and once again we just saw chrisa
walking up and she looked happy she
catch her in the studio uh just looking
at the remaining four games of the
ladies again um two decisive results no
decisive results in the open looking at
Arena uh game and every time I talk
about the game I and you know the
computer like contradicts everything I
say it's like Arena's worse you know and
I liked her position I still like her
position I think that she's doing
fabulously well well fabulously maybe an
exaggeration but you know this is a very
nice Rook this is a very nice Bish yeah
but once the the other rookin know
disappeared from the second rank true I
don't feel like that uh that attack is
now strong for a BL okay well let me
just throw out a move you tell me what
you think of this move I'm G to play A5
again it's it's my desire to weaken your
control like this would be a dream like
we could agree that you don't really
want to play B5 maybe this Knight will
go there maybe the bishop will go there
maybe the Knight will jump to G4 so I'm
just going to ask you a question what
are you going to do on the queen site
it's a very good question well thank you
very much so let me first kick away your
Rook so King F2 King F2 okay so
unfortunately The Rook is going where
okay G4 I'll be obstinate
stubborn and take over your PA and again
you know I'm asking questions very
question because now I want to play
Bishop C3 or Bishop D4 but I understand
what you mean suddenly like there are a
lot of weaknesses in White's position
right it's starting to be the case and
again it's because I see this
coordination of The Rook on G3 the
bishop on E7 hitting the pawn on B B5 B4
and uh something uh there for arena and
by the way I if gissa is going to be
winning game after game after game she
needs to keep Pace she did not play A5
by the way Knight G4 was
her choice Knight
G4
and With karissa's Victory updated there
you have it you could look at that five
points out of six wow that is incredible
first half of the tournament for Karissa
yeah Bobby fiser prize required
Perfection but that's not bad I mean
five out of six that is darn good uh I
don't say that arena is winning I don't
say that I just like her position and
the fact that she's the one asking some
serious questions what's happening in
your students game beam's game well beum
uh needs to catch up with W of Victory
if she wants to stay close neck and neck
with her going into the seventh round
and she's very close to doing that
really yes she is she managed to somehow
steal a pawn from her opponent take a
look at this broad daylight theft
exactly exactly Knight to D4 Knight to
B7 everything is fine equal Pawns
nothing seems to be uh going bad for
white Rook to A5 sure I'm going to go
for the E5 Pawn Rook to A2 but now she
got shy all of a sudden after this move
Knight to C2 what she had to do is just
simply take on E5 continue but the thing
is you start seeing ghosts like this for
example check check check check and now
you know you don't really feel like
going back to E1 but if you don't you're
losing so for example maybe this is what
she was calculating after to A1 Knight
to C4 the problem is you're not catching
the pawn that's problematic right I mean
this is the worst King you can ever see
on A1 is as far as possible from these
pawns that you have to catch at some
point so she did not take on G on E5 she
shied away with the move Rook to C3 the
problem is after Knight takes B4 Knight
to C5 King to E7 I'm just picking up the
pawn I'm a pawn up sure the material is
still Limited but if you have to go into
this end game after Rook to
C2 no no no no no this is not looking
good at all what I think she's going to
do she's going to try to go for some
sort of AR Rooks end game with a move
Knight to D3 of course don't fall for
this rap that would be a nice geometry
and yes as we expected Knight to D3 was
the move played but the problem is okay
we go into this one what if I continue
hunting your pawns you have to go for
Rook G3 okay King F6 King F6 Rook C7 uh
Rook C3 I think this is a draw I think
this might actually be very close to a
draw right so you have to take on e4 not
King to F6 you have to take on e4 and
then go for H4 I think this is how you
play this position and then you have
your two pass pawns this is the question
is this a win yes and we actually have
the table based response for that this
is a win with perfect play for both
sides not only that but this Rook on e4
actually completes Black's plan quite
nicely because the king cannot get close
to the C Pawn also this Pawn is going to
be very difficult to push down the board
H4 I'm just simply going to take that
pawn on H4 so this is the perfect
position for black to continue her
expansion C5 C4 King D6 and you're
coming very very quickly um to fulfill
those desires this one is not looking
good for white I have to say I'm looking
at the position she's in trouble atusa
is in trouble beg him definitely golden
opportunity out of an end game that
looked like nothing it didn't look like
she had a better position maybe at the
beginning but it felt like atusa is
slowly outplaying her at some point it
felt Ian atusa maybe could be trying for
more it wasn't the case and right now
beim is a full Pawn up and with great
chances to maybe win this game when uh
Christian said with perfect play for
both sides I was thinking to myself I'm
playing perfectly and I'm losing this is
not what I signed up for wait a minute
perfect play for both sides okay that's
it but I like this Rook ending and the
other one I wanted to ask was this
Knight takes Rook takes uh because
you've got the table base I had this
idea not if you don't exchange some more
pawns ah the table base doesn't work yet
no that we still have you mean in The
Rook A4 yes yes because I I had it in
mind that this was a bod vinck versus no
king of you that's the winning winning
route King F6 Rook there takes and H4
and I remember there was a game of binck
and nidorf where he had the pass E Pawn
but this looks no no no no you're not
winning this one you have to put the
Rook on
G3 maybe I even go g3 at some point in
this position yes okay uh we'll take a
pause uh because Christian you have a
special guest Karissa welcome back to
the show another game with the black
pieces is another victory in a
completely Wild game and once again you
were dictating the pace from the
beginning of the game with this modern
approach I mean what was up to
that um yeah I kind of just thought I
would switch it up a bit I think a shria
usually has good prep I figured G6 would
be something something she's expecting
and I'm having a lot of luck with this
uh San ceding my dark squared Bishop so
uh yeah that was kind of my thought
process behind this choice and it was at
this point when she decided to uh not
continue being a pawn up and just allow
you to take on F4 did this decision by
her surprise you this was also uh the
first the novelty in the
position yeah so I know that F takes E5
is the best move and it kind of goes
into a better end game for uh White
after Knight D7 but I kind of thought it
was unlikely that You' find um all of
this you know like Bishop E4 here and
then there are a couple more precise
moves that whites needs to sort of keep
a solid Advantage um so I was definitely
surprised by Castle but you know since
it wasn't something I looked at I
assumed it wasn't something very good
and I think I handled it okay because
after I take on F4 all of my pieces on
the king side get out prob you were
definitely right about that one because
it gave you a good position maybe even a
winning position after a few
inaccuracies from your opponent and at
this point this move Knight to D3 was
the final move that more or less gave
you the decisive
Advantage yeah I thought um Bishop A2
was interesting I was definitely a bit
worried after she sacrificed The
Exchange and you know like my light
squares for a while seemed a bit iffy so
I felt I had to play carefully but um
yeah I managed it okay I think well
Karissa congratulations guys any
questions for uh Champion so far no it's
all going very well for you Carissa keep
up uh the good
work thank you absolutely as H Carissa
scoring incredibly well sometimes it
just goes like that you just can't
explain it whatever it is if you could
put it in a can and you could sell
it uh you make a fortune uh it's
everything's just coming up roses it's
just going sometimes the tournament is
not going well at all and sometimes just
everything works like the preparation
works even uh you kind of try to switch
lines play something different that
works as well uh by the way we have
another interesting game between uh
nazzi PID and hly very interesting
endgame yeah I was a little bit
surprised because uh on our break I
didn't think that uh this was the right
play for uh n see with this uh you know
you you you kind of want to keep the
pawn don't you on G4 and just let
whatever happens over there just happen
because once you put it on a dark Square
the bishop can always Target it it's a
little bit vulnerable and well okay uh
perhaps this is not the big fear but uh
I do uh I I did find it a surprise like
right here at at this at this point
you're almost thinking to yourself okay
I've got
these pawns
perfectly stopped right it's time for me
to play B4 and A4 and to put my guys
over there to work and I was a little
bit surprised that uh Nasi just made
these decisions so y what's your
evaluation of this position or even if
you move it a few moves back because
black is having one Pawn Advantage here
exactly well that's the problem right
it's the the pawn Advantage here without
the move King E2 I thought
B4 balanced I mean I I I I didn't think
it was going to be easy at all for black
because okay obviously if I transfer my
knight to F5 maybe I start to think you
know I'm going to be better because I'll
have a a pass Pawn but uh the way uh the
game is gone kind of feel like Alice's
chances of winning are greater now now
than they were just a few moves ago
maybe but here we go Nazi is playing out
the B4 move trying to create something
on the queen side so why did I need King
E2 and King D3 I think she wanted to
just wait and now she just changed her
mind okay well let's ask the Oracle uh
the Oracle says great for Alice yeah uh
this one seems to be winning in fact for
Alice as after the move King to F5
because but visually you look at the
position and where's the break right
right
how do you invade A4 and A6 right now
I'm wondering if Bishop to d8 works as
well or if I have to play this move A6
first let's say A6 B5 right okay B5 you
take I take right how do you win this
one you just Bop to E3 you want so maybe
at some point you're just in yeah you go
King E4 yeah and if you take if you go
uh Knight to D4 you don't take here
because that allows me to
but in fact you just simply exchange and
then go back with a king you're in time
and you're not going to be able to touch
this Pawn on D5 because I'm going to
push my Pawn down to promotion so nice
you're in the Square yeah B4 King F5 and
at some point that's zwang is going to
come in the position after A6 maybe you
can keep the pawns like this with A5 but
I don't really like this move Bishop
Bishop to A7 still again at some point
you have to make a move yeah and you're
going to uh but with a Pawn on d a file
maybe I can go Knight
D4 now you have to take you cannot take
on D4 anymore right because you're not
PA yeah right well you are but I'm
actually going to go B6 I'm not taking
this one and that's going to be pretty
much a draw okay I just stay you have to
stay to protect against promotion of the
B Pawn that's a defended passer right
big difference protect protect yes yes
but I wonder what if I just simply go
Bishop to E3
now not good not good this is not good
Bishop to E3 is imprecise because of
this move A5 and if you go A6 maybe now
Knight
D4 once again you're not in time right
clear you have to go King D7 or King D6
you cannot take it because you're not in
the square right and then I go B6 we
make a draw so still some pitfalls along
the way A6 is the best move in the
position if you go back say five moves
uh when the when the pawn was on G4 yes
was this position losing I kind of
thought it was balance this was fine
this was fine King E6 KN on5 exactly
yeah but I have a different question
actually Christian that's what she
should have done if we can move back to
the variation we had with the B5 move
after Bishop all the way here yeah yeah
so Bishop E3 sure A5 A5 A6 uh Knight
What if I start with B5 no I want to
start with B5 force you to take and then
block the bishop so B but then I go King
E5 right so B5
take oh okay take that last move back go
A6 how many pawns do I
have I have a lot I understand you're
but yeah this is this is good for me
still running still running yeah you go
here you do get my Pawn on D5 but that's
not enough I have a lot more King G6 and
you got a lot more pawns than I do you
picked this one up but I pick both of
this and then you're going to be losing
that end game so right um this one is a
win as well still again A6 is a very
important move do not allow white to go
A5 followed by B5 but uh to to Kate's
point for a moment go ahead Play Bishop
E3 a A5 uh yeah so you allow me to go A5
yeah and you go a A6 just just I go B5
just not Knight
D4 good A6 okay can I go B4 oh this is
just going to transpose just
transposition sorry I was uh and that's
not very clever I can also go Bishop to
D and then I would win the B5 pawn and
maybe yeah yes but my pawns are very
fast AG agreed agreed
obviously still lot of calculations are
required to understand this position
very very difficult position still yeah
I mean okay the engine is saying black
is winning but it's not easy exactly uh
we left it some time ago tatv uh we
thought on her 40th move she snatched
defeat from the jaws of Victory she was
that close that's
brutal that's the sports term that's how
they do it in sports it's like American
Sports the snatching defeat from the
Charles of Victory it was that Queen B3
that was the most amazing and it's that
still the case is uh Talia it looks like
Talia is playing the Right Moves now on
yeah just to let's take a look that
Queen re refresh for our viewers uh a
massive material advantage for for uh T
looking here at Knight B2 right very
strong move just loing the queen uh just
a number of moves and anything except
this one this one at first sight it
looks kind of good you're just going to
go Queen B2 trade Queens later at your
leisure you'll pick up uh this Pawn
you've got C2 on tap until you see the
move Rook takes D2 and it's a cold
shower move because the
desired C2 this queen which has never
bothered anybody on the A1 square is
suddenly it's like the Kraken it's it's
released stly white is using that E7
Pawn to launch an attack exactly and
since you can't walk walk across the
defile it's made on the spot so that
happened and uh Talia turned the game
around and suddenly we're in this
current position and well there's
nothing to be done she's an exchange
down and the pawn on C3 is coral
absolutely and it does seem like begim
has found that variation that we were
discussing which takes her into a
winning at least technically winning end
game uh but it's not over yet this is
definitely not over I was looking
through the lines probably the best way
to do it so let's go G4 just to force
this uh H takes wait we have a move I
believe we have a move it's not G3 it's
not G4 it's King F2 what is it okay King
to F2 but that doesn't that lose another
Tempo another crucial Tempo perhaps she
wants to take back on G3 with the King
makes sense okay so we should go right
C5 time to push the pawns G4 or G3 I'm
on King H G3 C4 let's continue pushing
right Rook G6 because at some point I
have to you have to get behind the pawn
right now this is already a very uh
tense situation because there's only one
move that wins in this position it's
Rook to E3 check what king to D7
apparently is a draw after the move King
to F3 and King D7 is the most natural to
stop The Rook from coming to
C6 behind the pawn and I'm trying to
understand why I guess you're just
giving up the pawn but then King to E4
and this is a draw because of C3 I take
and see2 I catch you finally but in some
ways I've almost caught your cut your
king you know like King if my king was
going C6 King C5 well King C6 I go King
D4 right King B5 King C3 oh sorry you
have to play Rook over first yeah and
then it's a draw right right right so
yeah yeah one move away right I mean if
your king is on B4 if I lose another
temp your king is on B4 that's over
right right like this also Rook to H2 is
an option as well wow still a couple of
good moves to make to get the full point
in this one but I have to say begim has
a great opportunity to do so you sorry I
I cut you off Christian you w on Roll
not the move King D7 you were about to
tell us there's one move that does win
that's right C5 G4 HG King G3 Rook to E3
is the move check first7 check first now
if you give me the pawn well you're not
getting to E4 exactly you're not
blocking my pawns and slowly I will push
you I will push my king away like for
example C3 you go here I attack you have
to stay connected to the C pawn and then
I just push my king this is an easy win
right right so after Rook to E3 the
question is what do you do after King to
G2 I keep those pawns Alik still only
one move that
wins Rook to D3 now oh this is this is
next to Impossible these These are the
subt in this one are just amazing I'm
trying to get behind the pawn with Rook
to D5 or Rook to D6 if you allow me to
so Rook C6 after Rook to D3 then I go C3
I would assume sorry sorry I'm assuming
wrong noal I'm assuming wrong no natural
oh my God but this is like so difficult
guys it's
incredible I'm trying to understand why
my guess is that because you don't have
that many squares on the C5 right you
with a Pawn on C4 right so if you go C3
I have a feeling that H4 and then I go
to C4 right and you don't pick up time
this is it and you don't have time
because now I go back but once you get
close to defend that pawn finally you
cannot catch my uh PA anymore this is a
one move situation wow one tempo situ
situation this is not easy stuff guys
and by the way she played King D6 she
did not play the move
C5 and you know I'm wondering if maybe
which is not a winning anymore two wants
to play King F3 this is not a winning
anymore this is a draw right now after
King to
D6 I have a feeling the advantage and
the draw is going to change a lot more
times until we finish this game because
all of these lines that we've seen
they're border line impossible to
actually play them precisely over the
board it's just it's not going to happen
and Christian after King dc6 can I play
King F3 because I think that was the
idea to just improve the king maybe with
the tempo but you're allowing a check
okay King E3 now the king C5 right but I
at some point you will still have to go
G3 yes but now I'm happy that the king
is on E3 kind of catching the pawn uh on
the C file necessary was the problem is
you're not um that's doesn't help you
too much because you're not pushing your
Pawn will you have to connect your uh
compensation or at least counterplay to
that push of the H Pawn Rook H and she
signaled that with a move King to F2
right because she she wants to recapture
on G3 with her King right because if you
wanted to recapture with a rook I guess
you can do it like this also right
something like this let's say King D6
King F3 yeah and now you have to get out
maybe you can still go King D5 but you
get my Pawn at some point I will get to
E3
right so you can get it if you want but
she said no no no I'm going to go King
to F2 so I want to recapture with the
King but this is the key moment right
here key moment she has to go G3 or G4
yes and the way you go I think G4 makes
the most sense by the way let's just
jump to the game of n oops G3 G3
okay that G3 required no G3 is not the
best so uh by the way Alice did and she
took on G3
bad move you don't have to take on G3
you can go C5 because G3 doesn't
actually force you to take G4 forces you
because Rook H5 and I'm picking up the
second Pawn right so you have to take on
G3 but G3 taking on G3 was not the
forced move but now it King takes G3 is
required has to be played yes yeah in
order that you have some counterplay
with H3
H4 I wanted to say that in the game
between n and uh Alice Lee Alice Lee
back down she didn't play that move A7
A6 she withdrew her King King E6 and
that might not be the move that's back
to a draw uh that that could throw away
the half point it it it does it does but
again it's still not over I would assume
B5 is going to be played right and she
probably wants to go towards the other
side King D6 is that what she she trying
to do I'm just wondering I mean because
Nasi has a g pawn and that whole idea of
being able to play Knight E5 and Knight
takes F7 I'm wondering if you can play
like B5 use you know your queen side as
a decoy to get the king the black king
away from the E5 square and Knight E5 so
I in short I'm looking at King E6 B5 I'm
assuming you have to move your king what
do you think King D6 King D6 right right
now here I have a a question for you
that I'd like to
pose is this King and pawn end game
winning for
black I think this should be right
because I can capture the Knight and go
King C7 right oh but you going to go
back to
D3 right even though I haven't yet
established a protected past Pawn okay I
will go
H4 okay so I'm waiting let's
say because I think when you play King
to D6 I'm going to play King to D4 so if
we go back just a a moment
here you go
H4 and after King D3 can a triangle here
somehow that's what I was saying yeah
you you got to get you got to reach this
position and if your Pawn was on A6 and
my Pawn were on B6 then we would be
making a draw but uh since it's not a
protected pass Pawn I think it is uh a
win so I can't play the move Knight D4
Christian how is Arena doing arena is
doing great she's doing great she's a
pawn up and she has the pair of Bishops
as well in the position yeah she's doing
great she's borderline winning at this
point this is what we have right now I
think we left it where did we leave it
somewhere around here right Knight to G4
that was the last was move yeah Knight
to F4 okay good move so far Knight to E3
Rook takes E3 and King to F2 Bishop
takes C4 King King takes E3 was not the
right move the best and maybe the only
one was Bishop to
D1 the idea is that right now your Rook
is trapped right you have to go Rook to
D3 but at least right now I have two
Bishops as well you have two Bishops I
have two Bishops I am a pawn down and
I'm still on the defensive but my
chances are greater mhm in the game
continuation after uh taking on E3
Bishop takes C2 the problem is I have
the pawn and I have the compensation as
we often like to say and I do have these
two uh pass pawns on the enf file that
once they start rolling down the board
it's going to be very difficult to stop
so I have to say I'm looking at the
position it feels like I Rea will
probably win this one she has the
momentum in this
one the momentum indeed uh lots of
decisive games going on uh in the in the
lady section but I don't think there's
any decisive games in the open and by
the way
lanir uh really uh Mishra fought his way
back and I'm thinking he's making a draw
because he's got remember it was this
Bishops of opposite color you he has
established and yeah this we were
worried about a c Pawn just running
being Unstoppable well this if you play
H5 let's say you know you win the pawn
uh hold on whose turn is it black it's
actually black turn so King D4 was
played and he can just take the pawn I
was about to say why didn't he play H5
trying to trade everything off right
could he have played
H5 oh maybe G5 Bishop
d8 because no play a moment ago we were
talking about the Scholastics chess
players how they would use the pieces
that were off the board to calculate but
usually neatly placed but this is a
unusual ual for me to see them in this
array I always put the pieces behind the
clocks just like L right out of sight
out of mind kind of thing there's like a
zoo there with the pieces right what's
up with that um surprising move King D4
allowing Bishop takes I I think it's a
draw don't get me wrong you're just
going to plant your King on this
beautiful blockading squ you'll put your
Bishop I don't care on d8 just to keep
this guy protected and I do believe it's
a draw but that's a strange thing not to
take the kingside yeah one would prefer
to just exchange those pawns instead of
instead of keeping them there okay and
by the way once again to refresh uh five
draws out of uh the six games this far
almost a mirror opposite of uh yesterday
where the decisive games were every
everywhere uh decisive games and we here
we have standing so all draws so far but
Fabiano is keeping his lead four and a
half points closely followed by Hans
nean with four points and then we have
uh weso the only person with three and a
half points but we are expecting
Dominguez to join him with three and a
half we do know that Ray Robson is in
the clubhouse with the draw Ray and
Andrew Tang Drew their game uh so two
and a half points for Ray as well so
really it's all about the lady section
and is beum how is beum doing well still
a draw but once again a pivotal moment
is coming right now so and by the way
with the clock taking down this is not
going to be easy Rook to E3 was the last
move and I'm looking at the position
it's easy in fact to play the move King
to G2 I know it seems counterintuitive
but my idea is to not allow your Rook to
get behind my Pawn on the H file King to
G2 is losing you have to actually go up
King to G4 allow The Rook to get behind
but in fact it doesn't really matter
that much much because now I'm just
simply going to start checking checking
you go to C3 I attack the E Pawn you go
to E3 I attack the C Pawn right and
we're going to get something like this I
keep checking you and I keep attacking
you once you move the Rook to try to
defend I push my Pawn right and that's
going to be the race but this is the
pivotal moment because it's easy to go
King G2 stay passive and not allow black
to go behind the pawn from a practical
perspective she needs to calculate right
now if she finds King to G4 and
following it up with that sequence then
she's probably going to make the draw
but it's easy to slip at every single
point in this end game uh by the way
just point it out to me uh boldly please
King G2 yes
and me uh yes King G2 King G2 E4 H5 now
Rook F3 and this is how you get your
because I go to F7
gotta wow this is not easy Stu by the
way E4 is not the only one but um Rook
to B3 to go behind like to go in front
like this it's not easy right E4 makes
the most sense just to go Rook F three
Rook F7 again easy move to make King to
G2 let's wait and see in fact maybe
let's uh see the players right now this
is a key Moment by the way she has only
five minutes on the clock right time
effect for both players Kate yeah I
think she's really calculating I mean
King G4 looks kind of natural to try to
support that pawn but I understand kind
of the sneaky idea of King G2 just not
allow The Rook to go to H file exactly
so you know and the thing is you just
have to make a decision within five
minutes because clock is running down
yeah so you're sitting there thinking
about this and you see King G4 Rook E1
H5 Rook H1 and you think to yourself
well if I try to go King G5 and escort
my Pawns well E4 E3 I could easily lose
you start seeing those pawns running on
the board right so you start to say you
know what I can stop The Rook from
getting behind I can go King G2 and
that's a Temptation yeah and that's the
difference when you are playing the game
compared to when you are looking at it
with your computer because once you
seeing G4 is the best move you can
always justify it and understand it but
during the game you are just just
calculating very deeply and then
comparing those final variations well
even leevon made a very good point you
have to play certain things when the
stakes are high right that's exactly
what he said I can play Sicilian in a
Blitz game any time of the day right I'm
not going to feel any pressure In the
Heat of the battle in these most
important moments that's when you have
to make those difficult decisions and to
get used to make the right difficult
decision MH well I've always thought
about it that way as well like uh that
the players uh whenever they playing in
these competitions are being tested it's
like you know they're a sword going into
the oven you know and they're getting
um really the heat of the battle and
they're focused and when you're playing
a Blitz game you just you're kind of
doing it for fun and it's like you don't
really feel these end games that well
and I think she's going to G2 she did it
King to
G2 by the way I was just looking at the
camera there of uh beum and she looked
disappointed I'm not sure if she did I'm
not sure if she did well
you yes it almost looked like a sour
face like like you know you know how it
goes when your opponent plays a good you
play a good move and you see your
opponent kind of wice it's it's
difficult to say yeah and by the way
don't ask me why Rook to B3 is winning
but not Rook to A3 Rook to A3 is a draw
Rook to A3 is a draw yeah that
was no I was thinking that looks like a
drw right go what's the idea okay here
check you're going to have to buy Sam
shanklin's book to understand oh okay
okay okay now I'm starting to sort of
understand the idea being that if the
Rook was on B on the B file you can go
to B4 with the King right ah so the
checks drive you to B4 right so by the
way remember we don't have to buy the
book ah
ah oh no Rook B7 is still a draw so you
have to go Rook to B6 stop the H Pawn
okay and right now if you give a check I
go to E4 okay
okay by the way lenier and Mishra we are
being told that they're about to shake
hands it seems like this will be the
final the sixth and final game of round
six and for Misha he's got the perfect
blockade of uh the pawns on B7 and C6
and Lenard knows it of course he's not
even playing B5 yes to and M right a
very difficult game against Lenard truly
I mean uh he made that uh very tough
decision uh to go into this uh ending as
remember he had the whole night E3 and
could have sacrificed a rook that's a
big save for Vish no question and I have
to say kind of a big Miss for lener I he
had a big opportunity to win
cuz with this win lanir would have uh
tied for second um plus two with plus
two right behind Fabby half a point
behind Fabby
yeah by the way we kind of just kind of
glided by there but uh for Sam
Sean uh he came into today's game he's
playing against a guy who just won three
in a
row like excuse me you know that's very
very serious Sam seon has the black
pieces and you almost feel like a deer
in the headlights like uhoh you know am
I going to be the fourth victim yeah and
playing the leader of the tournament
that's always difficult there's this
extra Ed pressure on you he stopped him
cold I mean he just really shut uh Fabby
down today I think it was an impressive
draw yes absolutely very good opening
knowledge Sam seon showcase and even
after he got surprised that move Queen
to C2 in the opening fa still knew what
he's doing he reacted very very well to
that yeah so Kos to him and even after
that the middle game you know we're
seeing the moves it seems easy right but
there were a lot of decisions to be made
along the way and there were not easy
decisions do you go H5 do you try to
provoke H4 do you get the Knight back
via f8 then to E6 or maybe I try to keep
the Knight around the king to try to go
G5 and play for an advantage should I
play Knight takes decisions Knight takes
C3 she he made the right decisions and
you know he defended very well against
uh Fabiano a player that's in tremendous
shape exactly so uh by the way we're
seeing all the draws this will be our
sixth and final uh
game and all games done in the men
section all draws yeah and the women
have two results uh two decisive games
with four going um ongoing Arena CR
uh she had the two Bishops and an extra
Pawn we thought that she would be
winning let's see if she has made more
progress I like this bishop D1 move
isn't that it forces you to kind of
capture that Bishop right and then I'm
happy to have a dark Square Bishop so I
can Target those pawns on the queen side
truly that's a nice one now these pawns
I'll always have Bishop A7 so the King
has to kind of be a little bit honest
not running to E4 and the F7 E6 pawns
they're just they going to start run
yeah they're running now
mhm and
uh this is
uh a tsuji a domination of the knight uh
it's not allowing King D3 right so the
bishop can again get to the B2 square
and attack the pawns yes and in the
meanwhile the king will improve itself
uh King can um go to to a D5 and so the
whole E6 e E5 E4 it looks like this one
is all
Arena and uh let's take a look at naz's
game against Alice we had that again the
bishop and uh Knight end game as well
okay are they trans no I mean we were
looking at positions where the King was
on F5 here it's very clear that Alice is
trying to make a beline to the B4 Pawn
King C6 B5
on her agenda looks good but black has
to be careful right because King C6 runs
into Knight E55 what we mentioned before
okay still not that easy but white has
to make a move right so moving back King
to E2 right as an
option H okay got a qu no F6 you're
going to go G6 yes you have to too I
think so
right what about locking the bishop with
D4 and King D5 I know it looks a bit
ugly but I'm improving my king yeah but
wow wow wow wow just a second king D3 so
here King D5 B5 takes A6 King C6 okay so
now the question
is um who's first it's probably still
black F3 you have to go F3 G62 wait can
I go F2 and D3 oh yes yes oh yes it's
probably
exactly oh dear got me just one tempo
but it was
enough and with all of the results from
the open section completed here's our
standings after six complete rounds so
on the open section Fabiano Carana four
and a half points out of six closely
followed by Hans nean four points and
then a two-way tie again for the third
place Wesley saw and lenar Dominguez
with three and a half points and then we
see again three players uh with three
points so they close to each other yeah
I see the favorites doing very well I
see Hans Neeman out performing but I see
one leavon aronian really
underperforming at this um well I want
to say halfway mark so leavon really has
to well I mean he's got to go all in in
his next games because fabbi is looking
Regal and in the ladies is beum catching
Carissa I'm not sure I still don't know
because she played Rook A3 okay Rook A3
not Rook a dra yes but again there's a a
rook to A3 look it makes so much sense
to go Rook A3 as far as possible right
this is what we're being told in this
type of Rook end games H5 Rook to A6 and
now what atusa has to do is just give
some chots not easy not I know cuz
you're driving the king to a super go to
G3 unfortunately after Rook to
D6 wow or Rook to E6 the only two moves
that in fact win this position but again
it's all about the checks how do you
hide you don't actually have ways to
hide
anymore right now you can go C5 I'll
give you another check you can go to B4
I'll give you another check right I'll
go to A3 let's say you'll go to A3 okay
now I go King F3 C3 C3 I'm so eager to
push my pawn and I have to go King E2
oh King E2 I was not calculating that I
was calculating Rook C8 King
E2 King E2 you want to go in front of
the pawn and if I play Rook D6 you're
going to go
H6 no now I go H6 I'll force you to let
me go to that D1 Square oh my goodness
this is so difficult oh all right
look from a practical perspective this
feels almost impossible to I don't know
there are just so many nuances that
they're so on I play King G3 nine out of
10 times to be honest I'm looking at
this position I'm not giving checks
right I'm not trying to get your king
closer to the promotion of your pawns
I'm just trying to push my own Pawn so I
go King to G3 and I do understand Rook
E6 Rook D6 is a hard one for for me to
Fathom uh Rook E6 getting the Rook
behind the pawn and going E4 E3 Rook D6
just not have any
checks and then you just go King D4 and
push your
Pawn not easy very very difficult very
difficult to my eyes and uh in the game
by the way G3 I think it's on the board
no never mind it's not yet on the board
she's down to her last two minutes I oh
no yeah she's about to play is about to
make King F3 okay makes makes some sense
also aome CU it's controlling the E4
square and planning probably to give
check from behind and guess what there's
only one winning move now Rook D6 Rook
D6 is the only
move because after King
E3 Rook H6 maybe I mean you just went
Rook D6 I put my king in front of the
pawn so now you cannot touch the pawn
anymore uh Rook H6 right so King d36
checks I hide on C3 oh come on this is
too difficult ridiculous are you kidding
me so here we have the current position
only move Rook D6 only move only move
the win then you think to yourself okay
I'm really so clever I put the King on
E3 so I'm in front of the pawn this
guy's going nowhere this guy's no going
now over now Rook H6 because a moment
ago I could tag the pawn or defend it
and then after check King
C5 check just go through B4
yeah and you hide in front of the pawn
when you capture this Pawn you're
defending E5 as well and even if you are
not you're still winning that so I so
from the current position King E3 is
actually just a loser I have to I have
to have this move King G4 in my pocket
but that's the thing with this move King
to F3 you're also looking at ideas of
King to G4 right sure how easy it is for
uh begim to lose lose
basically visually at least a move with
Rook D6 and not play King D4 in this
position no that's very hard King D4 is
the most natural move of course it is
just go forward after King F3 King I
mean this move Rook D6 is you know
trying to make sense of it but King D4
yeah but
then you you you could start to warm up
to why you might want to play like this
uh Rook check and Rook to D5 so that you
could play King E4 take this Pawn or
King G4 to protect this Pawn I can see
why you might end up finding Rook D6 but
you need the time uh to come to this
conclusion by the way guys Arena
blundered the victory yes what and right
now Ru Yang can just simply go Knight
D4 what Knight D4 check is going to be a
draw because I'm just not allowing you
to push the pawns forward and I will
have King on E5 that's right
holy what because you have to capture
the Knight after Knight otherwise I take
on B5 yes you don't want to see that oh
my goodness you take the Knight this is
in fact not such a difficult King E3 she
didn't sense the moment that it was a
drawn ending so many back and forth by
the way so King D5 we are expecting now
but King D5 I go kn4 ch right that's
another but then I can go King
C4 and at least you don't take that you
take my E6 PA I take on D6 you take on
B4 I go C6 and I take your piece next oh
well wait a minute just a second king E3
we're looking at King D5 everyone then
Knight F4 check yes and we're suggesting
that Bishop takes F4 is a drawn right uh
King and pawn end game we're playing for
the win King C4 Knight takes E6 uh
Christian says uh White can win a a
piece by pushing her pawn and that is
true but wait a minute I've got a pass B
Pawn how are you going to
stop this
peski I'm going to go B4
Christian maybe I don't stop the
pish if you don't stop the peski all
right so Knight E6 now oh I thought I
like that kn six or okay Knight E6
because after B3 I go King D2 that's
right that was my plan
ah keeping your king it's nice and my
idea is to go after let's say King D5
just Knight F4 Knight G6 and sacrifice
the Knight for the last few points yes
precisely maybe I get adventurers and
even try to win somehow yes but these
end games there are so complicated I
mean we see Nazi against Alice atusa
against B here ruang against Arena but
this is a crucial moment right for arena
too can't she do can she
avoid uh Le let's say just at this
moment can I play I don't know Bishop B8
just throwing it out there so that I can
play now I go Knight D4 oh of course
excuse me that's my sort of threat
agreed no
94 is what I'm afraid of that was why I
played King D5 sorry but for some reason
ruang doesn't want to play night D4 so
maybe uh we can just play like Bishop at
some point she will have to do it at
some point she will be forced to do it
so like a move like Bishop F6 if you
play Knight here and I go Bishop here
maybe you will end up I'm not even sure
pushing E5 yeah that's the whole point
Knight for Bishop G5 yeah ah is that
winning be problematic yeah because
that's
a so right so she has has played Bishop
F6 so once again Knight D4 check as a
draw she uh Ruan can play Knight D4
check Force the trade get into a king
and Pon in game that's
drawn
wow and we're going to pause our
analysis because we have a guest
Christian over to you Mishra difficult
game yesterday another very difficult
game today but the result was that
definitely in your uh favor in this one
because you managed to save an
incredibly difficult position against
one of the best players on the planet
how are you feeling right
now yeah it feels nice to save this game
the last two games I like I had draws in
both of them just I had no time right
that was one thing I tried to I tried to
fix today I tried to keep more time on
the clock absolutely and of course I
there's I'm pretty sure yeah at some
point he was winning like after Queen
takes C5 and so on but it it kind of
shows that there's so much scope of
improvement at all levels it was all
about this moment at this point when you
guys were in this melee tactical melee
at this point and you played Bishop to
F4 we were a bit puzzled about this
decision because Queen to F5 made a lot
of sense when you played Bishop to F4
Queen to F5 was definitely on your radar
did you calculate Queen to G4 was that
it was that your plan all along
yeah Queen G4 was one idea and Knight D2
was another main idea otherwise of
course there's no point of this yeah but
I thought the issue there was one or two
issues with this I think Bishop E6 was
the main issue here mhm because after
Bishop E6 I just don't have I actually
don't have a move if I go Bishop G3 or
H2 he goes Queen C2 if I go Bishop uh
Bishop E3 he has Queen takes C5 Knight
F3 Queen E4 Knight D2 Queen C2 Bishop
takes B6 Rook takes D2 and I thought
like uh Queen E1 Queen takes
B2 and this looked quite difficult to
play because now okay Bish A5 Rook Rook
F2 is hanging and Rook B Rook B1 he has
Queen
C3
yes and you're losing this one as well
this one is not looking good so you
decided on Queen G So based on that uh
yeah Queen G4 actually when I played
Bishop 4 at first I I saw of course I
saw Queen F5 Queen G4 and here there's
basically two choices for black queen C2
and queen takes G4 yeah now Queen takes
Queen C2 my original idea was to go
Knight E3 Queen takes B2 Bishop takes H6
that's what we thought as well
yes yeah yeah if this works of course I
would play this but the issue is Queen
takes A1 check King H2 and
now the the main point of this position
is at the automatic move G6 fails to
Queen H4 that's right and there's mid
yes so based on this okay like I I of
course I had to check this out more but
the thing is black has King f8 instead
of G6 m mhm yeah very nicely calculated
King to f8 Queen takes G7 and now you go
King to E8 Queen takes G7 King E8 and
now here maybe you can try C4 that's
right like I'm not like it's one idea is
now you're turning Queen h8 check King
D7 E6 but I think here maybe black can
go uh maybe but Queen D4 is one can move
but Queen D4 you have Knight F5 like
maybe this maybe this somehow works but
I don't I don't believe in this at all
it was Queen to A3 at this point I think
the very unpleasant move the face ah ah
yes this is a nice move you just stop
stop all counterplay and this I mean
this has to be winning for black yeah
yeah no absolutely and uh well you
decided to go for Rook to F1 and you got
to this
position and then how did you feel about
your chances at this point because to
our eyes it looked very
very bad C5 C4 was coming very quickly
and we didn't see a good way for you to
stop it
yeah it looks quite Grim for white
because the queen on H4 it actually just
has no squares right other than E7
there's like I I don't think there's a
single Square I can move it I can move
the queen without hanging it I think uh
maybe Rook D3
is or is he played Bishop B6 right at
some point instead of yes I think he
should have maybe kept the bishop on B3
I think C5 was maybe perhaps more
precise here C5 C4 mhm mhm C5 C4 and but
still okay it's not it's not too easy
because somewhere the whole point of
this P stage6 was that now there's
always some Perpetual like you can never
play say Rook D3 in piece because maybe
somewhere I have Queen C8 check yeah
yeah without the that's a defensive
piece as well it protects your uh King
very
nicely yes and here maybe I can go H4 C4
H5 but okay like this should be quite
lost yeah and then you guys he allowed
you to uh enter this end game after the
exchange of the Rooks maybe a bit
prematurely for him did you understand
that this position is just
equal yeah actually I think I what I
spoke to him after the game I think he
he said F6 he missed like F3 because
after F6 F3 okay I get my queen on H4
finally gets some more breathing space
and now like Rook E1 is all already a
threat and now the thing is since he's
played F6 his King is also going to be
quite weak and and now the queen side is
also this bishop on is a really good
piece because now I just it kind of like
shuts down the queen side for now yeah
and if I ever get Rook E1 like now next
move Bishop A5 will be a threat right
due to the hanging Bishop on E6 yeah so
I think already around F3 I was kind of
getting a little bit more optimistic
like about my drawing chances yeah and
yeah this opposite card Bishop ending I
thought it might be a bit tricky but I
felt like in general it should be a draw
there's kind of two ways I can try to
hold this one idea is what to do what I
did in the game and bring the king to
the king side and start are pushing pots
the other idea is try to keep the King
on D4 and hold it like that I think the
one you did was pretty
practical yes because another issue is
that okay you put the King on D4 you
have to keep thinking every move yeah no
like here okay you you you kind of get a
force line and this is quite drawn but
the thing is uh like if I do if I keep
the King on D4 and stay somehow my king
side gets frozen it might seem like it's
for example say like in the in the worst
of worst possible scenarios if I have to
go F4 G3 H4 mhm I think that this might
just be lost because uh with the pawns
on say like G6 F5 black can keep the
King on D6 and say my king will be on B4
or D4 he can keep if my king is on D4 he
just has to cover the C4 square
and too many pawns on the board
basically and at some point yes you will
get in trouble no I think you took the
right decision very good practical
decisions along the way it wasn't easy
but I have to say I was impressed with
your defense so congratulations go get
some rest don't do too much training
after a 5 hour game don't do too much
training and we'll see you tomorrow it
was an honor to play against a legend
like Dominguez I've I've grown up
watching his games and he's simply one
of the best players in the world
absolutely absolutely congratulations M
seriously uh a very very big result uh
difficult opponent and it was a it was
very very impressive uh defense indeed
uh Alice Lee is uh actually she's
winning now at this ending as uh she
managed to transfer the king to the
queen side and exactly now she started
just grabbing the PA exactly Bishop B
Bishop takes B4 Bishop takes A5 as on
her her agenda and then she can always
there you go and then she can always
like if you get if pardon me if Nasi was
to get the Knight into the F7 Square you
can always uh sacrifice uh the bishop
and here she goes F2 as well gotta play
King E2 Bishop to D Bishop to E1 the
Knight is not going to uh
stop from marching too far away exactly
I know we talked about Alice starting
kind of slowly but if she manages to win
this is her third win in a row W
exactly and
uh Fabby is looking good on his uh three
win run uh Alis Le will be bouncing back
in the byway transposition in the Talia
cantes game against uh tatf Abraham they
have rukan game now what but I believe
is going to be keeping two extra pawns
there's been more ups and downs and and
turns in this game than I can possibly
fathom
but if you move it back there was a
really nice yeah this position T was
trying to kind of trap the king because
with the Knight there are some some
Forks exactly so the desirable King to
B4 for example one of your forks check
and she ended up playing King D4 check
and King
check and you kind of have to give up
The Rook but you know you recapture this
Knight on F4 with check that's the point
and it's really important move Rook F5
so you keep defending Pawn on F3 and you
recapture that on e4 that's a really
really nasty intereso there and probably
you can return the favor suddenly too as
well with a move like King B4 and uh
that's a nice intereso for white I like
that because if you captur the pawn on
A4 you're right black can capture on G4
yep and then give a check and recapture
that and that would be a draw oh my I
didn't realize I I I was being flipping
but I I didn't realize that Precision
was actually being required as well so
King B4 is uh a key move and Talia is
taking time she's not immediately
recapturing that pawn she she's less
than minute on the clock but she's
thinking I think she is considering this
King B before move I'm sure she'll find
it as well
because the moment you see King takes A4
HG and Rook C4 you say well like how can
I prevent my opponent from doing that
but the question is what is what is
different after okay King B4 very well
so if I go Rook D3 okay Rook D3 keeping
the same threat let me take a pawn you
will I will take the pawn as well ah no
you're going to give me a check I okay
getting tired here here and I I thought
oh now I'm winning two pawns not not
quite check sorry just second maybe you
are maybe you are okay take on Rook E3
you do like my decision take on H5 okay
okay and now Rook
C5 ah Rook C5 so uh just lassoing the
pawn this way right so this seems to be
winning that's nice that's very very
very very
simple
nice okay bag game seems to be winning
right now as well okay well huge game
going on there let's switch to atusa
what this is winning they should be
winning right just a second yeah because
the king can get to
E2 she had an easy draw well easy for us
to say that um instead of Rook to C8
just go behind on h8 defend the
pawn and then and push the pawn to H7
yes and then your king can never move
and allow a a check yeah so you go King
E2 H6 E3 H7 and now that's it more or
less there's no more mov you go to E1 I
go to E8 I pick up the E4 um E3 pawn and
that's it exactly so this would have
been the way to to make a draw to make
the draw she played Rook C8 but this is
just a Los going to get into Lucina
position right right well she took the
pawn on
H5 Rook takes
H5 Rook takes C4 King F3 Rook went back
to C8
aspiring for oops excuse me King to D2
to E1 King immediately to E2 and this is
a win also Talia just blundered guys no
Rook to E3 she played Rook to
G5 what and now she took on F3 a pawn
what
what what is this guys I think it's
takes H4 that's it it's just uh
tiredness oh my goodness so she did not
spot that idea with to C5 but why would
you
Evers right now right but why would you
play G4 takes H5 at
all we see a lot of blonders Arena
to five hours truly and they are getting
into like very important decision making
now okay but wait a minute is that pawn
running that pawn is definitely running
now the question is oh you just go
Knight D4 four next move you pick up the
pawn on B5 and then you get to F3 and
that's it that's a bad Bishop so you can
never wow you can never promote that
pawn so you don't actually go for the
pawn you don't actually go for the
bishop right so with C6 C7 so for
example Bishop here you don't try to
pick up the bishop on the contrary it
you try to sacrifice your knight for the
pawn so that your king
quickly yepop back to H
one wow I like that sound
effects well in his b Bob Ross art you
you're you're supposed to
go you make a a whoosing sound Alice Lee
by the way has won her third game in a
row that's that's a good streak that's a
very good streak very good streak you
can ask Fabby about
it as the final moves were she she did
get the bishop to E1 as we we we saw
yeah just at the very end here so Knight
E5 and Bishop
E1 and then F and this is what
happened King is getting to
C2 and it's a
girl so Alice wow uh well it just at the
end some some blunders as you know
tiredness Creeps in after the the fifth
six hours play this was bad but and by
the way we see Knight D4 being played by
ruang let me jump to that game um and
she understood that she can run back
with the
King
wow I'm just but this was in fact very
important not to take on
B5 after first of all yeah if you take
on B5 I just go H2 but let's say you
take on B5 and now you go King F3 I
still go Bishop to E1 and you stopped me
from getting my I stop you from yes yes
nice so yeah no very nicely uh done
spotted there by
rang to go King F2 King F2 and in case
of Bishop H2 MH then King then I go
C6 use my my my my my Pawn as a
distractor right King F2 is King all she
has to do is get her King to H1 and it's
the promised land of a draw so it's
Alice and it seems like beg him that
will win will be our last Victors of
today's round what a game this was back
and forth between these two uh ladies I
have to
say I can't even imagine their emotional
states after this I mean it's a roller
coaster right this game knows she was
winning winning completely she was
completely lost and theia is the same
situation she knows she was completely
losing then winning
and then finally ended up in the draw
okay but this
one seems like begim knows how to do it
just get the king to E1 push the pawn
all the way to
E2 give a check do the bridge yeah
that's
it
yeah that's an important uh
Victory and
uh okay here's the here's the H the the
the history Buffs so which year did
Lucena write the
book uh for the Lucena position that
this Rook ending is a win I have no
idea coach you got this sure you got
this easy no I I don't no I don't I have
no idea all right no I'm trying to
decide whether was like 1488 or 1512
I've got different dates in my mind uh
I'm not sure myself I just thought that
was
[Laughter]
uh well I I I remember aluli the
Magnificent from the uh you're good
buddy the Islamic uh period where they
had the uh when they were the best chess
players in the world and I I remember
this was fantastic Dr John and you know
he was very very pleased he had just
three-year project he gives me his
pondless endings he said yes sir here's
the perfect chess book I like what says
everything in this book The an analysis
is perfect
everything computer checked all the
variations are sound I was like amazed
so I opened up the book and it was like
the first uh diagram was Arab manuscript
87 eth Century Rook a knight versus Rook
uh winning MH and it was correct oh wow
they had worked it out from the 8th
century and it was a manuscript uh King
E1 and uh unfortunately for atusa she's
going to have to give up her Rook for
the pawn Rook takes Rook uh D7 check and
the King will be forced to step into a
skure and be him I think that's it
keeping keeping the pace keeping the
pace not easy with Carissa who's winning
so many games five out of six and there
you go last attempt the last trick don't
go E1 Queen don't get Hasty with your
promotion just give a check first right
stop think yeah Rook check that's it
yep because now King to E3 will be met
by E1 Queen that's what a back and forth
Affair in this one as well I mean that
game another one yes draw lost draw lost
draw lost and that leaves us with our
final game and it's the famous bishop
and pawn wrong color
Bishop uh and it's a dead draw
yeah yeah ruang is just going to play
King H1 King G1 King H2 King H2 King
H1 chess is not fair not fair at all but
this is a draw but it is I think we're
going to see a stalemate King F2 now H2
I would play
H2 you would play H2 I I I go for H2 yes
arena is just still kind of like a child
shock
yes AG you said it good call well thank
you you should be a professional
commentator I try I what are you doing
wasting your talents on uh
and SL missou
students and we have young Alice Lee in
studio Christian take it away Alice uh
another round another Victory that's a
hatrick for you after a slow start first
of all congratulations your emotions
right
now um yeah I'm very happy with this
game especially since I feel like um out
of the opening I didn't really get much
and I was okay with the draw uh so I
definitely like winning with a really a
great for me um and yeah because I defin
it definitely was like she was the one
who was like kind of slightly pushing um
but then something happened and I
thought then it became like easier for
me to play um and it was really nice to
be able to win at what point did you
feel like things are getting easier for
you to
play um so I would say uh so when she
played like Bishop takes uh D or when
she took my um one of my Min pieces uh
and then she allowed me to like take her
Bishop back instead of taking her KN it
was like Bishop takes D4 I don't know it
was around uh somewhere around
here take take Bishop takes F6 once you
got the two
Bishops yeah okay so uh after uh Bishop
F3 Bishop A5 and she took my Bishop um I
thought because if she played Knight C4
I'd probably play like Rook C8 and just
go I was putting that to then like uh uh
I mean I was I didn't have to
immediately take the night but I thought
then at some point it probably would end
up taking the night so it just be uh a
draw
after yeah after she play Bishop takes
D5 I'm assuming it probably it still
probably had to be a draw um but I
thought then it became easier for me
because my work gets active and yeah so
here I knew like this this I went upon
um but of course it's very hard for her
to play uh and defend this endan and
eventually in time trouble I think
um she made a few mistakes it wasn't
easy but you managed to grind her down
in this one congratulations Alice uh big
big game big streak for uh you and it
seems like things are finally working
your way once again in this tournament
great to see you in great
shape thank you see you tomorrow
AB W congratulations as well Alis we put
the fishing touches on this round six
very strange round uh no results in the
open section and uh wow Mishra saving
that position I'm still rather stunned
and so many difficult end games in the
women's section exactly up and down
positions draw it's it's winning it's
draw it's winning uh this position as
Alice was talking and she was saying to
with the audience she felt even though
she had won this Pawn on F2 she thought
the position was still a draw and I
think she's right I'm a little bit
stunned that Nasi exactly here in this
position didn't just aspire to put her
Knight on um on F5 right away just to
stunt this move F5 she kind of
allowed
uh Alice to get uh use of her
pawns as we were about and this was what
I I meant to say that when Alice could
use her pawns then the chance of Victory
and she ran away with it she won the
game very impressive and determined
young lady uh Christian oh yeah and to
start off so slowly with two losses in
the first three rounds and then turn
things completely around 180 I mean
that's truly impressive I have to say
I'm very impressed with her composure
during these games during these
difficult moments because she hasn't had
a lot of difficult moments throughout
her chess career things have been pretty
smooth for herent right what a great
year she's having up until rounds one
two three in exactly but she was unfaced
after that she managed to get herself
back up and right now with a hattrick
she's back in contention despite the the
fact that Karissa and begim are trying
to run away with the event but still you
see Arena one point and she's still
behind both of them and she still has to
play beg him at one point in the
tournament and Alice Lee is catching
fire exactly also Anna zansi by the way
she's on three and a half there
she she's in the discussion Hans nean
still doing incredibly well uh four out
of six uh he didn't come in as let's say
the top half of the draw now you talk to
Hans he says he's the big favorite but
that's a different discussion we're
having uh Kate who else is in that uh
group oh oh we're about to see our well
okay okay all right right all right I
you guys are them okay look you had no
choice I mean ban will will beat you if
you did uh say your student was going to
win the event that's probably
true that's probably true and Saina was
doing very well well I cannot believe
neither of you picked the Karissa this
is yeah a shame well and the only reason
you were forced to pick Neeman as a
podcaster of course you wanted to go
with your buddy it's B we're doing
pretty well right look that's that's
professional commentary right there it's
K and uh just as uh we're waiting for
beum to join us I I just wanted to say
that once again it was a very strange
day especially when compared to
yesterday oh yeah 10 victories out of 12
games and then suddenly it was like in
the in the open in the open section all
draws the open section it was very
different than what we've seen right
yesterday right but yesterday was an
anomaly in my op truly like everybody
somehow wanted to win everybody was
getting imbalanced positions and making
mistakes we don't see that very often
right it wasn't anomal their back to the
usual situation and they still are
getting a lot of uh opportunities sure
ler what amazing uh game he played today
with the black pieces I mean to get a
winning position with the black pieces
is never especially against a prepared
opponent such as Mishra but
unfortunately for him it just wasn't
meant to be he missed a bit at a great
moment agreed but for me also I just
want to say look I mean love him or hate
him hats off to Hans Neeman uh he didn't
want to make a draw early he kept
playing he kept fighting okay the game
ended in a draw but it wasn't because he
was trying to make a peaceful result
with the black pieces from luk one he
really tried he tried whatever whatever
he could but it just wasn't there and
one person we can also mention is Sam
Shanklin he got another rook and game
another Pawn down but technical rook and
game and this time he managed to make a
draw exactly something like five draw
five Rook endings out of the six games
he's played Sam's been amazing there's a
tendency for him right he's getting
drawn to the those Rook end games maybe
after you write the book you kind of
start looking for the type of positions
that you've analyzed you you spent three
years writing a work component game book
suddenly every ending you play is a rook
ending but we have special guests in
studio we do our last Victor of the day
is with us begim welcome back to the
show
congratulations this was a difficult
game uh it didn't seem like it's going
your way out of the opening at least not
more than a draw it seems like you did
equalize with the black pieces but in
the end game you tried and pushed and
pushed and finally it paid off how are
you feeling right now
hi guys thank you so much uh I'm a bit
tired I did expect a long game because
uh she plays E4 E5 this uh Bishop like
you know Spanish and then C4 lines is
also possible so I didn't expect much I
just tried to uh get a game basically
and then have a long game but I didn't
expect it going to be that long and of
course she was totally fine even in the
middle game but she she started to burn
a lot of time and when she had time
trouble I I think she just misevaluated
the position I thought she missed night
King D7 King D6 idea after that she
should be very careful and after the
time uh King D7 King D6 at move 34 as we
were getting close to the second time
control yeah right I think she she
thought it's going to be very
comfortable draw but suddenly my
position is uh slightly better and I can
just push I can uh play G5 H4 and then
go back with the Rook it's just going to
be like forever uh torture for her and
it was at this moment after Knight to C2
where she should have taken your Pawn
but in sh I was very upset about it yeah
I was very upset about it I I felt like
I should be winning I thought I I I I
will be winning after Rook C5 and after
she played Rook C5 I started to
calculate and I didn't didn't really see
anything Knight E3 King E1 and now she
has to go back to E1 and perhaps that
was the move that she didn't like making
exactly because if she does go to C1 you
have Rook to A1 and this is in fact a
win for
you yeah I saw that one like King she
needs to hold the King on E1 and
suddenly I just don't have anything
that's right and I I said like it's okay
it anyways Knight C2 is my best try and
she played Rook C3 now I'm pushing again
I have a pawn not probably rook and game
at some point it was it was a draw even
instead of King E3 King King G5 was a
better try but she just had no time at
that point this uh Rook end game was uh
very very difficult and we were looking
at the best moves we couldn't understand
it with the help of the engine um so I
don't blame you for missing a couple of
things here and there for example at
this point Rook to A3 was not the right
move Rook to B3 was uh the win so that
you hide the King on the B file whenever
she starts giving you
checks I mean this type of details
definitely not easy to understand King
to F3 once again winning with this move
Rook to D6 but you play the move E4 and
you mentioned yeah exactly that's why I
was thinking actually at this point I
stopped a little bit I felt like E4 and
Rook uh D6 are good options I felt like
Rook D6 is winning yes for some reason I
just had the feeling
H but my uh brain is you know thinking
and E4 seems logical position I just
yeah exactly I just had a feeling Rook
D6 she doesn't have any checks she needs
to move the king and I'm winning a
winning a Tempo that's right somehow and
then King G4 E4 is winning so I thought
there's no difference and then I started
to realize that there is a huge
difference actually in between so it's
just my pawns are running here and as
you were mentioning uh King to G5 was in
fact also a very good move for her
instead of King to E3 yeah uh she did
play King to E3 and still it wasn't
easy check
check and now after King to E3 she had
this final opportunity to make the draw
with Rook to h8 did you spot this one
it's ridiculous no you want to go H6
H7 yeah just I see that yeah I I thought
it's it's a good idea actually for her
to play that I wasn't sure if I'm
queening or not I thought okay she has
time trouble if she finds everything
right what can I do like yeah uh so I
just thought it's my just a final try
and it paid off I saw that she has this
idea yeah and it paid off because she
played I believe that this this end game
should be should be a draw but I
couldn't figure out how I I I can see
the options she can see the options but
it's just so hard to calculate and
evaluate the position maybe with a few
hours on the clock it would be uh easier
with just a couple of seconds never easy
well begging congratulations once again
you're keeping Pace with Karissa in this
one she is not letting go you're not
letting go this is going to be a race to
the Finish Line congratulations we'll
see you tomorrow thank you guys
absolutely our congratulations as well B
is uh you know five out of six I mean
these are Monster scores I mean those
that was very very impressive again you
know the tenacity of Fabby has been
amazing but also the two ladies scoring
five out of six you really have to be
determined oh yeah Christian you know
you come on you win three games You're
So Satisfied with yourself you give
another draw it's easy no no no no to
keep your the accelerator this is not an
open tournament you're not getting easy
uh games any of the rounds right you're
playing the best chess players in the
United States every single Round And as
you guys mentioned to win five games out
of six that's absolutely an incredible
score for both of these ladies Fabiano
and Hans also having great events up to
this point a lot of top curvy situations
and I'm sure we're going to see way more
in the upcoming rounds as the stakes are
getting higher and higher and we're
going to see the nerves play in crucial
role in the next few rounds I cannot
wait to call all the action exactly
Christian thank you and uh some
tiredness at the end because we did see
some mistakes inevitable they're going
to creep up you play five six hour game
and you just wow but it's kind of fun
for us to see like how the games are up
and down because people sometimes think
like okay you have an advantage you push
for it you win it's never that simple no
it's really really way more difficult
than that absolutely Kate wonderful
calling reaction with you thank you
everyone uh for joining us sharing your
day with us tell your friends where
you're hanging out make this the best
show show of Chess that it C possibly
can be and in the meanwhile a good night
we'll see you all tomorrow see you
[Music]
tomorrow
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited